FIRST THAT COMMITTEE OF THE NEW
YEAR. AND YET COMMITTEE YEAH
HIGHER.
WE HAVE YOU HAVE A CASES OUR
FIRST FOR. ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
TO THIS AT THIS OF COURSE IS A
JOINT HEARING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE.
ON EDUCATION FINANCE
ON CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
IT CERTAINLY IMPORTANT TOPIC
THAT WE HAD A HEARING ABOUT
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WANTED TO
REVISIT THE ISSUE.
TODAY WE ALSO MAY BE JOINED
LATER BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
WHO WHO'S CHAIRING THAT SIMPLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE MASTER
PLANTS ARE REALLY WERE OFF ALL
THREE OF US ARE LOOKING AT THIS
THAT SAME ISSUE.
AND YOU KNOW I THE ASSEMBLY HAS
LONG CHAMPIONED INCREASING
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION AND
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS IN LARGE
PART BECAUSE THE EFFORTS THAT WE
PUSHED WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO. HAD
ABOUT THIRTEEN THOUSAND MORE
SLOTS IN THE UC SYSTEM. OVER
FORTY THOUSAND ENROLLMENT SLOTS
FOR CSU AND EARLY EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND THAT SLOTS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUT PEACE
BESIDES ALL THIS AND THAT.
BOOMING ECONOMY IN THE
INCREASED.
BUDGET REVENUES WE KNOW THIS IS
NOT ENOUGH.
AND IT REALLY IS IS SOMEWHAT
DAUNTING WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PP
I SEE NUMBERS.
AS WELL AS THE.
CALIFORNIA COMPETES ANALYSIS
WHICH SHOWS MANY NEW ANYWHERE
BETWEEN ONE AND TWO MILLION MORE
GRADUATES INDIVIDUALS WITH
CERTIFICATES IN THE NEXT.
THAT TEN FIFTEEN YEARS SO THESE
ARE REALLY AMBITIOUS TARGETS.
AND TO ACHIEVE THAT'S GONNA TAKE
US SOME DRAMATIC.
WORK IN A HERCULEAN EFFORT ON
OUR PART TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT.
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW THINK OUTSIDE
THE BOX WHERE AS A HOW TO GET
PEOPLE TO. GRADUATE A SHORTER
PERIOD OF TIME HOW CAN WE THINK
ABOUT COLLEGE ANY MORE EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE.
A MANNER BUT TO DO THIS WE NEED
A PLAN AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT HERE TODAY AND
FOCUSING ON THE PLANET A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE.
AND THE SEGMENTS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN'T DO IT ALONE WE
CAN'T PUT. YOU KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE THAT KIND OF MONEY TO PUT
THE TABLE. UNFORTUNATELY AND.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT I KNOW THE
SEGMENTS HAVE SOME IDEAS AND WE
CAN BE WORKING ON THIS TOGETHER.
HOW WE LOOK AT CERTAINLY I'M A
CAPITAL OUTLAY ISSUES IN
FACILITIES BUT ALSO ABOUT
GRADUATION INITIATIVES THAT
TECHNOLOGY ENABLE TOUCHING AS
WELL? AND DEATH FOCUSING ON AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY THAT
PUSHES FORWARD BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT.
ARE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY NEEDS
THIS MORE GRADUATES AND
INDIVIDUALS IF THEY WANT TO HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL. CAREER IN LIFE AND
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY WE KNOW
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION CERTAINLY
IS THE TICKET SO THAT WE THAT WE
HAVE A. UP PACKED AGENDA TODAY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO BE OUR
CONVERSATION TURNED OVER TO OUR
WE KNOW THAT THE STATE IS
FACING A SHORTFALL OF OVER ONE
MILLION DEGREE HOLDERS. AND OVER
TWO MILLION DEGREE AND SUB
BACCALAUREATE HOLDERS.
THESE NUMBERS ARE ALARMING WE
MUST WORK TOGETHER IN ORDER TO
FIND CREATIVE FEASIBLE
AFFORDABLE. AND ACCESSIBLE WAYS
OF ENSURING OUR CURRENT
STUDENTS.
AND FUTURE STUDENTS NOT ONLY IN
ROLE IN OUR INSTITUTIONS BUT
PERSIST IN ACHIEVING THEIR
DEGREES. OF SUB OR SUB
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES OR
CERTIFICATIONS.
THIS MORNING AS WE LISTEN TO THE
SEGMENTS DISCUSS THEIR
INNOVATIVE IDEAS.
OF EXPANDING AXES AND
COMPLETION.
I AM EXCITED TO LEARN OF THEIR
PROGRESS.
AS MD RC SHARES WHAT HAS OR HAS
OR HAS NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
OTHER STATES.
AS THEY SEEK TO CLOSE THE DEGREE
GAPS
I AM HOPEFUL AND OPTIMISTIC
THERE WILL BE SOME GREAT IDEAS.
AND POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS THAT THE
STATE MAY ALSO BE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO AN INFORMATIVE
DISCUSSION.
AND.
LOOK TO THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE DYESS IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENTS.
OKAY LICENSING NINE WILL GET ON
WITH THE AGENDA THAT. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A AT STATE SAYS THAT
ARE AT THE AT THE OUTSET THAT PP
I SEE. AND CALIFORNIA COMPETES.
TALK ABOUT THE. CHALLENGES THAT
WE FACE AND SOME OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SUCCESS.
AS WE HAVE HANS JOHNSON WITH PP
I CITY.
AND ONE DAY JOSE WITH CALIFORNIA
COMPETES.
I THINK YOU CHAIR I DON'T
MCCARTY AND CHAIR MEDINAN%
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
HANS JOHNSON THE DIRECTOR OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION CENTER AT THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS MORNING I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN CLOSE THE
DEGREE GAP IN CALIFORNIA I'M
GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON. TARGETS
AND NUMBERS BUT CERTAINLY BEHIND
THOSE TARGETS IN NUMBERS ARE
PROGRAMS AND PLANS AND
INTERVENTIONS THEM AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
STUDENTS WE'RE GOING ABOUT
STUDENT SUCCESS. AND STUDENT
SUCCESS THAT WILL LEAD TO A
BETTER LIVES FOR STUDENTS IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC OUTCOMES BUT
ALSO OTHER OUTCOMES LIKE SOCIAL
HEALTH. AND WELFARE OUTCOMES AND
A BETTER CALIFORNIA MORE TAX
REVENUE AND LESS DEMAND FOR
SOCIAL SERVICES.
SO I HAVE.
ASK THE SERGEANT AT ARMS TO
GIVE YOU THIS HANDOUT.
AND YOU MIGHT WANT TO FOLLOW
ALONG AS I GO THROUGH MY
TESTIMONY. TO THE FIRST SLIDE I
HAVE.
SHOWS WHAT PP I SEE HAS
PROJECTED AND TERMS OF OUR
DEGREE GAP.
AND SPECIFICALLY THE ORANGE
LINE SHOWS A BASELINE SOME ARE
LESS THE ANNUAL NUMBER OF
DEGREES THAT CALIFORNIA IS ON A
PACE.
TOOK A BUT BUT PRODUCE BASED ON
CURRENT RATES OF COLLEGE GOING
COLLEGE COMPLETION.
AND.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY FOR
ALL INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE STATE FROM. A
PRIVATE NON PROFITS A PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT STEVEN AND CERTAINLY
UC AND CSU.
THE DARKER LINE THERE THE
GREENISH LINE IS WHAT IS OUR
CLOSING THE GAP SCENARIO AND IF
IF WE MEET THAT ARE SCENARIO. A
WE WILL FULLY SATISFY THE NEEDS
OF A WITH AN ECONOMY THAT IS
INCREASINGLY DEMANDING MORE
HIGHLY SKILLED AND HIGHLY
EDUCATED WORKERS AND. MORE IN AN
INCREASINGLY REWARDING THEM
ECONOMICALLY.
AND THE TOTAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THESE TWO LINES OVER
THIS ENTIRE A TIME FRAME IS
ABOUT ONE POINT ONE. MILLION
DEGREES SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
DEGREE GAP.
SO LET'S TURN TO THE NEXT SLIDE
THIS IS ON PAGE THREE OF YOUR
HANDOUT.
AND THE GOOD NEWS AND NOT SO
GOOD NEWS MAYBE IT IS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT OF ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT SO WHILE THOSE A
DEGREE GOALS ARE AMBITIOUS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WANT TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
AND UNLIKE SOME OTHER STATES
WHERE POPULATIONS ARE DECLINING.
AND SOME COLLEGES ARE HAVING
TROUBLES ENROLLING STUDENTS THAT
TENDS NOT TO BE THE CASE IN
CALIFORNIA AND CERTAINLY IS NOT
THE CASE FOR OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS.
I SAW THIS CHART IS SHOWING YOU
THIS PIPELINE FROM NINTH GRADE
THROUGH TO A COLLEGE DEGREE AND
SO OUT OF. ONE THOUSAND NINE
GRADES IN CALIFORNIA YOU SEE HOW
MANY WILL END UP GRADUATING FROM
HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THEN FINALLY AT THE FAR
RIGHT IS HOW MANY WILL
EVENTUALLY EARNED A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE SO OUT OF THOSE ONE
THOUSAND NINTH GRADERS. WE HAVE
A LITTLE OVER THREE HUNDRED OF
THEM WILL EVENTUALLY EARNED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREES AT TODAY'S
COLLEGE GOING ON COLLEGE
COMPLETION RATES.
THAT THE GOOD NEWS THAT AS WE
HAVE A LOT OF ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT. AND THE OTHER PIECE
OF GOOD NEWS I WOULD SAY IS WE
DO HAVE A LARGE NUMBER STUDENTS
WHO DO MAKE THE TRANSITION FROM
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE AND
YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE WE HAVE.
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY THREE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES OUT OF THAT
INITIAL ONE THOUSAND COHORT OF
NINTH GRADERS.
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO WILL
ATTEND A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS OF
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO WILL
ATTEND A COMMUNITY COLLEGE SET
ALTOGETHER THAT'S ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX OUT OF
THAT EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE ARE GOING ON TO COLLEGE.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM THERE.
TO IMPROVE COLLEGE COMPLETION
JUST AMONG THOSE WHO HAVE
ALREADY SUCCESSFULLY MADE THE
TRANSITION TO COLLEGE.
NOTABLY CALIFORNIA RANKS FORTY
SEVENTH IN THE NATION AND THE
SHARE OF RECENT HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES TO GO TO A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY THAT'S THE
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO NUMBER.
SO WERE DOWN NEAR THE BOTTOM
AMONG ALL STATES THERE'S A LOT
OF ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT THERE.
WE RANK FIFTH HIGHEST AMONG ALL
STATES IN THE SHARE THAT GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOCUS.
OUR IN OUR STATE WHICH IS PARTLY
A RESULT OF OF THE MASTER PLAN
AND AND OTHER ON DECISIONS WE'VE
MADE AND DECISIONS MADE BY
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
GIVES US A TREMENDOUS POOL OF
STUDENTS TO WORK WITH.
I'D LIKE YOU DID ESPECIALLY PAY
ATTENTION TO THAT THAT TRANSFER
BOX THERE IT'S A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE OUT OF THAT INITIAL
COHORT OF ONE THOUSAND NINTH
GRADERS A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE OUT
OF THE THREE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
TO TEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
YOU CAN TELL I'M A DEMOGRAPHER
LIKE THROWING OUT NUMBERS EARLY
IN THE MORNING.
BUT IN ANY EVENT THAT NUMBERS
TO LAW ARE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES NO IT'S TOO LOW THEY
HAVE A VERY AGGRESSIVE A VISION
FOR SUCCESS WHICH WOULD
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THAT
NUMBER AT THE GOALS TO INCREASE
THAT NUMBER THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
IN TERMS OF NUMBER TRANSFER
STUDENTS TO GO TO UC AND CSU. IF
THEY DO THAT THAT WOULD PUT US
AS A STATE AND THEM ON A SYSTEM
YOU COMPLETELY. ARE ON PAR WITH
WHAT WE HAVE RECOMMENDED IN
TERMS OF CLOSING THE DEGREE GAP
AND THEN FINALLY WE HAVE THIS
TRANSITION THAN FROM.
THOSE WHO MAKE IT TO A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE TO EARNING A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND THERE
AGAIN WE HAVE. CONTINUED TO DROP
OFF SO THERE'S A LOT OF PARTS
THIS PIPELINE WHERE THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE WORKING TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES. AND
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF BACHELOR'S DEGREES
WE PRODUCE.
IF YOU MOVE THEN TO SLIDE FOR WE
HAVE ACTUALLY IDENTIFIED A VERY
AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR EACH OF THE
SYSTEMS. ARE YOU SEE CSU PLAYS
ARE THE LARGEST ROLE AND THAT'S
BECAUSE IT IS BY FAR AND AWAY
THE LARGEST. UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
IN THE STATE AND IN FACT THE
LARGEST UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE
COUNTRY.
WITH.
THE DISH NO DEGREES NECESSARY
FOR THEM ANNOUNCING TOALMOST A
HALF MILLION AND. JUST UNDER
HALF THE TOTAL BUT OF COURSE YOU
SEE AND A PRIVATE NON PROFITS
PLAY A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE AS
WELL.
IF WE MOVE THEN TO SLIDE FIVE
PP I SEE HAS IDENTIFIED SPECIFIC
TARGETS THAT WOULD NEED TO BE IN
THAT TO CLOSE THE DEGREE GAP.
THESE ARE TARGETS IN TERMS OF
THE STE ELIGIBILITY SHARES THAT
THE SHERIFF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
YOU SEE OR CSU.
AND YOU'LL SEE THAT OUR GOALS
THAT ARE FOR YOU YOU SEE THE
MOVE FROM TWELVE AND A HALF
PERCENT TO SEVENTEEN AND A HALF
PERCENT. FOR CSU TO MOVE FROM
THE TOP ONE THIRD OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES TO THE TOP FORTY
PERCENT OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
WE HAVE FACED IN PERIODS FOR
EACH ONE OF THESE TARGETS WHICH
IS ON THE FAR RIGHT THERE. ARE
THE.
AGAIN SOME GOOD NEWS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
ARE INCREASINGLY MEETING THE A
THROUGH G. CRITERIA THE COLLEGE
PREPARATORY COURSES REQUIRED FOR
ENTRANCE TO UC AND CSU. WE SEEN
STRONG GAINS AMONG EVERY GROUP
IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING LATINOS
AND AFRICAN AMERICANS.
AND IN FACT THE ELIGIBILITY
STUDY THAT WAS.
PRODUCED LAST YEAR SHOWED THAT
SEE ISSUES ACTUALLY ADMIT. THAT
THAT THAT FORTY PERCENT OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES A LITTLE OVER
FORTY PERCENT HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES ARE ACTUALLY MEETING.
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA OF CSU
RIGHT NOW SO IN A WAY WE'VE
ALREADY MET THIS TARGET. YEARS
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE BECAUSE
STUDENTS ARE DOING SUCH A GOOD
JOB IN TERMS OF. COMPLETING
THOSE COURSES REQUIRED FOR CSU
ELIGIBILITY AT THE GRADES
REQUIRED BY CSU.
I YOU SEE ARE ALSO IS ACTUALLY A
SLIGHTLY HIGHER THAN THEIR
TWELVE AND A HALF PERCENT
ACCORDING TO THAT SAME
ELIGIBILITY STUDY.
THAT WE ALSO THEN.
FOCUS ON TRANSFER AND AS THEY
SAID THIS IS INCREDIBLE AYE
CREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
MECHANISM FOR IMPROVING COLLEGE
GRADUATION AND. AND YOU SEE.
THEIR THESE NUMBERS REPRESENT
THAT THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
INCREASE
THAT IS OF THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS. A GOAL THAT OUR
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY AND HIS TEAM
HAVE IDENTIFIED. AND THEN
FINALLY ON IMPROVING GRADUATION
RATES OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
ALREADY IN OUR FOUR YEAR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IS
ESSENTIAL ANNUAL SEE.
THERE WE SEE UC AND CSU ARE
EIGHTY THREE AND FIFTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF RESPECTIVELY WHEN WE
DEVELOP THESE PROJECTIONS.
THEIR LITTLE HIGHER NOW.
AND THEN WE HAD OUR CLOSING THE
GAP TARGETS FOR YOU SEE NINETY
TWO PERCENT AND SEE IF YOU FOR
SEVENTY FOUR PERCENT. ARE CSU
TARGET IS IN FACT.
EGGS A LITTLE LESS AMBITIOUS
THAN BUT CSU HAS SAT OUR TARGETS
OVER TWO THOUSAND THIRTY A CSU
HOUSE A SEVENTY PERCENT
GRADUATION RATE GOAL FOR THEIR
SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE. BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO THAT'S
ACTUALLY IF YOU IF YOU DRAW THE
LINES THAT'S ACTUALLY A LITTLE
BIT MORE AMBITIOUS THAN WHAT
WE'VE DONE SO WE'VE GOT SOME
GOOD VISION WE'VE GOT SOME GOOD
PLANS ARE ON THE PART OF THE
SEGMENTS. IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
IMPROVE GRADUATION RATES AND
COMPLETION I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM PRIVATE NON PROFITS
LATER AND I THINK THEY'LL TALK
ABOUT. A SOME OF THEIR GOALS
WITH RESPECT TO ENROLLMENT
INCREASES IN SERVING OUR
STUDENTS SO THERE'S A LOT OF
GOOD NEWS. OUT THERE.
A I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND.
JUST.
VERY BRIEFLY MENTIONED THIS NEXT
SLIDE SLIDE SIX WE BREAK OUT
THESE THESE.
TARGETS BECAUSE WE ASSUME MORE.
AND IMPROVING GRADUATION RATES
THAN THEY DO AND CSU THEIR
THEIR.
ACTUALLY A LITTLE HIGHER
ENROLLMENT NUMBERS ARE A LITTLE
HIGHER BECAUSE. I DON'T THEY
HAVE A SLIGHTLY MORE AMBITIOUS
GOALS WITH RESPECT GRADUATION
RATES THAN OUR OUR TARGETS HAD
SUGGESTED.
THEN IF WE TURN TO SLIDE SEVEN
OF THIS MIGHT NOT SEEM LIKE A
VERY IMPRESSIVE SLIGHT BUT THIS
IS THE ONE THAT MAKES ME MOST
HAPPY.
.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE ARE THOSE
INITIAL LINES YOU SAW BEFORE BUT
THIS TIME BROKEN DOWN FOR THE TO
PLOT LARGE PUBLIC SO THAT THE
SECTORS YOU SEE ON THE LEFT IN
CSU ON THE RIGHT?
AND THAT NEW GRAY BAR WHICH I'VE
ADDED IS WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENED SINCE WE DEVELOPED OUR
PROJECTION SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
THE GOOD NEWS IS BOTH YOU SEE
AND CSU ARE AHEAD OF. THE
TARGETS THAT WE HAVE SAT AND
THIS IS BECAUSE OF VERY SPECIFIC
ACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
IN TERMS OF PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. FOR ENROLLMENT AND FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS AND BY ACTIONS
TAKEN BY THE INSTITUTIONS
THEMSELVES TO ENROLL STUDENTS.
AND INCREASE OUR COMPLETION AT
PERSISTENCE COMPLETION AND
EVENTUALLY GRADUATION RATES
SO.
CAN.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE'RE ON PACE.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU LOOK ABOUT
CHART YOU SEE WE'RE JUST AT THE
BEGINNING AND WE HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK. TO GO.
ALRIGHT AND THEN UP FINALLY. I'D
LIKE TO KNOW THAT.
AND VERY IMPORTANTLY THAT ONE
OF THE BENEFITS OF CLOSING THE
THE DEGREE GAP IS A TREMENDOUS
IMPROVEMENT IN EQUITY.
OUTCOMES IN CALIFORNIA OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS ARE COMPRISED OF. EXCUSE
ME ACT AND.
ARE.
COMPRISED OF A MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FREE OR REDUCED PRICE LUNCH.
LATINOS ARE A MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS AN ARCADE TWELVE
SYSTEM.
SO FOR CALIFORNIA TO REACH THESE
GOALS MEANS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE INCLUDING STUDENTS FROM
GROUPS THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
BEEN UNDERREPRESENTED IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE. ARE IN
NUMBERS THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE AND.
FOR STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ENSURING I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTLY THAT HIGHER
EDUCATION CONTINUES TO SERVE AS
A LADDER OF ECONOMIC.
AND SOCIAL MOBILITY AND DOES
NOT SIMPLY.
REINFORCE CLASS IN ECONOMIC
DIVIDES THAT EXIST IN OUR
COUNTRY AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
GOOD.
STORIES TO TELL A GOOD TRACK
RECORD IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS HAVE
BEEN MORE INCLUSIVE.
THAN THOSE IN OTHER STATES
INCLUDING OUR PUBLIC SYSTEMS AND
CALIFORNIA. AND TO RISE TO THE
CHALLENGE OF THE FUTURE WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THAT CONTINUES
TANKER. MEETING THESE GOALS WILL
BE AYE COOPER INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT STEP IN MAKING SURE
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION CONTINUES
TO DO THAT FINALLY I SHOULD NOTE
THAT OUR PROJECTIONS ARE FOCUSED
ON BACCALAUREATE. UP PRODUCTION
BUT.
OTHERS HAVE LOOKED AT OUR
CREDENTIALS IN POST SECONDARY
BELOW BACKSPACE AGREES AS WELL
AS WORK YOU'VE DONE ON BASHES
GRACE THIS IS MONDAY DOESN'T IT
GOING TO HEAR FROM AND AMEND IT.
AND I SHOULD ALSO NOTE ARE THAT
YOU SEE HAS RIGHTLY POINTED OUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF GRADUATE
STUDENTS IN THE ROLE OF THE
GRADUATE STUDENTS PLAY IN OUR
ECONOMY THEY ACTUALLY HAVE THE
PAST. LABOR MARKET OUTCOMES OF
ANY GROUP.
BUT ALSO.
ARE INVOLVED IN TRADING FIRMS
AND FINALLY ARE ALSO HELP
EDUCATE UNDERGRADUATES THAT YOU
SEE AS THE UC. OUR UNDERGRADUATE
I CERTAINLY KNEW THAT WELL.
AND IT'S A GRADUATE STUDENT YOU
SEE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
COMPETES
AND WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT NON
PARTISAN PROJECT AIMED AT
BOLSTERING THE STATE'S POST
SECONDARY. AB.
PUT SECONDARY OUTCOMES TO FOSTER
A ROBUST ECONOMY VIBRANT
COMMUNITY AND A VERY ENGAGED
CITIZENRY.
HOW MUCH ARE WORK FOR THE PAST
SEVEN YEARS HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
MAKING THE ECONOMIC AND EQUITY
DRIVEN CASE FOR INCREASING
DEGREE ATTAINMENT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA? IN VERY MUCH BAKED
INTO OUR VIEW OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IS THE ASSUMPTION THAT
THE ECONOMIC MEETING THE
ECONOMIC NEEDS OF THE STATE.
WILL BRING ABOUT THE DESIRED AT
NOT OUT COME OF HAVING MORE
EQUITABLE OUTCOMES FOR THE
STATE'S RESIDENTS.
SO.
WHAT I HAVE BEFORE YOU IS A
POWER POINT ACCOMPANIED BY CAN A
FORMAL REMARKS?
MORE OR LESS EVERY PARAGRAPH
EXPLAINS EVERY SLIDE BUT I DON'T
WANNA GO THROUGH THAT WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO WITH KIND OF TALK
WITH YOU CONCEPTUALLY ABOUT THE
FOR BIG IDEAS. THAT WE THINK
WILL COMPLEMENT THE WORK THAT
OUR COLLEAGUES PP I SEE HAVE
DONE IN TERMS OF THINKING
THROUGH THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
ELIGIBILITY POOLS AND ROMANCE
TRANSFER AND COMPLETION. BECAUSE
I THINK BY ITSELF THAT SERVES A
VERY ROBUST MODEL FOR HOW THE
STATE MIGHT APPROACH THINKING
ABOUT SUPPORTING INCREASED
DEGREE ATTAINMENT. BUT WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE A COUPLE OF OTHER
SUBTLETIES THAT OUGHT TO BE
INCORPORATED INTO ANY MODEL IF
YOU WELL AS WELL.
.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND AS YOU KNOW
WE WERE ESTABLISHING AROUND
TWENTY TEN TO IN RESPONSE TO A
NATIONAL EFFORT TO INCREASE
DEGREE ATTAINMENT. AND I WE'VE
ALWAYS OPERATED FROM THE
ASSUMPTION THAT IF CALIFORNIA
WERE TO REACH FIFTY FIVE PERCENT
DEGREE ATTAINMENT BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. IT ACTUALLY PLACE
THE STATE IN THE TOP TEN OF
STATES.
WITH EDUCATIONAL DEGREE
ATTAINMENT.
UP UNFORTUNATELY WERE NOT ON
TRACK TO.
GET TO THIS GOAL OUR ORIGINAL
RESEARCH IN TWENTY TWELVE FOUND
THAT WE WERE GONNA BE SHORT BY
POINT ABOUT TWO POINT THREE
MILLION DEGREES. AND OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS WE'VE UPDATED
THAT NUMBER TWICE.
AND THAT'S BASED ON THE STATE'S
CHANGING POPULATION AND THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT AS HANS MENTIONED
OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS HAVE
ACTUALLY INCREASED THEIR OUT
RATE OF COMPLETION FOR MANY
ADULTS AND SO THAT. IS BEGINNING
TO HELP US THINK ABOUT HOW WE
CLOSE THAT GAP.
AT THE SAME TIME
DESPITE THEIR SIGNIFICANT
EFFORTS WE STILL CONTINUE TO SEE
A SIGNIFICANT GAP BETWEEN WHAT
THE STATUS FORECAST
PRODUCE AND WHAT IT ACTUALLY
SHOULD PRODUCE IF WERE TO BE
AWARE AMONGST ONE OF THOSE TOP
TEN STATES.
THE PROBLEM WE FACE IS THAT IS
THAT WE CAN'T REALLY CLOSE THAT
DEGREE OF PRODUCTION GAP.
THE CURRENT PACE THAT WERE OUT
ON BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
SO YOU KNOW EVERYONE NOW TALKS
ABOUT WILL WE NEED TO STAY. AND
STATE GOAL WOULD BE GREAT I END
BUT TO BE CLEAR LIKE THE STATE
GOAL AROUND TO GREET HIM AND IS
NOT A BE ALL AND END ALL
STRATEGY.
AT I THINK IT'S AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT FOR HOW WE THINK ABOUT
FURTHER PROMOTING COLLABORATION
AND COORDINATION ACROSS AN
INSTITUTIONAL SEGMENTS AND
ALIGNED WITH. THE WORK THAT YOU
ALL OF POLICYMAKERS DO BECAUSE
IT REALLY HELPS TO COMMUNICATE A
PUBLIC AGENDA FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND THAT IS IN FACT
WHAT THE STATE SORELY NEEDS.
LIKE MY COLLEAGUES AT PP I SEE
WE THOUGHT ABOUT THE VARIOUS
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS THAT WILL
MOST MEANINGFULLY HELP TO
ESTABLISH.
DEGREE ITAIM INCREASE TO GREET
HIM AND REACH A GOAL AND WE
AGREE THAT PAYING ATTENTION TO
ENROLLMENT ON TRANSFERS IS A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THAT BUT WE
RECOMMEND THAT YOU THINK ABOUT
EXPANDING THE MODEL. TO DEVELOP
DEGREE GOALS THAT INCLUDE NOT
ONLY IN PUTS.
BUT ALSO FOCUSED ON THE OUTPUTS
THAT LEADS EQUITABLE OUTCOMES
AND SERVE THE STATE'S ECONOMIES.
DEGREE COMPLETION IS THE MOST
OBVIOUS OUTPUT TO CONSIDER BUT
ARTICULATING A SET A GOAL
CENTERED ON DEGREE COMPLETION
REQUIRES PAYING ATTENTION TO
MORE THAN JUST THE TOTAL NUMBER.
IT OUT IT'S ALSO ABOUT WHO THOSE
DEGREES GO TO WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED AND HOW THEY SUPPORT OUR
REGIONAL ECONOMIES.
CONCEPTUALLY WE THINK THEREFORE
CRITICAL CONSIDERATIONS TO
ESTABLISHING MEANINGFUL RESPONSE
OF GOALS.
FIRST DEPICTED REPRODUCTION
OUGHT TO ALIGN WITH GROWING
OCCUPATIONAL DEMANDS.
THE LARGEST OCCUPATIONS THAT
REQUIRE DEGREE BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE ENCOMPASS A WIDELY DIVERSE
SPECTRUM.
BY THAT TIME THE STATE WILL NEED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TEACHERS STEM
PROFESSIONALS FINANCE EXPERTS
THE LIST GOES ON.
CLOSING THE GAP BY PRODUCING
DEGREES IN ONLY ONE OR A FEW OF
THESE FIELDS WOULD BE A FAILURE
FOR THE STATE.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE CAPACITY
CAPITAL AND THE INCENTIVES IN
PLACE.
TO SUPPORT INSTITUTIONS IN
PRODUCING DEGREES BUT OFFERED
THEM BEST LONG TERM OPPORTUNITY
TO STUDENTS AND RESPOND TO THE
CHANGING NEEDS OF OUR ECONOMY.
THIS REQUIRES THAT THE MODEL
THAT YOU ALL THINK ABOUT. ITS.
BE USED TO ESTABLISH GOALS THAT
ARE ATTUNED TO THE DIVERSE
MISSIONS AND CAPACITIES OF OUR
INSTITUTIONAL SEGMENTS.
SECOND DEGREE GOALS MUST BE
RESPONSIVE TO VARIATIONS
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO A RICH
DIVERSITY OF CULTURES AND
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES THAT AFFORD
SOME OF THE MOST THRIVING LOCAL
ECONOMIES. IN THE WORLD.
INCREASINGLY STATEWIDE DEGREE
ATTAINMENT IS A NET WHEN
HOWEVER.
REALISTIC GOALS TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS SHOULD BE CUSTOMIZED TO
ACCOUNT FOR REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES.
AN EQUITABLE APPROACH TO
INCREASING DEGREE PRODUCTION
ACROSS THE STATE.
WOULD UP DEVELOP A MODEL THAT
CONSIDERS REGIONAL CONTACTS.
THIRD WE MUST BE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT REGIONAL DIFFERENCE IN
WORKFORCE NEEDS AND LOCAL
INSTITUTIONS ABILITY TO RESPOND
TO THOSE NEEDS ARE ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT OF THE
ISSUE.
WERE NOT ADVOCATING FOR AN
EXPLICIT EDUCATION TO EMPLOYMENT
MAPPING OR USING LABOR FORCE
PREDICTIONS TO NARROWLY
PRESCRIBED WHAT DEGREES ARE
OFFERED IN EACH REGION.
HOWEVER THE MAJORITY OF U. S.
COLLEGE STUDENTS ATTEND SCHOOL
WITHIN FIFTY MILES OF THEIR HOME
AND ITS NECESSARY THAT STUDENTS
WHO GRADUATE WITH A DEGREE. HAVE
A FAIR OPPORTUNITY FOR LONG TERM
QUALITY EMPLOYMENT AND THAT
EMPLOYERS IN THE REGION HAVE
ACCESS
COMPETENTLY SKILLED WORKERS.
A PRUDENT WAY TO INCORPORATE
THIS INTO IT DEGREE ATTAINMENT
GOAL WOULD BE TO DEVELOP A MODEL
THAT INCORPORATES JOB PLACEMENT
RATES.
THE PATIENT PLACEMENT RATES AND
TIME TO EMPLOYMENT RATES FOR
GRADUATES.
FINALLY THIS REGIONAL LIVE
METHODOLOGY CAN AND SHOULD BE
APPLIED TO VARIATION IN
EDUCATIONAL TEN ATTAINMENT BY
RACE AND GENDER.
TO DEMONSTRATE THIS WE ANALYZED
ATTAINMENT DATA BY RACE AND
GENDER AND ONE OF OUR FAVORITE
REGIONS THE INLAND EMPIRE.
ALARMINGLY LATINOS WHO MAKE UP
ABOUT HALF OF THE TOTAL
POPULATION IN THIS REGION HAVE
DRAMATICALLY LOWER RATES OF
DEGREE COMPLETION COMPLETION
COMPARED TO OTHER GROUPS.
THIS IS NO MATHEMATICALLY
THERE'S NO MATHEMATICALLY VIABLE
PATH FORWARD TO INCREASE
REGIONAL DEGREE PRODUCTION
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE
INEQUITIES OF COMPLETION GAPS.
SPLAYED ACROSS DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS.
TO REACH A RACIALLY EQUITABLE
EDUCATION EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT.
GOAL SHOULD BE CONTEXTUALIZED TO
COUNT FOR THE PROGRESS MADE
TOWARDS ELIMINATING ENROLLMENT
AND COMPLETION DISPARITIES.
IF YOU CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT
HOW TO IMPLEMENT DEGREE
ATTAINMENT GOALS WE HOPE YOU
WILL CONSIDER NOT JUST HOW MANY
DEGREES OUR STATE NEEDS BUT WHAT
MAJORS AND WHAT DEGREES ARE
NEEDED. TO FUEL THE REGIONAL
ECONOMIES AND HOW WE OUGHT TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE.
HIGHEST EDUCATIONAL NEED.
WE A CALIFORNIA COMPETES ARE
QUITE EAGER TO SUPPORT YOU IN
YOUR EFFORTS TO INCREASE
STATEWIDE DEGREE PRODUCTION
THROUGH COMPLETION. AND WE OFFER
OUR EXPERTISE THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO REFINE THE STRATEGY THAT
EQUITABLY EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
TO HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
FROM HIS FIRST.
PANEL.
YES FAMILY MEMBER BAKER THANK
YOU AND I DID SNEAK IN MIDWAY
THROUGH BUT THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND TO FURTHER THE
HEARING IN THE TOPIC.
I'M LIKE TO GO BACK TO.
IT'S A GOOD OBSERVATION IS BEING
MADE IS THAT THE REGIONALISM
THAT WE NEED TO BE CONSIDERING.
HOW?
HOW MUCH?
CAN WE BE LOOKING ALSO AT HOW
NIMBLE WE NEED TO BE AS THAT
CHANGES.
FOR EXAMPLE IF WE'RE GOING TO
SAY THE INLAND EMPIRE IS GONNA
HAVE A LOT OF NEEDS FOR NURSES.
OR PEOPLE WITH NURSING DEGREES
OR SOME SORT OF MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE DEGREE.
AND POPULATIONS CHANGE THEY
MOVE AND YOU WANT PEOPLE TO BE
AS MOBILE AS POSSIBLE. AND AS
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THESE NUMBERS.
HOW HOW MUCH RECONSIDERING
MOBILITY AND THE PEOPLE UP AND
MOVE AND?
SPLIT AFTER THEY GET A DEGREE
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY STAY
RIGHT WHERE THEY'RE AT.
SO WE WANT TO HAVE A DEGREE
THAT'S PORTABLE WE ONE HAVE THE
SKILLS OR PORTABLE TO GO WHERE
PEOPLE WANT TO GO BUT. I'M CAN
YOU COMMENT AT ALL ON THAT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW REGIONALISM NOW
I MEAN I THINK THE REGIONALISM
QUESTION IS IS AN IMPORTANT ONE
BECAUSE CERTAINLY YOU DON'T WANT
TO.
.
OVERLY TYPE PRESCRIBE PEOPLE'S
OPPORTUNITY STRUCTURE RIGHT SO
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET YOUR
DEGREE AND TAKE IT WHERE EVER
YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO.
THE SAME TIME I THINK PART OF
THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE SUCH ON
EVEN.
THEY'RE SUCH GREAT REGIONAL
DISPARITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY OBVIOUSLY
COMPARED TO.
HOLLYWOOD INLAND EMPIRE ARE
ABOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY THEIR
REAL DISPARITIES IN TERMS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY STRUCTURE THERE AND
I THINK THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
FACE WITH THINKING ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE REGIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AS.
OUR BEST LABOR MARKET DATA COMES
AS CLOSE TO TO THE YEAR WERE
STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING WHICH
DOESN'T REALLY GIVE OUR
INSTITUTIONS THE TIME THAT THEY
NEED. TO RE CALIBRATE AND YOU
KNOW YOU CAN'T WAIT UNTIL. NOW
TO TO GET YOU KNOW FIVE HUNDRED
MORE NURSES FOR SEPTEMBER SO
THERE IS A TENSION THERE BETWEEN
HOW WE THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
REGIONAL OPPORTUNITIES ARE
CURRENTLY. AND HOW WE NEED TO.
ADJUST AND FLEX OUR
INSTITUTIONAL AND INSTITUTIONS
BE ABLE TO CREATE THE KINDS OF
OCCUPATIONS THAT THAT ARE
NEEDED.
AND THE THIS MAYBE FOR MISTER
JOHNSON HAD JUST SORT OF LOOKING
AT THE. THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT ARE
HERE ABOUT THE DEGREE GAP.
AND WHERE WE DEFINING IS A
DEGREE.
BECAUSE WHEN I VISIT WITH
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
THAT WE'RE THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUES THAT THEY MENTION IS JUST
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE SKILLS
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE FOR YOUR
DEGREE.
AND I'M A VERY BIG PROPONENT OF
FOR YOUR DEGREE BUT I'M IS ARE
WE LOOKING AT MANY OF THE TRADE.
OPPORTUNITIES THAT FOR WHICH WE
CAN HAVE CERTIFICATIONS ARE
DEGREES ARE DIFFERENT PATHS.
IS THAT INCLUDED IN THIS.
ANALYSIS OF THEIRS
OF HOW.
BROUGHT THE GAP IS BETWEEN THE
DEGREES WE NEED BECAUSE THIS
LOOKS MOSTLY LIKE NEED FOR YOUR
DEGREE SO SO RIGHT SO SO WE
FOCUSED OUR IN THIS AREN'T. WORK
ARE ON FOUR YEAR DEGREES BASHERS
GREASE FOR A COUPLE REASONS
FIRST THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA PARENTS WANT THEIR
CHILD TO EARN AT LEAST ABOUT
FIRST DEGREE. AND A FACT IN OUR
LATEST SURVEY A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA PARENTS WANT THEIR
CHILD TO ACTUALLY EARN A
GRADUATE DEGREE.
THE DEMAND IS VERY HIGH
STUDENTS.
ARE INCREASINGLY RESPONDING TO
THE NEEDS A IN TERMS OF A
COLLEGE PREPARATORY
REQUIREMENTS.
AND RESPONDING FINALLY TO TO
THE CONNIE WHICH CONTINUES TO
DESPITE WHAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
READ.
REWARD COLLEGE GRADUATES WHAT
THE BASHERS AGREE MORE THAN ANY
OTHER.
MOSTLY MORE THAN LESS EDUCATED
INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING ARE THOSE
WHO HAVE SOME COLLEGE OR THOSE
WHO HAVE CERTIFICATES ON AVERAGE
NOW. LET ME UNPACK THAT LITTLE
BIT.
I WE'VE DONE WORK IN MONDAY'S
DONE WORK ALSO SO LONG THEY
MIGHT WANT TO ADD TO THIS
BECAUSE LANDET HOUSE DEVELOP
PROJECTION SIMILAR TO OURS
EXCEPT HERS ARE. BUT SHE'S ALSO
ADDED CERTIFICATES TOOK TO THE
NUMBER. ARM AND IT'S ROUGHLY
DOUBLES BUT THE NUMBER BUT THAT
THAT WE HAVE THE ONE POINT ONE
MILLION BECOMES TWO POINT THREE
SOMETHING LIKE WHAT FOR HALF A
POINT FOR.
AS A WE DON'T MARKET PP I SEE
LOOKING UP HIGH VALUE
CERTIFICATES PURSES MAYBE NOT SO
HIGH VALUE CERTIFICATES WE
STARTED OUT WORK LOOKING AT
HEALTH AND OBVIOUSLY THE MOST
HIGH VALUE CERTIFICATE YOU CAN
EARN AND HEALTH IS ACTUALLY CALL
VOCATIONAL DEGREE IS AN
ASSOCIATES DEGREE IN NURSING.
MEDICAL ASSISTING DOESN'T GET
YOU MUCH ANNA IN THE LABOR
MARKET AYE IT DOES ALLOW YOU
THOUGH VERY IMPORTANTLY. TO MOVE
ARE OUT OF INDUSTRIES WHERE
MAYBE THERE ISN'T A LOT OF
UPSIDE POTENTIAL RETELL FOR
EXAMPLE TO HEALTH WHERE THERE IS
A LOT MORE UPSIDE POTENTIAL AND
ONE OF THE PIECES THAT WE'VE
DONE LOOKING AT CERTIFICATES.
AND OF FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN A
MEDICAL ASSISTING DEGREE FOR
EXAMPLE IS THAT A NUMBER OF
THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO EARNED
THOSE DEGREES WILL GO ON AND
EARN HIGHER DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES AND HEALTH. I
SOMETIMES INCLUDING ALL THE WAY
UP TO REGISTERED NURSE SO
THAT'S.
STEPWISE OF BUILDING OF DEGREES
I'D CERTIFICATES IS A STRATEGY
THAT STUDENTS ARE EMPLOYING
COLLEGES ARE INCREASINGLY
IDENTIFYING AS A WAY TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS WHO MIGHT
BE EARNING.CERTIFICATES THAT
ARE RELATIVELY LOW INCOME OUR
LOW OF LOW VALUE AT THE START
HAVING SAID THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS WHO ARE THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM GREEN NEVER COME
BACK AND DON'T EARN. A HIGHER
VALUE CERTIFICATES THAT'S
ANOTHER CHALLENGE BUT I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
ROOM IN OUR ECONOMY FOR POST
SECONDARY AWARD SHORT OF THE
VOUCHERS DEGREE.
AND AGAIN LINE BASED ON SOME
WORK AND WE'RE DOING SOME WORK
ON THAT BUT PLEASE DO NOT.
.
DISMISS THE TREMENDOUS
IMPORTANCE OF THE BACHELORS
DEGREE IN TERMS OF SOMEONE'S
LIFE AND LIVELIHOOD BY HONEST
WITH YOU. HIGH SCHOOL FRESHMAN.
OF MY OWN AYE I WON'T LAST LAST
MINUTE TO DO WITH THAT WHAT ROLE
YOU SEE THE NEED FOR REMEDIATION
OR MEDIA WHAT WE'VE BEEN CALLING
REMEDIAL.
EDUCATION WHEN SOMEONE IS
STARTING OFF AT POST HIGH
SCHOOL.
IN AND COMPLICATING THE IT'S THE
DEGREE GAP AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN SOME MOVEMENT IN
POLICIES WITH SOME OF OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS ON THAT.
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO WORK ON THAT
BUT I'D LIKE TO HAVE YOUR
OPINION ON HOW MUCH THAT HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO THE DEGREE GAP SO
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK LOOKING
AT REMEDIATION IN CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ARE ABOUT
EIGHTY PERCENT OF ENTERING
COHORTS IN THE PAST WERE
IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING
REMEDIATION. AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE STUDENTS NEVER
EARNED A CERTIFICATE OR TRANSFER
OR AN ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE. AND IN
FACT A MAJORITY OF THEM NEVER
PASS.
COLLEGE LEVEL ENGLISH OR MATH
COURSE.
WE'VE LOOKED AT REFORMS IN
ENGLISH AND MATH OR ENGLISH OF
REFORM WORK IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTED ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH HERE IN SACRAMENTO. OUR
AND OUR MOUTH REFORM WORK SHOWED
THAT ACCELERATED PATHWAYS FOR
STUDENTS SERVE THEM MUCH BETTER
COMBINING FOR EXAMPLE TO
REMEDIATION COURSES. INTO ONE
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY WAS ARE THE
STATISTICS PATHWAY. AYE IN MOUTH
VERSUS A TRADITIONAL MOUTH
PATHWAY LED TO MUCH MUCH BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS INCLUDING
MORE SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF
SUBSEQUENT COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES
AND MARK.
TRANSFER LATER ON.
HAVING SAID ALL THAT MEANWHILE
YOU OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR HAVE PASSED BILLS THAT
WILL DRAMATICALLY REFORM. HOW
REMEDIATION TAKES PLACE IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I KNOW WE
HAVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PEOPLE
HERE WHO CAN TALK ABOUT THAT
FURTHER? BUT THAT WORK WILL LEAD
TO ACHIEVE AT VERY LARGE SHIFT
ALREADY SEEN THIS HAPPENING AT
SOME OF THE COLLEGES THAT A
BENEFIT FOR FRONT OF THESE
STRANGERS. LOOKING AT HIGH
SCHOOL GRADES AND COURSES AS THE
PRIMARY WAY TO PLACE STUDENTS
WHICH.
IS THE BEST PREDICTOR OF HOW
SOON WILL DO IN COLLEGE NOT HOW
THEY DO ON A SINGLE PLACEMENT
EXAM. AND THAT WORK SHOWS THAT
THOSE STUDENTS
ABOUT STUDENTS NOW ARE
INCREASINGLY.
BEING PLACED DIRECTLY INTO
COLLEGE LEVEL WORK NOT EVEN
BEING HAVE NOT EVEN HAVING TO
REMEDIATE AT ALL AND OF COURSE
SUCCESS RATES ARE GOING UP
TREMENDOUSLY THROUGH BUT. I
EXPECT WILL GO UP QUITE A BIT
WHICH CREATES A CHALLENGE FOR
ALL OF US THEY CAN DOWN THE LINE
HOW DO WE ACCOMMODATE. WHAT I I
WOULD CALL THE WAVE AND MAYBE
THE TIDAL WAVE OF?
TRANSFER ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AS
THESE REFORMS ARE IMPLEMENTED
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
FOREST PLACE AT UC CSU ARE
PRIVATE NONPROFIT. AND RIGHT NOW
WE DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
HANDLE ABOUT FLOW AND SO I THINK
THAT'S A TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE
GOING FORWARD NINE WERE VERY
EXCITED INSTITUTIONALLY. ABOUT
THE REFORMS THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE AND AND WE THINK THEY'RE A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
AND THE LEGISLATURE. AS WELL AS
THE COLLEGES SHOULD PAT
THEMSELVES ON THE BACK FOR
MAKING THOSE REFORMS THANK YOU
VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU SOMEONE
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
YES THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION IN
RESEARCH I'VE.
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS BUT ONE
ON A TRANSFER DEGREE WE'VE SEEN
THAT.
OVER THE YEARS ON THAT THIS
GROUP I AS FAR AS THE CAL STATES
OF CAL STATE FULLERTON IN MY
DISTRICT THE ON THE LARGEST ONE.
OF THE CS USE AND THEY ARE
MAKING INCREASES IN THEIR
TRANSFER PROGRAM AND YET. IT'S
STILL NOT WHERE WE WANT IT SO WE
HAVE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW DO YOU GET INTO THE
NEXT STEP IF THEY ACTUALLY. YOU
KNOW DO ATTAIN SOME TYPE OF
DEGREE WE DO HAVE THE TRANSFER
PROGRAM THING AND YET I'VE HEARD
THAT.
ANYTIME STUDENTS DON'T KNOW
ABOUT IT AND IF THEY DO KNOW
ABOUT IT SAVE RT STARTED TAKING
COURSEWORK SO THEY CAN'T REALLY
FIT INTO THAT. TRANSFER DEGREE
PROGRAMS SO IF YOU CAN JUST
SPEAK IF YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON.
IS THAT WORKING IS IT.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO GET THOSE
STUDENTS TEND TO LOOK INTO THAT
TRANSFER PROGRAM?
SO THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR FAST
PROGRAM IS A GREAT IDEA AYE AND
IT'S DESIGNED TO TRY TO SOLVE
ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEMS. WE HAVE
WHICH IS.
ELIMINATING BARRIERS TO MOVING
FROM COMMITTEE ECOLOGIST FOR
YOUR CALLER ISN'T SUPPOSED TO
MAP OUT FIRST TUNE AND GUARANTEE
A STUDENT. A SPOT AT A
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS ARE IN A MAJOR IF IT IS.
HAS HAS DEVELOPED AN AGREEMENT
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SO I'M A BIG FAN
BUT IT'S IT'S JUST A STOP AND I
WOULD SAY ALMOST A BABY STEP IN
AYE DIRECTION FOR THE REASONS
THAT YOU'VE JUST IDENTIFIED A
LOT OF STUDENTS DON'T KNOW ABOUT
IT.
AND ALSO THE AGREEMENTS ARE
BETWEEN.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND
SEE ISSUE CAMPUSES YOU SEE IS
NOT A PART OF OF THE AGREEMENT
AND THEN FINALLY IT'S NOT SYSTEM
WIDE.
SO ARE A LOT OF CAN YOU COLLEGE
STUDENTS MIGHT THINK WELL I'M
NOT SURE I MIGHT WANT TO GO TO
YOU SEE I MIGHT WANT TO GO TO A
CSU. AND SO THAT DOESN'T REALLY
WORK IF YOU GET AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER THAT ONLY
GOES TO ONCE YES YOU MAYBE WANT
TO GO TO DIFFERENT CSU. AND THEN
FINALLY SO HAVING MORE SYSTEM
WIDE COHERENCE AND AGREEMENT I
THINK WOULD MAKE SENSE AND.
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM NDRC ABOUT
PRACTICES AND OTHER STATES SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS PART OF
THAT TESTIMONY BUT SOME OTHER
STATES HAVE MUCH MORE UNIFORM.
LOWER DIVISION REQUIREMENTS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
CLEARLY FEED TOO.
THEIR FOUR YEAR COLLEGES
AND AND AND UNIVERSITIES FINAL
NOTE THAT.
THEY TOO MANY COLLEGES ARE
IMPLEMENTING THIS NEW GUIDED
PATHWAYS INITIATIVE WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO SOLVE SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS YOU MENTIONED WERE
STUDENTS TO START TAKING COURSES
AND THEN THEY.
MAYBE LATER SIGNED UP FOR THE
EIGHTY TWO YEAR THEY DON'T KNOW
ABOUT WHEN THEY FIRST GOT THERE
AND THE GUIDED PATHWAYS
INITIATIVE IS SUPPOSED TO GET
STUDENTS RIGHT WHEN THEY COME
IN.
AND HELP THEM HAVE A GUIDED
PATHWAYS MEANING YOU KNOW VERY
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING WHAT COURSES
THEY NEED TO TAKE WHEN. AND
MAKING SURE THOSE COURSES ARE
AVAILABLE. WHEN THOSE STUDENTS
WANT TO I NEED TO TAKE THEM SO
THAT THEY CAN COMPLETE ON A MORE
TIMELY BASIS AND ON THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AGAIN HAVE FUNDED. ABOUT PROGRAM
JUST ONE NOTE I WOULD AGREE WITH
HAUNTED IT'S NOT SYSTEM WIDE AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IT'S
NOT SYSTEM WIDE. BOTH BY
INSTITUTION AND ALSO BY. DUBBED
BY MAJOR SO SOME INSTITUTIONS
MIGHT HAVE THE THIRTY THREE FOR
TRANSFERRING THE PSYCHOLOGY
DEPARTMENT OTHERS WANT SO THAT
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT REALLY AN
EQUITABLE CHOICE FOR ALL
STUDENTS ACROSS.
SO LET ME ASK OUR CHAIRS REALLY
QUICKLY IS IS THERE ANY
POSSIBILITY OF AT LEAST GETTING
IT THE CURRENT INFORMATION WITH
WHAT WE WILL HAVE TO SAY BY THIS
SPRING. TO HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUSES
SAY THEIR LAST SEMESTER UP
BECAUSE THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
ALREADY MADE THAT THE.
STEP TO GO TO A FOUR YEAR
THEY'VE ALREADY.
DONE THE APPLICATIONS WHETHER
IT'S YOU SEE YOUR CAL STATE BUT
THE STUDENTS ARE GOING TO GO TO
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE. MAY BE I.
TRYING TO MAKE THAT DECISION AND
IF THEY DO OVER THE SUMMER
DECIDE I'M GONNA GO TO JUST SAY
FULLERTON COLLEGE THEY STILL
MIGHT NOT KNOW ABOUT THE
TRANSFER DEGREE. OF OR ANY OF
THESE PATHWAYS AND NOWADAYS A
LOT OF STUDENTS DON'T GET TO THE
CAMPUS AND OTHER VERY FIRST DAY
OF CLASSES. BECAUSE THEY CAN DO
ALL OF THIS ONLINE SO IS THERE
ANY WAY FOR US TO HAVE.
TO DO TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THIS INFORMATION TO HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS.
I HATE USING THE WORD AND ALL
OF THEM OR NOT BEEN MAKING IT
AVAILABLE BUT I REALLY DO THINK
IF WE HAD JUST A. VERY SIMPLE
ONE PAGE INFORMATION ABOUT
PATHWAYS IN THE TRANSFER BEFORE
THEY EVEN GET TO SIGNING UP
THEY'D AT LEAST KNOW THAT THAT'S
AVAILABLE.
NO I IF I COULD ANSWER.
I REMEMBER AS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER OF WHEN THE CSU SYSTEM
WAS GIVING.
.
THE ASSESSMENT TEST.
TWO I SCHOOL SENIORS AS PART OF
THEIR OTHER TESTING.
AND AND THAT WAS WORK DENSE SO
THAT STUDENTS ALL SENIORS WHO
WERE TAKING THE.
I FORGET WHICH ASSESSMENT TESTS
WERE ABLE TO TAKE THE CSU
ASSESSMENT TESTS AS THE UP AS
PART OF THAT I THOUGHT THAT WAS
HELPFUL. AND SO CERTAINLY MISS
QUIRK SILVA I THINK THAT BOTH
CSU AND YOU SEE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO FIND A WAY. TO GET THAT
INFORMATION TO US. ALL HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS BEFORE THEY
GRADUATE AND WE CAN WORK WITH
THEM ON THAT BECAUSE I THINK ANY
WE ALWAYS TALK BIG GLOBAL KIND
OF CHANGES BUT THIS CAN BE VERY
SIMPLE. WHERE AGAIN FOR THAT
GROUP OF STUDENTS WHO IS NOT
SURE WHAT THEY'RE DOING NEXT BUT
MIGHT CHOOSE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CUT THAT THEY KNOW
BEFORE THEY EVEN LOOK AT THE
OFFERED? TO AN EIGHTIES ARE
THERE THAT THE COURSEWORK THAT
HEY IF I CHOOSE THIS TRANSFER
EVEN IF IT MAY NOT BE ALL OVER
AT LEAST THEY HAVE A PATHWAY
INTO THE FOUR YEAR. BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE SEEN MANY
MANY STUDENTS I WOULD SAY MORE
MALES THAN FEMALES.
SPENDING FIVE AND SIX YEARS AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE A LOT OF
IT IS THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO BUT A LOT OF IT IS
THEY START TAKING COURSEWORK.
THAN THEY REALIZE ALL I DON'T
REALLY NEED THAT THEY MIGHT SEE
A COUNSELOR COULD BE A YEAR INTO
THEIR EYES THEY DROP CLASSES AND
WE'RE JUST SEEING THAT THAT
STUDENT SUCCESS WHERE. THEY WANT
TO BE THERE MAY BECAUSE THEIR
PARENTS ARE TELLING THEM BUT
THEY JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO AND AND IT'S TAKING
THEM A LONG TIME IF THEY EVER
TRANSFER.
THANK YOU.
BUT YOUR QUESTION YOU CAN.
I HAD TWO QUESTIONS.
.
RANDY I THINK YOU MENTIONED
YOU'VE MADE THE STATEMENT A A
LACK OF THE PUBLIC AGENDA FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND.
ONE OF THINGS THAT HAS STRUCK
ME MOST.
AS CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
IN MY SEVERAL YEARS NOW SERVING
AS THE CHAIR UMPIRE EDUCATION IS
THAT WE DO NOT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ANYMORE. HAVE AN
OVERRIDING A UMBRELLA GROUP.
WHOSE MISSION I WOULD THINK
WOULD BE TO SET THAT AGENDA TO
SEE HOW THE DIFFERENT SEGMENTS
WORK TOGETHER.
SO I MAKE REFERENCE TO. WHEN WE
GOT RID OF SEPAK.
I'D THE POST CALIFORNIA PUT
SECONDARY EDUCATION COMMISSION
BEFORE WE GOT HERE YES AND THERE
HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT.
ATTEMPTS
BY THE LEGISLATURE BOTH IN THE
SENATE.
A TO TRY TO CREATE SUCH AN
ENTITY.
SO THAT STRIKES ME.
VERY MUCH THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
SUCH AN ENTITY ANYMORE AND SO
THEREFORE WHERE WITH THE AGENDA
COME FROM.
ALSO WITH THAT.
THE ABSENCE OF A STATE
COORDINATING BODY FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. ALSO CONCERNS EXISTS
BUT THE STATE STILL HAS LIMITED
DATA CAPACITY.
WHICH COULD IMPACT OUR ABILITY
TO ASSESS DEGREE AND PAYMENT
INPUTS AND OUTPUTS
SO MY QUESTION. IS DO YOU HAVE
ANY SUGGESTIONS ON WAYS THAT
THIS CAN BE ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE VERY VERY STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF THE STATE.
HAVING A NEW BETTER VERSION OF
WHAT WAS THAT CALIFORNIA POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION COMMISSION.
THAT ENTITY REALLY.
IS A SIGNIFICANT INSOFAR AS IT
DOES HAVE THE ABILITY IF
CONSTRUCTED PROPERLY TO BE ABLE
TO SET A PUBLIC AGENDA FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION ONE THAT WOULD
BE INFORMED BY CERTAINLY.
THE VIEWS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION BUT ALSO
ONE THAT REALLY IS LOOKING OUT
ACROSS ALL OF OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION.
SEGMENTS TO UNDERSTAND HOW FAR
ARE WE GETTING ON THIS DEGREE
ATTAINMENT GAP AT WHAT RATE WHAT
KINDS OF POLICIES COULD BE IN
PLACE WHAT THE CAPACITY
CONSTRAINTS WE FACE HOW WOULD
YOU SOLVE FOR THOSE WHERE THE
CAPITAL NEEDS OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS. WE ACTUALLY THE
STATE HAS NO FUNCTION FOR
FIGURING OUT ANY OF THAT.
I KNOW MISTER BERMAN IS HAVING
HIS HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE MASTER PLAN AND THE MASTER
PLAN ORIGINALLY DESIGNED. THAT
THE SEAT SEE PACKETS THAT AS IT
EXISTED BUT OVER TIME SEE PACK.
A ROAD FOR A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
REASONS AND NOW WE ACTUALLY FROM
THE HAVE INSTITUTIONS THAT I
THINK ARE DOING THEIR BEST BUT
IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW THAT ACTUALLY
RELATE TO THE STATES GOALS BOMB
RELATIVE TO THE INCREDIBLE LEVEL
OF INVESTMENT MAYBE NOT AS MUCH
AS WE MIGHT LIKE. TO SEE BUT
THEY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT THAT
THE STATE MAKES AND HIGHER
EDUCATION AND ALSO RELATES TO
THE SIZE AND SCOPE AND SCALE AND
DIVERSITY OF OUR POPULATION AND
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO BOTH
SUPPORT THOSE STUDENTS. AND MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN WHAT THOSE STUDENTS ARE
DOING AND OUR BROADER ECONOMY A
ONE THINKS HE PACKED INTO WAS TO
THINK ABOUT ECONOMIC CONCERNS AT
ALL IT WAS VERY JUST SINGULARLY
FOCUSED ON THE INSTITUTIONS. AND
IF THERE WERE ANOTHER STATEWIDE
COORDINATING ENTITY I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT BOTH THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE RELATIONSHIP IS A CROSS
BETWEEN INSTITUTIONS WHAT THOSE
NEEDS ARE FOR STUDENTS AND
INSTITUTIONS. AND WHAT THE NEEDS
OF THE ECONOMY ARE BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY THE ROBUST.
KIND OF AGENCY OR OR FUNCTION
THAT WE NEED I THINK AS A STATE
SO.
CALIFORNIA COMPETES IS DONE A
FAIR AMOUNT OF WORK ON WHAT IT
WOULD LOOK LIKE CALIFORNIA'S ONE
OF TWO STATES IN THE NATION THAT
DOES NOT HAVE SUCH A
COORDINATING ENTITY.
AND WE'D BE VERY MUCH
SUPPORTIVE OF TRYING TO HELP
FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT WOULD WORK
BEST FOR CALIFORNIA GIVEN WHERE
WE ARE TODAY.
IT CERTAINLY SEEMS A THAT WE ARE
MISSING THAT HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO MY SECOND
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH YOUR
STATEMENT. ABOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
WHICH I REPRESENT.
AND AND LET YOU KNOW STUDENTS.
AND THEIR LACK OF ACHIEVEMENT.
AN AND I WILL NOTE THAT.
.
EVEN IN THAT STATEMENT UC
RIVERSIDE WHICH IN MY DISTRICT.
PROBABLY HAS THE VERY HIGHEST
A DIVERSITY OF ANY OF THE UC'S
AND PROBABLY GRADUATES NOTE BUT
A LARGE NUMBER OF BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN A GRADUATION. OF LATINO
STUDENTS
A EVERY YEAR AND DOES A GREAT
JOB WITH AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS.
AS WELL.
SO MY MY MY QUESTION IS HOW
IMPORTANT ARE LATINO STUDENTS TO
CLOSING THE.
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND.
WHAT ELSE CAN THE STATE DO?
I THOUGHT YOU KNOW LATINO
STUDENTS ARE CENTRAL TO CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP WHEN YOU
LOOK AND WE HAVE A DEMOGRAPHER
HERE WHO CAN TALK WITH US ABOUT
THAT THE CHANGING CALIFORNIA
POPULATION BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE COMPATIBILITY OF STUDENTS IN
THE STATE. INCREASINGLY.
THE LARGEST SHARE AM.
AND MANY OF OUR INSTITUTIONS
ARE LATINO STUDENTS AND SO WE
REALLY CAN'T GET TO.
TO THIS THIS GOAL WITHOUT
TAKING VERY SERIOUSLY THE GAPS
THAT WE IN THE DISPARITIES THAT
WE FACE BY RACE.
LATINO STUDENTS AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR
ARE AT RISK OF NOT GRADUATING
WHAT WE SEE IS A LOT OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS WHO WENT UP.
PARTICULARLY MEN WHO END UP FOR
OUR ATTENDING PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
MAKE THEIR WAY THROUGH OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONAL SYSTEMS.
BUMP INTO WE REALLY NEED TO JUST
HAVE A MUCH CLEANER FOCUS ON
WHAT KINDS OF STRATEGIES WE NEED
TED TO MOVE THROUGH THAT I KNOW
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM DRC YOU'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT A PROJECT THAT
THEY ARE LOOKING UP IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. LATINO WHICH IS
LOOKING AT HOW TO YOU AND MOVE
THE NEEDLE IN PARTICULAR ON
LATINO STUDENTS.
BUT I THINK THAT IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF.
OF OF THE STORY IN ABOUT TWO
WEEKS WE'RE GONNA BE COMING OUT
WITH A SET OF FACT SHEETS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES HAS
DEVELOPED ON RACE IN THE ECONOMY
THAT'LL SHOW SOME OF THE DID
THESE DISPARITIES BY RACE. AND
SUGGEST WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
REALLY MOVE STUDENTS BOTH
THROUGH THE PIPELINE AS WELL AS
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE IN THE
ECONOMY.
AND LASTLY A NOT A QUESTION BUT
A A STATEMENT AND THAT IS THAT
IT IS ALSO STRIKING TO ME. THAT
AT THE TIME THAT LATINO STUDENTS
MAKE SUCH A HIGH. A PERCENTAGE
OF THE POPULATION AND MAKE
CREATE SUCH A HIGH PERCENTAGE.
OF THE COLLEGE STUDENTS IS THE
EXACT TIME OR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DECIDES TO NOT FUND
HIGHER EDUCATION AT THE RATES
THAT IT HAS IN THE PAST.
THANK.
THANK YOU AND I WILL HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS LEVINE LIMON
BUT I WAS GOING TO FOLLOW UP ON
MISTER MEDINA'S QUESTION.
THE IT BUT JUST FIRST WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE WHOLE NOTION AS
FAR AS THAT THAT MASTER PLAN IN
THE TWELVE AND THIRTY THREE FOR
UC AND CSU RESPECTFULLY I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT AND. I
KNOW THAT MISTER BERMAN'S.
SUBCOMMITTEE I MEAN SELECT
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN TAKING A LOOK
AT THIS TOO BUT I I THINK WE
OUGHT TO ASK OURSELVES THE
QUESTION IS IS IS THAT THE MAGIC
NUMBER. SIXTY YEARS AGO YOU
DIDN'T NEED A DEGREE TO GET A
GOOD PAYING JOB IN A BE IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
THAT WAS NEVER CODIFIED THE AD
CODE IT WAS THAT A PLAN AND SO
THAT WAS THEN THIS IS NOW IN SO
I REALLY THINK WE OUGHT TO.
THINK ABOUT WHETHER THROUGH THE
OTHER A BUDGET PROSELYTIZATION
AND WHAT HAVE YOU. AND
STATUTORILY CHANGE THAT AND PUT
IT AND PUT IT IN AND ARE
CALIFORNIA.
THE EDUCATION CODE AS FAR AS I
HIGHER NUMBERS AND GOALS BECAUSE
REALLY REFLECT THE NEEDS OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW BY DIDN'T ASK
ON THE ON THE IN. THE NUMBERS
AND EQUITY ISSUES. YOU KNOW IT'S
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING FOR A LOT
OF US WE LOOK AT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN OUR COLLEGES
DON'T REFLECT IN THE
COMMUNICABLE JUST PRETTY GOOD
CSU. UP PRETTY GOOD TO YOU SEE
UP NOT SELF.
SO IF IF WE DID HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE UC LOOK AT THEM
GO FROM THAT THAT TWELVE AND A
HALF TO THE TO THE SEVENTEEN.
COULD WE EXPECT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A DRAMATIC IMPACTS IN
DIVERSIFYING THAT THE UC
POPULATION LIKE WE SEE AT CSU.
SO IT IS THE CASE THAT IF YOU
SEE HOLD AND MORE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES IT WOULD. HAVE A MORE
DIVERSE SET OF STUDENTS
ATTENDING SO IT WOULD GO PART
WAY.
TOWARDS CLOSING THOSE.
DIFFERENCES.
ABOUT AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
NEED BETTER HIGH SCHOOL
PREPARATION AS WELL SO THAT WE
HAVE. MORE LATINOS MORE AFRICAN
AMERICANS SPEND MORE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. WHO ARE? ELIGIBLE FOR
YOU SEE. EVEN AT THAT THE TOP
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF PERCENT OF
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO. AND
AGAIN THERE'S BEEN PROGRESS
MADE.
IF YOU LOOK AT A THREE G.
COMPLACENT BUT IT'S STILL NOT
SUFFICIENT AND THE GAPS REMAIN
QUITE QUITE LARGE.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER LIVING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU BOTH FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
THIS FIRST HOURS GONE BY REALLY
QUICKLY AND I REGRET THAT I NEED
TO DEPART. THAT I WON A COUPLE
COMMENTS IN OUR QUEST BUT BOTH
OF YOU BUT ALSO OF THE SYSTEMS
ARE THAT ARE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY LATER.
FIRST OF ALL. OF MISTER JOHNSON
YOU WOULD TALK YOU MENTIONED.
THE CS USE CHANGE IN THE
REMEDIATION POLICY WHICH I
APPLIED OUT WHICH IS A HUGE
BARRIER FOR STUDENTS JUST TO
TAKE THEIR GENERAL EDUCATION
MATHEMATICS REQUIREMENT SO
STUDENTS STILL NEED TO TAKE. A
G. E. IN MATHEMATICS.
.
AT THE CSU AND IT THIS
A HUGE BARRIER TO JUST EARNING
UNITS.
IS GONE BECAUSE ATTORNEY
REMEDIAL CLASSES EARNED ZERO
UNITS THAT THAT'S INSIDE PAY FOR
THAT DID NOT GET THEM TO
GRADUATION SO THAT IS A GREAT
MOVE BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
THE.
AT MISTER CHAIR OF MR MEDINA
HAD MENTIONED.
THE DEMISE AND END OF SEPAK
AND.
.
A LITTLE BIT OF A QUESTION OF
WHO SETS THE AGENDA NOW FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION WHICH I THINK
WE WILL CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH HOW WE COORDINATE THAT
BEYOND THE HEADS OF THE THREE
SYSTEMS.
BUT TAHT BUT IT IN IN THAT THAT
ABSENCE IN THE VOID.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS STEPPED UP
SOMEWHAT. AND DIE IN IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO ASK FOR
SOME HELP BOTH FROM YOU AS WELL
AS FROM THE SYSTEMS IN. HELPING
US LEARN FROM A LAW THAT I
AUTHORED LAST YEAR. ON HAVING A
TO POINT THE DOCTOR JOSI MADE.
ON WHETHER HAVING THAT THE THE
SEGMENTS
BE MORE CONNECTED WITH THE JOBS
THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR THE
REGION'S
AFTER THE EMPLOYMENT THAT'S
NECESSARY AND SO I AUTHORED AB
NINE FIFTY SEVEN. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES VERY.
UP QUICKLY.
CONNECTED WITH AN OBAMA ERA
PROGRAM TO BE TIED IN WITH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PORTS AND
MY BILL. OUT REQUIRED THIS
YEAR'S YOU REQUESTED THE YOU SEE
TO ENGAGE IN THE VERY SAME WAY.
AND IT'S TOO SOON TO LEARN WHAT
THE OUTCOMES OF THAT OUR.
IT BUT. BUT I THINK THAT IN A
FEW YEARS WE MAY HAVE A SENSE
BOTH OF HOW THE SYSTEMS HAVE
CHANGED THEIR COURSE OFFERINGS
IN THEIR PROGRAM OFFERINGS AND
OF COURSE IF THE. THE UPTAKE
FROM THE STUDENTS.
MATCHES
THE OFFERINGS OF THIRD THAT
SKILL DESIRE.
IS MATCHED AS WELL AS IF THOSE.
EVENTUALLY ENDED UP INTO JOBS IN
THOSE REGIONS
WHICH IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
NOT JUST FOR ECONOMIC SUCCESS OF
THE INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS BUT THE
REGION'S THEMSELVES.
AND DIED AND SO. IF I HAD PUT IN
TO THE BILL THAT WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY STUDY WEATHER AT ALL
CURRENT WOULD INTO EXPENSIVE AND
THEN WE PROBABLY WENT TO BELA.
AFFORD TO PAY FOR THAT BILL BUT
WE WILL NEED THE HELP FROM THE
SYSTEMS EVERYONE'S LAUGHING
BECAUSE THEY KNOW HOW THAT GOES.
CAN AND DOES SO THE HELP FROM
SYSTEMS AS WELL AS HELP FROM
OBSERVERS LIKE YOU WHO CARE.
TO SEE IN IN THE GOT COMING
YEARS IF THAT IN FACT
KURT I WOULD BE GREATLY.
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT I THINK WE
ALL WOULD WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THAT KNOWLEDGE.
AND LASTLY ANOTHER POINT THAT.
THAT MR MEDINA REALLY APTLY MADE
WHICH IS.
THAT.
THE RISE IN THE LATINO
POPULATION IS COMING AT A TIME
WHEN SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION. IS SLOWING
DRAMATICALLY SO IT'S IT'S NOT
GOING DOWN BUT IT'S GROWING AS A
SHARE OF THE STATE BUDGET. IT'S
LESS THAN IT HAD BEEN IN THE
PAST
AND.
IN IS DECLINING.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE POINTS THAT
WE HAVE TO JUST KIND OF.
TAKE A MEASURE OF THIS MOMENT
AND SAY HOW DO WE PREPARE
CALIFORNIA FOR A BETTER FUTURE
AND IT'S GOING TO BE GROWING
PUBLIC INVESTMENT NOT SLOWING
DOWN PUBLIC INVESTMENT. AND SO I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
REALLY.
STRONG COMMITMENT JUST TO THE
STATE IN ITSELF TO RECOMMIT THAT
TODD BACK GROWTH TO A LEVEL THAT
MEETS THE STATE'S NEEDS RATHER
THAN ON. IN A SENSE.
I AS COSTS GO UP THAT WE SHRINK
AWAY FROM COVERING THOSE COSTS
AND DIED OUT ALLOW FOR.
DOT FUTURE TO ALSO BE
DIMINISHED SO THANK YOU BOTH
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MS LOW.
THINK YOU AND I WANTED TO COME
AND SOMETHING THAT US SUMMER
CREEK SILVA HAD MENTIONED AND I
KNOW THAT AT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT I WORKED WITH ACTUALLY HAD
A EVERY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT WHO
KNEW THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND ASSESSMENT ON THE HIGH
SCHOOL CAMPUSAT THE STUDENT
WOULDN'T HAVE TO GO TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT THEY ALSO
HAD. KIND OF A DAY WHERE YOU
HAVE THE ADMISSIONS DEPARTMENT
THE TRANSFER CENTERS THE
FINANCIAL AID DEPARTMENT THE
COUNSELING SERVICES AND STUDENT
SERVICES COME TO TALK TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
SO I THINK THAT PERHAPS.
IF WE REFRAME.
HER QUESTION ABOUT YOU KNOW.
INTO IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE DOING.
AND AND WHAT KIND OF OUTREACH
AYE IS HAPPENING IN HIGHER ED
WITH HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS.
I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THE UC'S
HAVE THE EARLY ACADEMIC OUTREACH
PROGRAMS.
A AND THAT YOU KNOW SEE SACK
HAS THE THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
CAL SO PROGRAMS.
THERE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS.
THAT ARE HAPPENING IN SO MAYBE
IT'S TRYING TO IDENTIFY ARE
THESE CLUSTERED JUST IN CERTAIN
REGIONS AND NOT IN OTHER REGIONS
AND MAYBE THAT'S WHERE IT NOW IF
WE START TO DESEGREGATE SOME OF
THE DATA. MAYBE THAT TELLS US
SOMETHING ELSE.
BUT THERE'S BEEN A HISTORY OF
EFFORTS
TO REACH OUT TO STUDENTS EARLY
ON AND TO HELP THEM HAVE A PLAN.
UP HAVING SAID THAT AND WE KNOW
RIGHT NOW THERE'S A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT THE GUIDED PATHWAYS BUT
THE CONCEPT HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES HAVE STUDENTS HAVE A
PLAN. AND THAT'S NOT. A NEW
CONCEPT AND SO I GUESS THAT TO.
YOU KNOW. HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE THE CONCEPT ISN'T
NEW?
I WE'VE TRIED IT WE HAVE
TRANSFER AGREEMENTS WE HAVE YOU
KNOW THE A DEBT SEE WE HAD THE
CSU BREADTH REQUIREMENTS.
BACK BUT YOU KNOW HOW HOW DO WE
TACKLE IT BECAUSE THIS THIS
IDEAS BEEN AROUND FOR DECADES
THAT WE NEED TO REACH OUT TO
STUDENTS EARLY. BUT WE ALSO NEED
THEM TO HAVE A PLAN AND WE NEED
TO HELP THEM WITH THAT PLAN AND
I THINK WE'VE STRUGGLED.
IN HIGHER ED TO DO THAT WE'VE
MADE TUNES.
AND PERHAPS THOSE GAINS ARE
SUSTAIN WITH FUNDING AND THAT WE
SEE IT ROLL BACK ON AFTERWARDS
WERE LIKE YEA WEGOT OUR MARKS
UP YOU KNOW WE HAVE MORE
STUDENTS ENROLLED THERE MORE
APPLICANTS BUT.
HOW DO WE THINK ABOUT THAT NOW?
CAN YOU PLEASE. SO I AYE
MOONLIGHT AS CHAIR OF THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION WHICH I
GUESS I SHOULD HAVE SAID BEFORE
I STARTED.
AND SO I WANTED TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE KELSO
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT IS THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSIONS EFFORT
TO ACTUALLY GET THAT INFORMATION
TO STUDENTS EARLY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE COMPLETING THEIR
FAT CITED I WORKED FOR KELSO FOR
NUMBER YEAH HOW I LIKE IT I
LIKE.
IT RUNS IN PAGE.
SO I THINK THE COUNCIL BUT THE
PART AND IT'S ALSO TRUE IS YOU
KNOW THAT WE DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE
CONCEPTS FOR EVERY REGION IN THE
STATE.
AND WE ARE NOW THINKING ABOUT
IT THIS DO NAY COMMISSION HOW
CAN WE RETHINK THAT ARE WE
SERVING THAT THE MOST AT NEED.
IMMEDIATE STUDENTS AND YOU KNOW
IDEALLY WE'D HAVE A COUNCIL FOR
EVERY REGION BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES FOR THAT SO THERE
IS A RESOURCE CONSTRAINTS. ON
BUT WE ARE VERY MINDFUL
PARTICULARLY WITH THIS ISSUE
RELATED TO LATINO STUDENTS AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT RATES. OF.
TRANCE OR NOT TRANSFER BUT
RATES OF MATRICULATION INTO A
CUP COLLEGE WHERE WE HAVE GAPS
AND WHERE WE HAVE GAPS BY REGION
SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS ON.
THE AGENDA AND ON THE MINDS OF
THOSE OF US AT PEPSI SOCK.
IN TERMS OF GUIDED PATHWAYS I
THINK THAT.
IT IS TRUE THAT WE HAVE SOME
SENSE OF WHAT THE PATHWAY
PERHAPS OUGHT TO BE.
I THINK THEY'RE A COUPLE OF OF
REAL CONSTRAINTS DEL AND THAT IS
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
ENORMOUSLY COMPLEX HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST REALLY HARD
IT'S HARD IF YOU'RE STUDENT AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO DECIDE YOU KNOW
I'M AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACTS
AND I WANT TO TRANSFER TO MAYBE
A YOU SEE OR MAYBE A CS YOU. AND
GUESS WHAT THEY'RE NOT THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS FOR EVERY
INSTITUTION RIGHT SO I HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT COURSES I NEED
FOR THIS SCHOOL WITHOUT SCHOOL
AND FOR THE SCHOOL AND WHAT THAT
DOES IS THAT AND IT DRIVES
ENROLLMENT IT DRIVES GOD TIME TO
DEGREE. BECAUSE STUDENTS ARE
SPENDING LONGER IN SCHOOL TRYING
TO GET ALL OF THOSE COURSES SO
THAT THEY CAN THEN TRANSFER TO
THE INSTITUTION OR HAVE A
CHOICE.
CHOICE ABOUT WHAT INSTITUTION
THEM ON A TRANSFER TO SO THERE
ARE SOME REALLY LEGITIMATE
BARRIERS AND I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S THIS TENSION
BETWEEN THE INSTITUTIONAL.
DEMANDS FOR FOR ADMITTING
STUDENTS AND BOB THE PREPARATION
OF STUDENTS BUT I WOULD AGREE
THAT HAVING STUDENTS HAVE A PLAN
IS A PART OF IT BUT YOU CAN'T.
IT'S HARD HAVE A PLAN FOR FOUR
DIFFERENT OPTIONS
AND SO PART OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
SOME KIND OF STREAMLINING I
THINK ON THE OTHER SIDE. SO THAT
IT IS MUCH CLEARER TO STUDENTS
WHAT THE OPPORTUNITY STRUCTURE
IS IF THEY FOLLOW THE PLAN AND
THEY DON'T NEED HOW FOR
DIFFERENT PLANS.
CLINTON LET ME JUST ADD SO AS
USUAL I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
LONG THEY SAID.
.
I WOULD I WOULD IDENTIFY THREE
CHARACTERISTICS OF WHAT'S
NECESSARY AND WHY SOME OF THESE.
PROGRAMS AND INTERVENTIONS
HAVEN'T HAVEN'T. MET WITH LONG
TERM SUCCESS AS AS YOU MENTIONED
SO FIRST I THINK WE NEED.
COMPREHENSIVE
PLANS
ESTHER IS HIT BY COMPREHENSIVE
THAT MEANS ACTUALLY
UNDERSTANDING ALL THE WAY FROM
NINTH GRADE TO HIGH SCHOOL
WHAT'S REQUIRED AS WELL AS
WHAT'S REQUIRED. ONCE YOU GET TO
COLLEGE DEPENDING ON WHAT PATH
YOU WANT TO PURSUE THEIR. I'D
ALSO SAY UNIVERSAL IF WE CALL
CALIFORNIA THE UNIVERSE WHICH
CALIFORNIA OFTEN DOES BUT.
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS JUST THEY
CAN'T JUST BE ONE REGION OR ONE
PLACE OR ONE SCHOOL IT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE STATEWIDE ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO TELL A EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND EVERY COLLEGE IN
OUR STATE? AND THEN FINALLY
TIMING THAT HOUSE TO HAPPEN AT
THE RIGHT TIME IN A STUDENT'S
LIFE.
AND IN MANY CASES THAT MEANS
NINTH GRADE BEFORE YOU START
NIGHT GREAT ACTUALLY IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL SO THAT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO. WHEN YOU GET TO HIGH
SCHOOL UNDERSTANDING THE A
THROUGH G. COURSES IT'S HARD
ENOUGH FOR A COLLEGE EDUCATED
PARENTS TEND TO KNOW OKAY THESE
ARE A THREE G. THESE ARCADE
FRUITY.
LET ALONE FOR A STUDENT WHO
COMES FROM A FAMILY WHERE.
NONE NEITHER OF THE THAT THE
PARENTS HAVE GONE TO COLLEGE AND
SO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY I THINK
THEN THIS CALLS FOR
INSTITUTIONAL RESPONSES THAT ARE
STUDENT CENTRIC.
PROGRAMS AND INTERVENTIONS
RATHER THAN INSTITUTIONAL. ES TO
FIND FOCUSED AND WEEKS WERE
SAYING SOME OF THESE CHANGES
HAPPENING ALREADY SO FOR
EXAMPLE.
CAMPUSES THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CSU AND YOU SEE ARE THINKING
ABOUT COURSE SCHEDULES IN LIGHT
OF STUDENT DEMAND TO MEET THIS.
THAT THE PLANS THAT STUDENTS HOW
FOR THEM SO THAT STUDENTS CAN
ACTUALLY TAKE THE COURSES WHEN
THEY NEED TO TAKE THEM IN THE
NOT.
.
LOCKED OUT OF THE COURSE BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT SUFFICIENT ROOM SO
THERE'S SOME SIMPLE THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING. THAT SEEM TO BE.
ALREADY HELPING BUT THEY NEED
TO BE COMPREHENSIVE THEY NEED TO
BE.
ACROSS THE SYSTEM AND THEY NEED
TO BE AT THE RIGHT TIME.
I WOULD JUST WALK OUT AT ONE
NOTE THAT ADVISING IS ALSO A
HUGE PART OF THE THE.
A CHALLENGE THAT STUDENTS HAVE
IN TERMS OF COMING UP WITH THOSE
PLANS BECAUSE DESPITE THE
INCREDIBLE.
AND AND MY KIDS WILL TELL YOU
THAT EVERYTHING THEY DO IT
THROUGH THE COMPUTER IT'S REALLY
HARD THROUGH GOOGLE OR YOU KNOW
AN ONLINE. JUST AN ONLINE.
.
AT A TOOL TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY
HOW YOU'RE GONNA NAVIGATE THESE
VERY COMPLEX SYSTEMS AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE KIND OF ADVISING
ON THE HIGH ON THE HIGHER ED
SIDE OR ON THE K. TWELVE SIDE TO
ACTUALLY HELP STUDENTS IN NINTH
GRADE. OR TENTH OR ELEVENTH OR
TWELFTH GRADE FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT PATHWAYS.
YOU WE HAVE THE AND ANY
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE LOOKING AT
KIND OF OUT OF THE BOX ADVISING
MODELS.
WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOWOFF HOURS
WEEKEND HOURS.
I MEAN I FEEL LIKE I DO
ANYTHING TECH AND I GOT ONLINE
ADVISING NOW I DON'T KNOW.
IF THERE'S OTHER MODELS TO
CONSIDER.
LIKE I DON'T KNOW THAT I'LL BE
ABLE TO COME UP WITH ENDING ON
THE SPOT BUT I KNOW THAT WHEN
THE GOVERNOR HAD HIS INNOVATION
PRIZE. OF THE FIRST TIME WHICH I
THINK WAS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
OTHER WERE THINK WHERE ABOUT.
FIFTY NINE APPLICATIONS AND AT
LEAST FORTY TWO OF THEM REALLY
SPOKE TO GAPS IN ADVISING OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS UP AND
A LOT OF THE INNOVATIONS THAT
WERE THEN BEING PROPOSED WORK
INNOVATIONS TO GET IT HOW DO YOU
FIX THE ADVISING FUNCTION OR
IMPROVING ADVISING FUNCTION.
WITHIN HIGHER EDUCATION SO I
THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME MODELS
OUT THERE ON THE NOT BE HAPPY TO
KIND OF LOOK THROUGH IT AND AND
PASSED ALONG.
OF.
RANDY AND MISLEAD BONE.
YOUR DISCUSSION GIVES ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE I SEE
OUT IN THE AUDIENCE
A SEVERAL OF THE.
COLLEGE COUNSELORS OF THAT I
SAW LAST NIGHT AND.
AND TO MENTION THAT THIS IS
NATIONAL COUNSELING WEEK NOW
FULLER WEEK AND ALSO THE
MENTION.
OF YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER.
THE FACT
THAT AS WE TALK ABOUT COUNSELING
THE OVER BURDEN OF STUDENTS THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT THE
COUNSELORS. HAVE TO DEAL WITH A
IN THEIR LOAD SO THAT YOU KNOW
IF.
TEACHERS ARE FACING THIRTY SIX
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM
COUNSELORS OR.
LOOKING AT TWO THOUSAND.
STUDENTS A THOUSAND STUDENTS
THAT THEY HAVE TO ATTEMPT TO
MEET WITH. A ONCE A YEAR.
IN ORDER TO TRY TO DO THE
COUNSELING THAT THE ACADEMIC
COUNSELING THAT THEY DO SO I
JUST WANTED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE COUNSELORS AND. THANK THEM
FOR THEIR HARD WORK EVERYDAY DAY
IN AND DAY OUT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTIONS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION VERY VALUABLE AND
WITH THAT I'LL BRING UP.
ALEXANDER MAYOR FROM MD RC TO
DISCUSS THE GROWING BODY OF
RESEARCH SHOWING WHAT IS
EFFECTIVE AND SIGNIFICANTLY.
INCREASES THE DEGREE ATTAINMENT
AND OTHER STATES
HE WILL ALSO DISKETTES
SOME METHODS AND PRACTICES THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK IT
TEAR MEDINA AND THANK YOU
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ALEX MEHR NINE THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND NDRC.
NDRC IS A NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN
EDUCATION AND SOCIAL POLICY
RESEARCH ORGANIZATION.
WE'RE DEDICATED TO FINDING WHAT
WORKS TO IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
AND POST SECONDARY EDUCATION WE
EVALUATE PROGRAMS AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND WE TRY NEW SOLUTIONS
AND TEST THEM BASED ON RESEARCH.
WE HAVE OFFICES BOTH IN OAKLAND
AND IN LOS ANGELES AND WE'VE
TESTED MANY PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING A STATEWIDE
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
THERE ARE THREE POINTS ALLEN
EMPHASIZED MY RESEARCH BEFORE I
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE EVALUATED.
FIRST SHORT TERM PROGRAMS TEND
TO HAVE MODEST SHORT TERM
RESULTS
WELL THIS MEANS THAT SOMETIMES
FALL SHORT OF THEIR GOALS THE
FINDING STILL PROVIDE LESSONS
THAT WE CAN BUILD ON AND THE
PROGRAMS THEMSELVES ARE
HAPPENING ARE HELPING STUDENTS
ADVANCE. WHILE THE PROGRAMS ARE
OPERATING.
SECOND IT IS POSSIBLE TO
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE STUDENT
OUTCOMES.
WE'VE SEEN THIS A COUPLE OF
PROGRAMS THAT I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT AND HIGHLIGHT IN MY
TESTIMONY TODAY.
AND THIRD COMBINING AND
INTEGRATING MULTIPLE EVIDENCE
BASED STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
MULTIPLE FACTORS CAN BE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE.
MOST OF THE FINDINGS I'M GOING
TO DISCUSS TODAY ARE FROM
RANDOMIZED CONTROL TRIALS.
AND A RANDOMIZED CONTROL TRIAL
STUDENTS ARE RANDOMLY ASSIGNED
BY LOTTERY EITHER TO PARTICIPATE
IN A NEW PROGRAM. OR TO A
CONTROL GROUP.
STUDENTS IN THE CONTROL GROUP
CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN THE NEW
PROGRAM BUT THEY STILL HAVE
ACCESS TO ALL OF THE EXISTING
SERVICES THAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY HAVE ACCESS TO.
RANDOMIZED CONTROL TRIALS OF THE
GOLD STANDARD AND EVALUATION
RESEARCH.
THEY'RE THE SAME AT THAT YOU
THINK CLINICAL TRIALS TO
EVALUATE NEW MEDICAL TREATMENTS.
AND HERE IT IS EVALUATED A
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THESE INCLUDE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS LIKE PERFORMANCE BASED
SCHOLARSHIPS AND DIFFERENT WAYS
TO DISPERSE STUDENTS REMAINING
PAUL REFUNDS.
INCLUDE LEARNING COMMUNITIES
ENHANCE STUDENT SERVICES
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL VISITS TO
ADVISORS.
AND STOOD ON.
AND STUDENT SUCCESS COURSES
WE'VE STARTED INSTRUCTIONAL
REFORMS AND WERE NOW STUDYING
INCREASINGLY BEHAVIORAL
INTERVENTIONS AND COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAMS THAT COMBINE MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES.
WHEN WE LOOK ACROSS THE STUDIES
WE FIND THAT SHORT TERM PROGRAMS
THAT LAST FOR ONE OR TWO
SEMESTERS GENERALLY PRODUCE
MODEST SHORT TERM RESULTS.
HOWEVER WHEN SEVERAL THESE
PROGRAMS ARE COMBINED INTO AN
INTEGRATED STRATEGY AND WHEN
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE THEM FROM
SEMESTER TO SEMESTER THE TOTAL
EFFECT CAN BE DRAMATIC.
THE MOST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM WE'VE
STUDIED IS THE CITY UNIVERSITY
OF NEW YORK'S XCELERATED STUDY
AND ASSOCIATE PROGRAMS.
KNOWN AS A SAP.
A STEP INTEGRATES MULTIPLE
STRATEGIES
IT REQUIRES STUDENTS TO ENROLL
FULL TIME AND IT SUPPORTS THEM
TO DO THIS.
TUITION WAIVERS WITH TEXTBOOKS
WITH TEXTBOOK VOUCHERS AND WITH
THREE METRO CARDS THAT CAN BE
USED FOR UNLIMITED USE ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
A STEP ALSO PROVIDES
COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT SERVICES
SUCH AS REGULAR HIGH TOUCH
ADVISING. CAREER DEVELOPMENT
AND TUTORING.
A SAP IS BOTH AN OPPORTUNITY AND
AN OBLIGATION FOR STUDENTS.
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THE METRO
CARDS AND THE OTHER BENEFITS OF
THE PROGRAM
STUDENTS MUST BE WITH THEIR
ADVISOR TWICE A MONTH AND
SATISFY OTHER PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS.
THE PROGRAM LASTS FOR THREE FULL
YEARS.
OUR VALUATION FOUND THAT IT
NEARLY DOUBLED THE THREE YEAR
GRADUATION RATE INCREASING AT
FROM TWENTY TWO PERCENT TO FORTY
PERCENT.
NOW THESE ARE ALL STUDENTS WHO
ENTERED INTENDING TO EARN A TWO
YEAR DEGREE. AND THE SUB SUBJECT
OF REMEDIATION CAME UP EARLIER
ALL OF THE STUDENTS NEEDED
REMEDIATION. ACCEPTED NOTHING
AND NOTHING INSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM THIS IS ALL AROUND
SUPPORT SERVICES AND IT NEARLY
DOUBLED THE TWO YEAR COULD THE
THREE YEAR GRADUATION RATE.
GIVEN THE STRENGTH OF THE
FINDINGS UNION NDRC PARTNER TO
BRING A SAP TO THE A SET MODEL
TO OTHER STATES.
THREE COLLEGES IN OHIO HAVE NOW
REPLICATED THE PROGRAM AND THE
EARLY RESULTS ARE VERY
PROMISING.
BY JUST A SECOND SEMESTER THE
PROGRAM INCREASED ENROLLMENT BY
TWELVE PERCENTAGE POINTS AND
INCREASED FULL TIME ENROLLMENT
BY TWENTY FOUR PERCENTAGE
POINTS.
STUDENTS ARE ALSO EARNING MORE
CREDITS.
THESE RESULTS ALIGN CLOSELY WITH
WHAT WE OBSERVED AT A SIMILAR
TIME POINT IN THE ORIGINAL CUNY
A STEP PROGRAM.
WE ARE NOW WORKING WITH TWO
OTHER COLLEGES TO IMPLEMENT A
SAP INCLUDING SKYLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DETROIT CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WHICH ADMINISTERS
THE DETROIT PROMISE PROGRAM.
THE DETROIT PROMISE PROGRAM
COVERS TUITION AND FEES FOR
DETROIT PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES.
ALTHOUGH THE PROMISE PROGRAM
HELPS STUDENTS ENROLL IN COLLEGE
TWO IF YOU STAY IN SCHOOL AND
TOO FEW GRADUATE.
TO IMPROVE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES THE
CHAMBER AND MY ORGANIZATION AND
THEY ARE SEE PARTNER TO ADD.
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE EXISTING
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM THAT ENHANCE PROGRAM
INCLUDES CAMPUS COACHES WHO HELP
STUDENTS NAVIGATE ACADEMIC AND
PERSONAL ISSUES.
MODEST FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
EXPENSES WHICH A CONTINGENT ON
MEETING WITH COACHES TWICE A
MONTH.
BEHAVIORAL MESSAGING TO
ENCOURAGE SUMMER ENROLLMENT.
AND A MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM THAT TRACKS STUDENT DATA
STUDENT PARTICIPATION AND CAN BE
USED TO COMMUNICATE WITH
STUDENTS.
BY JUST THE SECOND SEMESTER OF
THE PROGRAM THE COMBINED PACKAGE
OF STUDENTS SUPPORTS HAD VERY
LARGE EFFECTS.
AND INCREASED ENROLLMENT BY
ELEVEN PERCENTAGE POINTS AND
INCREASED FULL TIME ENROLLMENT
BY FIFTEEN PERCENTAGE POINTS.
WE'RE NOW EXPANDING OUR WORK
WITH BRIGHT WITH PROMISE
PROGRAMS
WE'RE CURRENTLY PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THE FIVE
OTHER PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING TWO IN
CALIFORNIA THE LOS ANGELES
COLLEGE PROMISE AND THE RICHMOND
PROMISE.
FINANCING AND SCALING STRATEGIES
LIKE THESE CAN BE CHALLENGING.
DATA MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEMS ARE IMPORTANT AND THEY
CAN ALSO LEAD TO EFFICIENCIES.
THEY CAN BE IS THE MONITOR
STUDENT PARTICIPATION AND
AUTOMATE MESSAGING FOR FREEING
UP STAFF TIME SO THAT STAFF CAN
FOCUS ON MORE CHALLENGING
STUDENT ISSUES.
EVEN THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS THOSE LEAVE MANY
STUDENTS WITHOUT GOOD ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES AND THERE'S STILL A LOT
OF WORK TO DO.
AND THE CUNY A SAP EXAMPLE.
SIXTY PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS
HAD NOT EARNED A DEGREE AFTER
THREE YEARS.
SO WE'RE CONTINUING TO FAST NEW
APPROACHES TO FILL THE GAP.
THE DATA CENTERS MATHEMATICS
PATHWAYS IN TEXAS IS ONE
APPROACH
THIS IS A MAJOR INSTRUCTIONAL
REFORM OF DEVELOPMENTAL OR
REMEDIAL MATH.
INSTEAD OF TEACHING ALGEBRA TO
ALL STUDENTS THE PROGRAM OFFERS
STATISTICS
AND QUANTITATIVE PATHWAYS THAT
ALIGN WITH STUDENTS MAJORS.
AND STRUCTURES INSTRUCTORS ALSO
AVOID LECTURING AND THEY FOCUS
MORE ON INTERACTIVE FORMS OF
STUDENT LEARNING THEIR EARLY
RESULTS ARE PROMISING AND THIS
ALSO RELATES TO THE PROGRAM THAT
HANS MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION.
WE'RE ALSO TESTING A VARIETY OF
BEHAVIORAL STRATEGIES INCLUDING
INCENTIVES AND MESSAGING TO
INCREASE SUMMER MOMENTUM AT TEN
COLLEGES IN OHIO. AND A TEXT
MESSAGING STRATEGY TO INCREASE
POST SECONDARY ENROLLMENT AMONG
LOW INCOME ADULTS AT EIGHTEEN
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY CENTERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND FINALLY WERE ALSO
COLLABORATING WITH A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO INVESTIGATE PROMISING
STRATEGIES THAT HISPANIC SERVING
INSTITUTIONS IN THIS IS THE
PROGRAM THAT LINE I MENTIONED.
A KEY LESSON FROM OUR RESEARCH
IS THAT COMBINING AND
INTEGRATING MULTIPLE STRATEGIES
TO ADDRESS MULTIPLE FACTORS CAN
BE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE.
AS CALIFORNIA REVISIT THIS POST
SECONDARY PLAN
TO DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE
COMPLETION AND CONSIDERS
CONSOLIDATION OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS. THERE'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO INTEGRATE
RESOURCES AND ALIGN THEM AROUND
EVIDENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
QUESTIONS YOUR COMMENTS.
BUT A QUESTION TO.
.
IN INDIA STUDIES THAT YOU'VE
DONE AND AND OTHER STATES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
I I I.
I BELIEVE YOU FACE THE SAME
CHALLENGES OF FOR STUDENTS AND
ROLLING BUT NOT COMPLETING.
DEGREES.
SO WHAT WHAT HAS BEEN THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT YOU'VE
FOUND.
FOR STUDENTS IN AND COMPLETELY.
AND COMPLAINING THERE THERE ARE
A LOT OF CHALLENGES A STUDENT'S
FACE AND IT'S HARD TO PUT YOUR
FINGER ON ONE BUT I THINK
REMEDIATION IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES.
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BUT AS YOU KNOW AND IT'S WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT THE LAST DISCUSSION
ALSO A FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS.
STUDENTS ARE COMING IN AND
THEY'RE UNDER PREPARED FOR
COLLEGE AND THEY HAVE TO TAKE
REMEDIAL COURSES BEFORE THEY CAN
EVEN GET INTO CREDIT BEARING
COURSES.
SO WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK
AROUND THIS ISSUE WERE ALSO
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE RESEARCH CENTER ON A
NATIONAL CENTER TO START TO
STUDY STRATEGIES. THE
DATACENTERS MATHEMATICS PATHWAY
THAT I MENTIONED AS ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES THAT'S DESIGNED TO
CHANGE THE WAY DEVELOPMENTAL
REMEDIAL MATHIS TAUGHT. SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN PROGRESS THROUGH
MORE QUICKLY OR THINK VERY EARLY
PROMISING RESULTS WE HAVE
ANOTHER MAJOR STUDY AS PART OF
THAT CENTER WHICH IS AROUND
USING MULTIPLE MEASURES LIVE
RESULTS COMING OUT SOON FROM. A
SEVEN COLLEGE STUDY THE NEW YORK
STATE. BUT IT BUT REMEDIAL
EDUCATION IS A HUGE PROBLEM BUT
STUDENTS ALSO FACE A LOT OF
OTHER PROBLEMS AND AND FINANCIAL
THE FINANCIAL SIDE OF COLLEGE
CAN'T BE. UNDERESTIMATED.
AND SOME OF THE STUDIES YOU'VE
DONE HAVE BEEN AND AND.
SMALLER STATES IN CALIFORNIA.
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS A YOU
MENTIONED OHIO.
.
HOW WELL DO YOU THINK THAT THE?
STUDIES YOU'VE DONE OF THE
MODELS THAT YOU LOOKED AT ARE
APPLICABLE TO AYE CALIFORNIA AND
CAN THEY BE SUCCESSFUL. IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT THAT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION IT WE WE
PREDOMINATELY LOOK FOR PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SERVING LOW INCOME
POPULATIONS AND WE'RE VERY
FOCUSED ON. STUDENTS OF MINORITY
STUDENTS AS WELL. THAT THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE STUDIED OUR
GENERAL APPROACH IS AFTER WE
FOUND A PROGRAM THAT'S EFFECTIVE
WHICH I DETEST THAT AGAIN IN
MULTIPLE CONTEXT AND SO THE IDEA
THE A STEP PROGRAM THAT I
MENTIONED STARTED IN NEW YORK.
WE TESTED IN OHIO AND AND
THERE'S NOW PROGRAM THAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING ON IN CALIFORNIA.
AT SKYLAND COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
SEVERAL OF OUR OTHER PROGRAMS
WE'VE TESTED THESE AND MULTIPLE
LOCATIONS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND SO THE EVIDENCE SPACES
BUILDING I THINK A LOT OF THE
LESSONS THAT COME OUT OF THE
STUDIES ARE APPLICABLE TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND AND AND AS I ASKED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES YOU KNOW I AS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE.
.
AS A COMMUNICATIVE JE INSTRUCTOR
I I THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
ESPECIALLY AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL IS THAT STUDENTS
CANNOT OR OR NOT. FULL TIME
STUDENT
YOU NO I A THINK AT THE TIME
WHEN I WAS A STUDENT IN THE.
EARLY NINETEEN SEVENTIES WE WERE
ALL FULL TIME AND THE ONLY THING
THAT WE HAD TO WORRY ABOUT. WAS
GOING TO SCHOOL GOING TO BUT NOW
WE'RE SEEING STUDENTS
WITH JOBS. PERHAPS MULTIPLE JOBS
FACE SEEN.
CHALLENGES AND KNOW WHAT IF
THEY GONNA HAVE FOR DINNER.
.
SO THAT THE THE CHALLENGE OF
BEING FULL TIME I THINK IS
CRUCIAL. AND ANY STEPS THAT WE
CAN TAKE. AS WE DID LAST YEAR IN
THE LEGISLATURE. OF WOULD
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
SAYING THAT IF YOU'RE A FULL
TIME STUDENT WILL TAKE CARE OF
YOUR.
FEES I THINK IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
SKY.
I THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SO I I THINK THE
RESULTS ARE REALLY INTRIGUING.
AND WHAT I'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
SUCCESS OF SIMILAR PROGRAMS YOU
KNOW I USUALLY HERE WHILE WE DO
THESE TEN THINGS AND IT LEADS TO
THIS. LEVEL OF IMPROVEMENT AND
OUT COMES AND IT DO YOU HAVE ANY
SORT OF MORE FINELY GRAINED
ANALYSIS OF EXACTLY WHY IT IS
THESE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING OTHER
SOME.
PORTS THAT SEEM TO BE.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN OTHERS IS
THERE SOMETHING ABOUT THE
COMPREHENSIVE NATURE OF THE
SUPPORT SYSTEM SUCH THAT THAT
THE WHOLE IS GREATER THAN THE
SUM OF ITS PARTS I MEAN. OUT
WHAT WHAT CAN WE EXTRACT FROM
THIS AS FAR AS WHAT MOST
VALUABLE THAT THAT THAT'S A VERY
GOOD QUESTION AND IT'S IN OUT
THAT'S ONE OF THE REAL
CHALLENGES WE FACE BECAUSE IT'S
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT THE KEYS OUT
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT. BUT WE DO
TALK TO STUDENTS WE DO SURVEYS
WITH STUDENTS WE TRY TO GET OUT
THIS IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND WERE
ALSO. CONSTANTLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO LOWER THE COST
OF THESE PROGRAMS SO WE FIGURED
OUT NOW HOW TO DEVELOP WE HAVE A
COST TOOL THAT WE CAN START TO
SEE IF WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
PROGRAM LIKE. WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN DETROIT FOR EXAMPLE TO A NEW
AREA WE CAN START TO PRICE OUT
WHAT EACH COMPONENT WILL COST
AND THINK ABOUT THE PACKAGE AS A
WHOLE? BUT THERE ARE SOME THAT
IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION
THERE'S SOME GENERAL PRINCIPLES
LIKE THAT COME OUT AND I THINK
ONE OF THEM IS JUST THE
IMPORTANCE OF HIGH TOUCH
ADVISING THIS GOES TO AND WHAT
CHAIR MEDINA. MENTIONED ABOUT
STUDENTS WHO ARE PART TIME AND
FACING YOU KNOW MANY CHALLENGES
AN ADVISER CAN BE SOMEONE WHO
CAN HELP NAVIGATE THOSE KIND OF
CHALLENGES. BUT GETTING STUDENTS
TO ENGAGE WITH ADVISERS HAVING
ADVISORS HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO
TALK WITH STUDENTS IS A REAL
CHALLENGES AND SO WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN MANY CASES AND WHAT WE
STUDY TO PLACES LIKE UNITS THAT.
ARE WAYS TO ENCOURAGE STUDENTS
TO TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THOSE
SERVICES THAT WE KNOW CAN HELP
THEM ALONG BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT
THEM AT THE SAME TIME SO FOR
EXAMPLE METROCARD. IS A VERY
VALUABLE THING TO A STUDENT
IN AND OF ITSELF BUT CAN ALSO
HELP THEM I QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
FOR COMING.
AND SHARING YOUR
YOUR FINDINGS WITH THIS
THAT YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO
INVITE YOU SEE.
FORWARD.
AND IF A.
YOU WOULD PLEASE.
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES TO US.
WHAT?
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME VERY MUCH AND I WANT TO
START BY THANKING ALL OF YOU.
FOR THE SPORT THAT YOU PROVIDE
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IT IS ESSENTIAL AND IT IS
APPRECIATED SO. I BEFORE I
INTRODUCE MY COLLEAGUES I WANT
TO I'M KIERAN FLAHERTY AND THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
I BEFORE I INTRODUCE MY
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
JUST QUICKLY IF YOU PERSPECTIVES
ON THE CLOSING THE GAP SCENARIO.
AYE THEY REFERENCE IN THE PP I
SEE RECORD OBVIOUSLY ELIGIBILITY
TRANSFER COMPLETION RATES.
I AND I DO WANNA TOUCH A LITTLE
BIT ON THAT.
MISTER JOHNSON PROVIDED SOME
GOOD INFORMATION AND SOME GOOD
NUMBERS AND I WANT TO RELATE
THAT A LITTLE BIT TO THE SUPPORT
THE STATE HAS PROVIDED.
SEND THE BUDGET ACTS OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE
IS A TARGET SAID OF ENROLLING
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS.
IN RESPONSE THE UNIVERSITY AND
ROLLED OVER TEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE SO
WE'VE MADE SOME SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS WHEN IT COMES TO
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AT THE
UNDERGRADUATE LEVEL. THE STATE
ALSO.
ONCE AGAIN STARTED PROVIDING.
FUNDS SPECIFICALLY FOR GRADUATE
INSTRUCTION GRADUATE ENROLLMENT
SO WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT
CONTRIBUTION. ON.
THE NEXT POINT THAT I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE IS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE PAMELA IS GONNA SPEAK
A BIT ABOUT THE RECENT CONTINUED
INCREASES IN GRADUATION RATES.
THAT'S EVEN SINCE THE TIME THAT
THE PP I SEE REPORT HAS COME OUT
SO I LET HER HANDLE THAT.
BUT OBVIOUSLY ENROLLMENT GROWTH
AS WELL AS OUR CURRENT
ENROLLMENT AYE REQUIRES
CLASSROOMS LABORATORIES
INFRASTRUCTURE SO CAPITAL
OUTLAY.
AYE THE REPORT THAT YOU SEE
SUBMITTED LAST YEAR ESTIMATED
THAT AT LEAST TWO POINT FIVE TO
THREE BILLION IN CAPITAL
INVESTMENT. WOULD BE NEEDED TO
ACCOMMODATE THE ANTICIPATED
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT'S THE
ADDITIONAL I THE ONE HUNDRED
PLUS STUDENTS THAT WERE
REFERENCED IN THE IN THE REPORT
ON TOP OF. WHAT UC'S CURRENT
PROPOSE NEEDS OF FIVE POINT SIX
BILLION FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY? WELL
THOSE ARE A LOT OF BIG NUMBERS
BUT WHAT WE WANT TO TRY AND DO
TODAY IS TRANSLATE WHAT THOSE
GENERALITIES MEAN FOR STUDENTS
AND THE CAMPUS.
SO WE THOUGHT HAVING OUR AYE.
WE NEED OF FINANCE AT THE DAVIS
CAMPUS AYE KELLY RATLIFF OUGHT
TO SORT OF ILLUSTRATE FOR YOU EN
AND PUT A LITTLE BIT A MEANING
BEHIND THE NUMBERS FROM A
STUDENT CAMPUS PROSPECTIVE.
BOB SAW THIS CLOSE BY SAYING
THAT WE WANT TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING OUR CURRENT AND FUTURE
STUDENTS WITH THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED. AYE THIS INCLUDES OF
COURSE OUR PARTNERSHIP ON
FINANCIAL AID.
WITH THE STATE AND THE
INSTITUTIONAL AID BOTH.
WE REALLY DO WANT TO HIRE MORE
FACULTY IN ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OTHER IMPACTS OF ENROLLMENT
GROWTH INSURE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN GRADUATION
RATES. OUT SOME OF THESE OTHER
THINGS SO ALLOW MY COLLEAGUE
PAMELA BROWN WHO IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR INSTITUTIONAL
RESEARCH IN ACADEMIC PLANNING.
FOR THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT TO TAKE OVER FROM
THERE SONY PAMELA. THANK YOU
KAREN I AM IN MY ROLE AS A VICE
PRESIDENT FOR INSTITUTIONAL
RESEARCH AND ACADEMIC PLANNING I
REPORT TO THE PROVOST AND
PROVIDE DECISION SUPPORT FOR YOU
SEE LEADERSHIP. AND FOR THE
CAMPUSES AS WELL A AS PART OF
THAT WORK MY OFFICE WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PUTTING TOGETHER
THE REPORT THAT THAT YOU SEE
TODAY. UP I THINK UP PP I SEE
NDRC CALIFORNIA COMPETES FOR
THEIR.
INFORMATION AND APPRECIATE THIS
TIME TO HAVE THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION WE'VE BEEN HAVING
SIMILAR DISCUSSIONS WITHIN THE
UC SYSTEM AS WELL. A AYE ALONG
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
PROVOST OFFICE WITHIN ADMISSIONS
AND DIVERSITY AND ENGAGEMENT
HAVE MADE TO PRESENTATIONS TO
THE BOARD OF REGENTS ABOUT THE
CHANGING DEMOGRAPHICS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT THAT MEANS
IN TERMS OF OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS
ARE WORK RELATED TO ENROLLMENT
PLANNING AND OUR CAPITAL NEED.
BUT IN ADDITION IN NOVEMBER
CHAIR OF BOARD CHAIR KEY FOR HAD
A REQUESTED THAT PP I SEIZE UP
PRESIDENT MARK ABOUT THE SORRY
AND DIRECTOR HANS JOHNSON. COME
A PRESENT THE RESEARCH THAT THEY
SHARED HERE TODAY WITH THE
BOARD.
SO THAT THEY WOULD UNDERSTAND
THE WORKFORCE SKILLS GAP THAT
IT'S A COMING UP. AND THEN IN
JANUARY PRESIDENT.
JANET THE PUBLIC TENDO ASKED
YOU CO P. LEADERSHIP AND THE UC
CHANCELLOR'S TO TAKE A LOOK
SPECIFICALLY AT THE PP I SEE
CHALLENGE. A UC CHANCELLORS ARE
TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT THEY MIGHT
BE ABLE TO DO TO ADDRESS THE
DEGREE GAP THAT. IS BEFORE US
AND OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING EARLY
ON IS THAT THE STRATEGIES THAT
CAMPUSES MAY TAKE MAY VERY.
IN SOME CASES SOME CAMPUSES ARE
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
ESTABLISHING PARTNERSHIPS WITH.
LOCAL UNIVERSITIES OR COLLEGES A
IN THAT AREA THEY MAY BE LOOKING
AT INCREASING OFF CAMPUS
PARTICIPATION IN INTERNSHIP
PROGRAMS LIKE YOU SEE DC OR ON
YOU SEE SACRAMENTO'S CENTER OR A
EDUCATION ABROAD. AS A WAY TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT AND ACCESS
OF BUT ALSO TO MINIMIZE THE
AMOUNT OF CAPITAL COSTS THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED TO IT TO MANAGE
THAT. OTHERS ARE GONNA BE
PRIORITIZING EFFORTS TO INCREASE
DEGREE PRODUCTION AND THAT'S
IMPROVING GRADUATION RATES.
REDUCING TIME TO DEGREE.
IN SOME CASES IT MAY BE
PROVIDING INCENTIVES FOR
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO GRADUATE
IN THREE YEARS. SO WHATEVER THE
CAMPUS STRATEGY IS THE OVERALL
GOAL IS THE SAME TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF DEGREES THAT WERE ABLE
TO PRODUCES A SYSTEM.
BUT TURNING TO THE REPORT THAT
WE PRODUCED IN THE SLIDES THAT
WE HAVE THERE THE FIRST ONE
THERE. IS THE PROPOSAL FOR WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE TO ACHIEVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND.
BACHELOR'S DEGREES THIS IS THE
SAME ONE THAT WAS IN THE YOUR
COMMITTEE REPORT.
IT SHOWS THAT THE ANNUAL
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THAT WE HAVE A
GO FROM WHAT WE HAVE TODAY ABOUT
ONE PERCENT. UP TO ALMOST FIVE
PERCENT OVER AN EIGHT YEAR
PERIOD THAT TRANSLATES TO ANNUAL
GROWTH OF ABOUT TEN THOUSAND TO
OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND A YEAR.
IT REPRESENTS NOT ONLY
UNPRECEDENTED GROWTH FOR THE
UNIVERSITY BUT IT ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF STATE
RESOURCES.
IF WE ESTIMATE THAT ONE AT TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH
ADDITIONAL STUDENT IN THE OUT
YEARS THAT WORKS OUT TO BE A ONE
BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR. ADJUST
FOR ENROLLMENT FUNDING IF WE
TOOK A LOOK AT WHAT OUR
ESTIMATES ARE FOR CAL GRANT
SUPPORT. THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION AND
THEN KIERAN ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THE CAPITAL COSTS THAT WE'VE
ESTIMATED ASSOCIATED WITH IT SO
TWO POINT FIVE TO. THREE BILLION
AN ADDITIONAL CAPITAL OUTLAY AND
THAT'S ON TOP OF FIVE POINT SIX
THAT WE HAVE ESTIMATED. AS NEED.
FOR THE NEXT FIVE TO TEN YEARS.
ANOTHER POINT THAT WE'D LIKE TO
pMAGNITUDE FOR OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WOULD MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY COLLEAGUES TO BE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE THEIR PP I SEE GOALS.
OF INCREASING THEIR ENROLLMENT
BY IT DEGREES AWARDED BY AROUND
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND. OF WE'D
BE TAKING A LARGER PROPORTION OF
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRANSFERS. THAT WOULD
TRADITIONALLY GO TO YOU SEE.
AND IT WOULD ALSO HAVE AN
EFFECT ON THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE MADE ON THEIR
GRADUATION RATES WE RAISE THIS
TO YOU BECAUSE WE BELIEVE AS YOU
DO. THAT PUBLIC EDUCATION HIGHER
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS AND
THE INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ARE ALL GOING TO
NEED TO COLLABORATE AND
COORDINATE. TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN MAKE PROGRESS IN
A CLOSING THIS DEGREE GAP AND
MEETING THE STATE'S FUTURE
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
THERE'S ANOTHER A COMPONENT I
DON'T WANNA LOSE SIGHT OF AND
THAT'S THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
A IF WE CONTINUE TO GROW
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREES WE NEED TO
ALSO INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE STUDENTS TO GET GRADUATE
DEGREES. AND IF WE TAKE A LOOK
AT THE SECOND SLIDE THIS PRESENT
SOME INFORMATION THAT WE'VE A
HAVE ON. AT THE PLANS AND THE
ACTUAL IS FOR I'M STUDENTS
GETTING GRADUATE DEGREES. OF OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT AROUND FORTY
PERCENT OF UC'S UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS ASPIRE TO GET A
GRADUATE DEGREE AND JUST OVER
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT AND THAT
DOING SO. WITH THE HIGHEST
PERCENT OF UNDERGRADUATES WHO
BOTH ASPIRE AND ACHIEVE TO GET A
GRADUATE DEGREE BEING ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS.
SO WE'D LIKE TO ADVOCATE FOR AN
APPROACH THAT WOULD INCORPORATE
BOTH BACHELOR DEGREE AND
GRADUATE DEGREE PRODUCTION IT
ALIGNS WITH PP IC'S RESEARCH
THAT CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST SKILL
GAP ARE FOR JOBS THAT REQUIRE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR HIGHER.
TO MEET THIS ONE POINT ONE
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL DEGREES
THE STATE IS GONNA NEED
ADDITIONAL TEACHERS WITH
MASTER'S AND PHD EASE.
IN ADDITION PP I SEIZE
IDENTIFIED GROWING FIELDS THAT
WILL NEED DEGREE RECIPIENTS THAT
REQUIRE MORE THAN A BACHELOR'S
DEGREES. FIELDS LIKE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND HEALTH CARE WHERE
YOU SEE PRODUCES OVER SEVENTY
PERCENT OF THE STEM DOCTORAL
DEGREES FOR THE STATE AND MORE
THAN SIXTY PERCENT OF THE
STATE'S GRADUATE MEDICAL. OF
PROFESSIONAL DEGREES.
YOU SEE GRADUATE STUDENTS
PRODUCE RESEARCH TODAY THAT
ADVANCES OUR ECONOMIC INDUSTRIES
INCLUDING AGRICULTURE
BIOTECHNOLOGY AND CLIMATE
SCIENCE.
THEY CREATE START UPS THAT
PROMOTE JOB CREATION. AND
TODAY'S GRADUATE STUDENTS ARE
TAKING ON CHALLENGES IN
PROVIDING HOPE FOR THE FUTURE.
INCLUDING UC SANTA CRUZ SARAH ON
SKITS AN EARTH SCIENCE GRADUATE
STUDENT WHO IS LOOKING AT WAYS
TO COLLECT WATER DURING FLOODS
AND BE ABLE TO STORE THAT
UNDERGROUND UNTIL THE NEXT
DROUGHT.
THEN THERE'S UCLA'S MACHEL
KELLER A HEALTH POLICY GRADUATE
STUDENT WHO'S ANALYZING BIG DATA
TO SEE HOW DOCTORS PRESCRIBE.
PRESCRIBED PAIN KILLERS.
BUT TO HELP HEALTH SYSTEMS CUT
DOWN ON A NEEDED OPIOID
PRESCRIPTIONS AND FLAG THOSE AT
RISK OF OPIOID ADDICTION. THOSE
ARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES OF THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT GRADUATE
STUDENTS ARE MAKING AND I MARCH
TWENTY FIRST YOU'LL HOPEFULLY
HERE FOR MORE DURING ARE YOU SEE
GRADUATE RESEARCH STAY THE IN
THE CAPITAL.
WE PRODUCED AN ALTERNATE
SCENARIO THAT WOULD BE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE AND COLLABORATIVE AND
STILL WOULD ENSURE THE STRENGTH
OF CALIFORNIANS WORKFORCE AND
THE STATE'S KNOWLEDGE BASED
ECONOMY. IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
SLIDE THREE. THIS SHOWS A
HEALTHY BUT MORE MODEST
ENROLLMENT GROWTH JUST OVER ONE
PERCENT A YEAR OR AN ANNUAL
INCREASE OF TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
UNDERGRADUATES AND NINE HUNDRED
GRADUATE STUDENTS BETWEEN NOW.
AND TWENTY THIRTY.
OUR INITIAL STE OTHER ESTIMATES
SHOW IF YOU JUST DID THAT THAT
WOULD INCREASE THE DEGREE
PRODUCTION BY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND FOR THE STATE.
THAT'S A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND BACHELOR'S DEGREES
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND GRADUATE
DEGREES AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN MAKE UP SOME OF THAT PORTION
OF THE BALANCE BY HIM WITH THE
APPROPRIATE SUPPORT.
FURTHER INCREASE OUR GRADUATION
RATES.
TODAY YOU SEE SIX YEAR
GRADUATION RATES FOR OUR
FRESHMAN IS EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT.
THE FOUR YEAR RATE IS EIGHTY
EIGHT PERCENT FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS THAT'S SLIGHTLY HIGHER
THAN ONE PP I SEE DID THE
ORIGINAL REPORT. OVER THE DECADE
WE'VE SEEN GREATER IMPROVEMENTS
WITH A ARE YOU SEE FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE FOR FRESHMAN.
THAT'S GONE UP EIGHT POINTS FROM
FIFTY SIX TO SIXTY FOUR PERCENT
AND THE TRANSFER TO RATE IT TO
YOUR RATE HAS GONE UP FIVE
POINTS FROM FIFTY ONE TO FIFTY
SIX.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
CAMPUSES TO SHARE RESEARCH AND
LEARN FROM THEIR PROGRAMS AND
STRATEGIES THAT THEY HAVE IN
PLACE TO IMPROVE UNDERGRADUATE
OUTCOMES AND EXPERIENCES. FOR
EXAMPLE WE KNOW THAT STUDENTS
WHO HAVE A LOWER SENSE OF
BELONGING HAVE LOWER GRADUATION
RATES.
UC IRVINE HAS A PROGRAM TO
WELCOME THE THE NEW FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS ON THEIR
CAMPUSES THEY HAVE THE FACULTY
THAT WERE FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS THEMSELVES WEAR TEE
SHIRTS SO THAT THEY CAN IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES. AND THAT PROVIDES A
WAY FOR THEM TO KNOW THAT THERE
WERE OTHERS THAT THEY CAN TURN
TO THAT MAY HAVE HAD SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES. THEY ALSO SERVE AS
MENTORS ON THE CAMPUS THAT
PROGRAM WAS EXPANDED TO OTHER
CAMPUSES AND THIS YEAR IT
OPERATED ON ALL OF OF ARE YOU
SEE UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES.
A AND HAS SHOWN SOME POSITIVE
OUTCOMES.
UC BERKELEY HAS A FALL PROGRAM
FOR FRESHMEN WHICH PROVIDES A
SMALL COLLABORATIVE LEARNING
COMMUNITIES. WITH ACCESS TO
SMALLER GATEWAY COURSES AND ONE
ON ONE ADVISING AND THAT'S SHOWN
THAT PARTICIPANTS IN THAT
PROGRAM HAVE SLIGHTLY HIGHER
GRADUATION RATES THAN OTHER
FRENCH FRESHMAN ENTRANCE.
AND IT UC RIVERSIDE OF THAT
INSTITUTION IS PARTICIPATING IN
THE UNIVERSITY INNOVATION
ALLIANCE A COLLABORATION WITH
TEN OTHER. UNIVERSITIES THAT ARE
STRIVING TO IMPROVE GRADUATION
RATES AND IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
IT'S FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE
HAS INCREASED OVER NINE POINTS.
FROM FORTYEIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
PERCENT.
IN ADDITION TO THAT RECENTLY
COMPLETED CAMPUS EFFORTS TO
REVIEW AND WHERE POSSIBLE REDUCE
UPPER DIVISION MAJOR
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE TOP SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT AND OF
UNDERGRADUATE MAJORS.
AND THE CREATION OF THREE YEAR
DEGREE PATHWAYS FOR TOP MAJORS
PATHWAYS THAT WOULD MAP OUT THE
COURSE SEQUENCES THAT STUDENTS
WOULD NEED TO TAKE EACH TERM AND
ORDERED GRADUATE IN THREE YEARS.
THOSE ARE TWO OTHER EXAMPLES OF
WAYS THAT WHERE UMP WORKING ON
TRYING TO POTENTIALLY REDUCE
TIME TO CREATE. IF WE WERE ABLE
TO MEET PEOPLE YEAH SEIZE GOAL
OF NINETY TWO PERCENT OF A
GRADUATION RATE. THAT WOULD ADD
POTENTIALLY ANOTHER FIFTY
THOUSAND DEGREES BRINGING THAT
TOTAL THAT WE HAVE UNDER THE
PROPOSAL A ON SLIDE THREE. JUST
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND.
SLIDE FOUR HIGHLIGHTS THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE IN AND MEETING THAT
GOAL.
ON THIS SLIDE SHOWS THE
PERCENTAGE OF NEW FRESHMEN THAT
A PELL GRANT RECIPIENTS ALONG
WITH THEIR GRADUATION RATES IT'S
A DATA THAT WAS RELEASED. EARLY
LAST END OF LAST YEAR AND IT
SHOWS THIS INFORMATION FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES
AND FOR THE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICAN UNIVERSITY PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS.
WHAT THIS HIGHLIGHTS IS THAT OF
THE UNIT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AT THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
PROVIDING UNPRECEDENTED ACCESS?
TO LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
THAT'S IN LARGE PART THANKS TO
THE SUPPORT OF THE CELTS AS
STATES CAL GRANT PROGRAM AND
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT.
CONTINUED IMPROVEMENTS IN THESE
GRADUATION RATES FOR THE
STUDENTS IS CRITICAL BECAUSE WE
KNOW AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT WITHIN FIVE
YEARS OF GRADUATING THE MAJORITY
OF PROGRAM RECIPIENTS GO ON TO
EARN MORE THAN THEIR FAMILIES
DID.
AS THE STATE GRAPPLES WITH
GROWING INCOME INEQUALITY
INVESTMENTS IN EDUCATION CAN
ADVANCE SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY. AS WELL AS SUPPORTING
THE STATE'S WORKFORCE NEEDS
BUT WE NEED MORE SUPPORT TO
ENSURE STUDENTS LIKE THESE ARE
ABLE TO SUCCEED. THE FOUR YEAR
GAP IN GRADUATION BETWEEN PALIN
NAM PELL RECIPIENTS ON OUR
CAMPUSES IS JUST OVER TEN
POINTS.
AND CURRENT STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
THAT GAP INCLUDE SMALLER CLASSES
GREATER USE OF TECHNOLOGY ACCESS
TO SUMMER BRIDGE ANOTHER SUMMER
PROGRAMS AN ADDITIONAL ADVISING
A MENTORSHIP OPPORTUNITIES THAT
REQUIRE GREATER INVESTMENT.
TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO THESE LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND CONTINUED TO
IMPROVE GRADUATION RATES
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL SUPPORT IS
NEEDED STARTING WITH FULL STATE
FUNDING FOR ENROLLMENT. AND
EXPANSION OF GUILT CAL GRANT
SUPPORT OVER THE SUMMER TO
SUPPORT LOW INCOME STUDENTS TO
BE ABLE TO ATTEND DURING THAT
TIME.
TO PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION ON
THE CAPITAL NEEDS IN THE CAMPUS
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR FINANCE
OPERATIONS AND ADMINISTRATION ON
THE DAVIS CAMPUS.
KELLY RATLIFF.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK.
ALL BE BRIEF AS MY COLLEAGUES
NOTED WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK AHEAD WITH
YOU ABOUT HOW THE UNIVERSITY CAN
CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE TO
MEETING THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
NEEDS.
I'M ALL BE ADDRESSING THE
CAPITAL MEANS ASSOCIATING.
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASING
DEGREE PRODUCTION ALL FOCUS ON
MY CAMPUS THE DAVIS CAMPUS.
AND GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES I
PROVIDED A LITTLE TWO PAGE
HANDOUT.
BUT FIRST LET ME MENTION OUR OUR
RECENT CLAIM TO FAME.
THAT'S SOMEWHAT COLORFUL
REFERENCE TO UC DAVIS AND LADY
BIRD THE OSCAR NOMINATED FILM BY
THE SAME NAME.
HE MIGHT KNOW IN THAT MOVIE LADY
BIRD.
ADMONISHES THE PROSPECTS OF
ATTENDING THAT BLEEP UNIVERSITY
OF FAMOUS FOR ITS BLEEP
AGRICULTURAL SCHOOL.
AND YOU KNOW IT IF IT'S A FAIR
REFERENCE WERE NUMBER ONE IN
AGONY AND NATION NUMBER TWO IN
THE WORLD.
BUT OF COURSE YOU SEE DAVIS'S
IS MUCH MORE.
THIS HALLWAY AND ROLLED OVER
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS
INCLUDING TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES OF THE
HIGHEST IN THE UC SYSTEM.
AND ANOTHER SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
GRADUATE PROFESSIONAL STUDENTS
ACROSS
FOR COLLEGES AND SIX
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS.
AS IS THE CASE FOR ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES WE'VE HAD A TREMENDOUS
PERIOD OF GROWTH LAST TEN YEARS
UC DAVIS IS IN ROWING TWENTY SIX
PERCENT MORE STUDENTS COMPARED
TO FALL TWO THOUSAND EIGHT JUST
TEN YEARS.
AND THAT GROWTH AND OUR CAMPUS
HAS BEEN GUIDED BY A TWENTY
TWENTY PLAN HOME WHERE IN
ADDITION TO GROWING CALIFORNIAN
ROMANS WE ALSO INCREASED
PROPORTIONATE NATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS.
BUT THAT PLAN HAD MANY GOALS BUT
PRIMARY AMONGST IT WAS OUR
ABILITY CREATING FUNDING TO
INVESTING CAPITAL.
AS WE TURN TO CAPITAL JUST A
BIT MORE.
CONTEXT FOR UC DAVIS
WE HAVE OVER FIFTY THREE HUNDRED
ACRES.
AND NEARLY TWELVE HUNDRED
BUILDINGS COMPRISING FOURTEEN
MILLION SQUARE FEET AND HUNDRED
THIRTY MILES OF INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S IN DAVIS IN ADDITION HERE
IN SACRAMENTO WE HAVE A HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE ACRES WAS SEVENTY
BUILDINGS. AND WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL FACILITIES THAT
SUPPORT TEACHING AND RESEARCH IN
PLACES LIKE BUT DEGARR TAHOE A
TO NAME A FEW.
SO IF WE IF WE THINK ABOUT
GROWTH I WANNA FIRST CONSIDER
CLASSROOMS THAT'S AN OBVIOUS IN
CRITICAL NEED FOR ACCOMMODATING
STUDENT GROWTH.
AND JUST TO INTRODUCE YOU TO OUR
BASE SCENARIO.
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A SIX YEAR
PROGRAM.
THAT'S RENOVATING OUR EXISTING
HUNDRED THIRTY CLASSROOMS.
WEARE INVESTING A TOTAL OF
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE SIX YEARS TO DO FLOOR TO
CEILING RENOVATIONS TO IMPLODE
PROVE THE STUDENT LEARNING
EXPERIENCE.
OTHERS THERE'S A COUPLE OF
PHOTOS AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
FIRST PAGE OF THE HANDOUT. SO
WHEN WE GO IN AND DO THESE.
PROGRAMS WERE TAKING CARE OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FOR REPLACING OUTDATED
TECHNOLOGY WERE PROVIDING SOME
FLEXIBLE SEATING AND AND OTHER
ARRANGEMENTS TO SUPPORT. A
MODERN INSTRUCTION.
APPROACH FOR USING IS TAKING.
ABOUT EIGHT TO TWELVE
CLASSROOMS EACH SUMMER TO DO
THIS FULL RENOVATION AND IT'S
HAD EXCELLENT SUCCESS.
BUT WE NEED A MECHANISM TO
SUSTAIN IT.
IN ADDITION TO CARING FOR THE
EXISTING CLASSROOMS.
ENROLLMENT GROWTH CREATES THE
NEED FOR NEW SEATS.
AND TEACHING LABORATORIES AND IF
YOU'RE CAMPUS LIKE UC DAVIS
ANIMAL SCIENCE TEACHING.
SO WE'RE DELIVERING HERE TO WERE
ADDING OVER FOUR THOUSAND SEATS
AND SEVEN FACILITIES.
TO CATCH UP TO THE GROWTH WAS
EXPERIENCED AND TO SUPPORT MORE
INTERACTIVE TEACHING.
THE NEW BUILDINGS ARE REQUIRING
INVESTMENTS TOTALLING OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION THAT'S
BEYOND THE RENOVATION PROGRAM.
SO THAT WE CAN MEET OUR TWENTY
TWENTY PLAN.
ANY ADDITIONAL GROWTH THAT
SUGGESTED BY THAT PP I SEE PLAN
WOULD REQUIRE SUBSTANTIAL.
INVESTMENT BEYOND THAT.
ANOTHER CATEGORY OF CRITICAL
NEED ARE LABORATORIES FOR
RESEARCH AND TEACHING.
SO CHAIRMAN OFFER CHEMISTRY AS A
CASE STUDY.
OR TOP RANKED RESEARCH
UNIVERSITY FIFTY SEVEN PERCENT
OF THE UNDERGRADUATES AT UC
DAVIS ARE IN STEM FIELDS.
AND THAT WERE LEADERS AND
DISCOVERY AND INNOVATION ACROSS
THE WORLD.
STEM OF COURSE REQUIRES
SPECIALIZED TEACHING FACILITIES.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED PLUS WET AND
DRY LABS SUPPORTING INSTRUCTION
AT UC DAVIS WITH CLASSES RUNNING
FAR INTO THE EVENING FOR MANY OF
OUR HIGH DEMAND COURSES.
YEAH OUR CHEMISTRY BUILDING
BUILT IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX HAS
NEVER HAD A FULL RENOVATION.
PROGRAMS OF TRIMMING.
PART ME CHANGED DRAMATICALLY IN
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THE BUILDING
IS LAGGING FAR BEHIND. AND OF
COURSE WHEN A BUSY CROWDED
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN RESEARCH AND
TEACHING FACILITY.
SO WE DEVELOPED A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN TO RENOVATE THE CHEMISTRY
BUILDING IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
AND OF COURSE THAT WAS THAT THE
STRIKE THE START OF THE FUNDING
CRISIS AND SO WE HAD TO SHELVE
THAT PLAN.
WE PULLED BACK OUT TWENTY
FOURTEEN WE WORKED ON UP A
REVISION OF THE PLAN TO INCREASE
CAPACITY OF THE EXISTING SPACE
BY TWENTY PERCENT. USING AN OPEN
MODULAR LAP CONCEPT.
THE STATUS TODAY.
WE'RE USING GENERAL FUND
FINANCING TO ADVANCE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION UPSIDES AT THE LIFE
SAFETY.
WERE ALSO INVESTING FIFTY FOUR
MILLION FROM CAMPUS FUNDS TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL EXHAUST AND
ELECTRICAL CAPACITY NEEDS WERE
CONSTRUCTING A SMALL ADDITION TO
GET DESKS AND FACULTY AND
RESEARCHERS RESEARCHERS OUT OF
LABS. AND INTO OFFICE SPACE.
AND WE'RE RENOVATING ABOUT TEN
PERCENT OF THAT CHEMISTRY
BUILDING.
TO DO THE WHOLE THING WE NEED
ANOTHER ELEVEN MILLION FOR A
SECOND PHASE.
OF.
.
WORK THAT WE'RE POSTPONING AND
THEN WE HAVE PHASES AND AN
ADDITIONAL THREE PHASES THAT
WOULD TOTAL ANOTHER HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION. TO. RENOVATE THE
WHOLE BUILDING.
WE HAVE TO PHASE BECAUSE WHEN
THESE ARE ACTIVE SPACES AND SO
IN ORDER TO AVOID DISRUPTION AND
MOVE FOLKS IN AND OUT IT TAKES
THIS PHASED APPROACH.
BUT.
THE SUBSEQUENT PHASES I'M
MENTIONING THEY'RE NOT SCHEDULED
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT FUNDED. AND
SO WE'RE GONNA GET THROUGH A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF PROGRESS IN
AND THEN WE'LL BE BACK PROBABLY
IN A LAP BY LAP BRAND OF PATIENT
MODE.
THE STORY OF CHEMISTRY IT'S
REPEATING AND ANOTHER SIX
BUILDINGS COMPRISING.
A HALF MILLION SQUARE FEET THAT
WERE BUILT IN THE SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES WE HAVE LARGE
BUILDINGS WHERE WE COULD DO MORE
ABOUT BUT WITHOUT.
PLANNING FUNDING THAT WE CAN
COUNT ON AND PLANNED FOR IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TO EXECUTE ON
THESE PLANS.
SO I'LL ALL END WITH THE
OBSERVATION THAT UC DAVIS WE
HAVE A VISION WE HAVE PLANS AND
WE HAVE GOOD FOLKS DOING GOOD
WORK.
TO BE SUCCESSFUL WHEN HE
PARTNERSHIP AND WE NEED STABLE
AND PREDICTABLE CAPITAL FUNDING.
AND WE'RE GOING TO DO ANYTHING
ALONG THE LINES I HAVE ADVANCING
THE PP I SEE GOALS MEETS TALK
ABOUT THAT CAPITAL FUNDING. UP
FRONT SO THAT WE REALLY CAN
EXECUTE AND HAVE THOSE
FACILITIES AVAILABLE AS THE
STUDENTS ARRIVE.
THANK YOU.
QUESTION.
THE CHECK SHARE.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
REFERRING TO SLIDE ONE.
THAT YOU HANDED OUT HERE YOU
HAVE THE THE THIRD BULLET POINT
ESTIMATED GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION INCREASE OF ONE
BILLION A YEAR FOR INVOLVEMENT.
WAS. WHAT WHAT IS THE CURRENT?
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION FOR
ENROLLMENT.
I THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO
THAT CURRENT GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION FOR THE UNIVERSITY
IS.
A LITTLE BIT OVER THREE POINT
FOUR BILLION.
THAT UNIVERSITY RECEIVES.
TO PRIMARY SOURCES OF FUNDS FOR
WHAT WE CALL OUR CORE BUDGET
ABOUT STATE GENERAL FUND THAT I
JUST REFERENCED AND THEN.
TUITION AS WELL AYE THERE ARE
SOME OTHER.
FUNDS THAT GOING TO YOU SEE
WHAT WE CALL YOU SEE GENERAL
FUND SOME PATENT INCOME THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS. ABOUT THAT THAT
CONSTITUTES OUR COURT BUDGET AND
THAT IS WHAT WE EXPAND FROM FOR
OUR AYE INSTRUCTION.
AND RESEARCH PURPOSES SO SO IN
OTHER WORDS IN ORDER TO.
ACCOMPLISH A.
THE TO A FIFTY THOUSAND MORE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES BY TWENTY
THIRTY WE WILL HAVE TO INCREASE
THE.
BY BYE ALMOST TOOK.
.
BUT MORE THAN A THIRD.
MORE THAN THIRTY PERCENT.
YEAR FOR ENROLLMENT.
SO OUR ESTIMATE IS THAT.
AND ACHIEVING THAT AMOUNT OF
ENROLLMENT IT WOULD TAKE.
AT BILLION ADDITIONAL AS A BASE
ON GOING.
BUDGET THAT I. ADDITIONAL AYE
AYE AUGMENTATION ARE BASED ON
GOING BUDGET YES
SO BASED ON AND.
.
WHAT WE CALL I'D A STATE CHAIR
MARGINAL COST OF INSTRUCTION IF
WE ESTIMATE THAT WE'RE EXPANDING
ABOUT?
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
TO EDUCATE A STUDENT.
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND OF THAT
AMOUNT IS I SPENT FOR FINANCIAL
AID PURPOSES.
WHICH BRINGS US DOWN TO AROUND
THAT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN RANGE.
IF ABOUT THIRTEEN OR SO.
OF THAT OF THOSE DOLLARS ARE
ARE COMING IN FROM.
STUDENTS TO ASH AND.
THE BALANCE IS WHAT WE
CONSIDERED TO BE A STATE CHAIR
ROCK COMBINED WITH TUITION AND.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
CUMULATIVE INCREASE IN
ENROLLMENT OF A HUNDRED AND SIX
THOUSAND YOU ASSUME THE TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT
THAT GETS YOU OUT TO UP MOUNT.
OKAY SO.
.
BUT OF THE THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION IN THE CURRENT GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION AND NOT ALL
OF THAT IS GOING TOWARD
ENROLLMENT CURRENT.
THAT'S CORRECT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF IT THAT
IT'S GOING FOR CAPITAL FOR.
FINANCING FOR CAPITAL PURPOSES.
AND I THINK.
PROBABLY.
PAMELA MIGHT BE ABLE TO TELL US
AYE HOW MUCH OF OUR EXPAND.
FOR FACULTY SALARIES FOR STAFF
SALARIES IS ATTRIBUTABLE TO.
STATE GENERAL FUND.
WHO?
ACTUALLY I HAVE YET WE WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO INTO THAT IN DETAIL
NOW I AM JUST TRYING TO GET A.
YOU KNOW I GOT A. IN OVER A
REALITY CHECK HERE OF HOW MUCH
MORE MONEY.
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE
THE TO INVADE THOUSAND MORE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES.
.
THIS IS SO SO THE ONE BILLION A
YEAR OF THAT. THAT WOULD BE THAT
THAT THAT BASICALLY ONE BILLION
IN ADDITIONAL CHAU OFF AN
APPROPRIATION TO INCLUDE
ENROLLMENT AS WELL AS.
.
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
NO CAP THE CAPITAL OUTLAY WOULD
BE SEPARATE SO I WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ENROLLMENT GROWTH
WE GENERALLY TRY AND USE.
BASICALLY AIR RIGHT.
IN AMOUNTS THAT.
WE ATTRIBUTE APPORTIONED IT
TUITION AND A PORTION TO STATE
CONTRIBUTION.
TO ADDRESS WHAT IT COST TO
EDUCATE ONE ADDITIONAL NEW
STUDENT ON AN ONGOING BASIS.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE COME UP WITH
THE E. TEN THOUSAND PER STATE
STUDENT AS SORT OF A HISTORICAL
STATE SHARE. THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED SO FOR INSTANCE WHEN
THE YOM.
STATE PROVIDED ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING RECENTLY FOR AYE
GRADUATE STUDENTS
I BELIEVE WE LANDED ON SIX
HUNDRED GRADUATE STUDENT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FOR SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN THAT BUDGET
THERE WAS.
A COUPLE DIFFERENT GOING ON BUT
THAT WOULD BE TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
AND THAT'S WHY WITH THE OTHER
PROPOSAL THAT WE'VE PROVIDED
WHICH HAS BOTH GRADUATE AND
UNDERGRADUATE GROWTH.
THAT WE CALL THAT A MORE MODEST
PROPOSAL IT STILL WOULD REQUIRE
A SIGNIFICANT.
OUTLAY IN FUNDS IT BE ABOUT
HALF OF WHAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
IF WE JUST DID A.
pTHERE.
AND OUR OUR FEELING ABOUT
SOMETHING ALONG THIS PRO
APPROACH BY LOOKING AT GRADUATE
STUDENTS IN ADDITION TO
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS AT BOTH
SUPPORTS THE EDUCATION OF THE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS. IT MEETS
THE WORK FORCE THEN AND ECONOMIC
NEEDS OF THE STATE MOVING AHEAD.
AND.
OF WOULD HAVE A BETTER BALANCE
FOR US AS WE LOOKED AHEAD.
SO IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE FOR THE
ALTERNATE SCENARIO. OF HOW MUCH
MORE OF A GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION INCREASE ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT SO IT'S ABOUT HALF
OF. WHAT WOULD BE REQUIRED UNDER
THERE SO AROUND ON FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION HEALTH?
I THINK IT.
I LIKE THAT ASK A QUESTION ABOUT
THE A PROPOSAL.
OF INCREASING.
THE. PERCENTAGE OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES
SO IN THE MASTER PLAN THE
NINETEEN SIXTY. MASTER PLAN WHAT
WE'RE IT TWELVE POINT FIVE
CRACKED.
.
WE HEARD TESTIMONY THAT.
GOING TO SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE.
WOULD INCREASE THE DIVERSITY OF
STUDENTS AND ALSO ADDRESS.
MORE OF THE SOCIO ECONOMIC
DISPARITY.
OF OF STUDENTS.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON.
MOVING THE THAT THE PERCENTAGE
OF HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES US SO
IF WE LOOK AT WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS THE LARGEST. GROWING
POPULATION OF OUR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS ARE CHICANO LATINOS AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT WILL
CONTINUE UNDER EITHER THE
PROPOSALS AND THAT WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY. THE FIRST
PROPOSAL THE ONE WITH BACHELOR'S
ONLY FOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND THAT.
ASSUMES THAT WE WOULD GO FROM
ABOUT TWELVE AND A HALF TO
SEVENTEEN PERCENT A AND.
EH AGAIN IT WOULD INCREASE A
YEAR THAT AS WE LOOK AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL POPULATION GOING THROUGH
ITS BECOMING INCREASINGLY
DIVERSE.
SO YOU BE PULLING AND.
THAT A UNDER UP EITHER PROPOSAL
IT'S JUST THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THAT YOU BE BRINGING AN.
CAN CAN YOU ALSO COMMENT ON.
WHAT IS OUR PROGRESS ON THE
STATUS OF THE TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN TRANSFERRED TASK
FORCE?
BUT SO DID THE TRANSFER TASK
FORCE UPRAVO SPENT BROWN. WHO
BEGAN LAST YEAR IS THAT GONNA BE
IN CHARGE OF THAT?
THEY ARE LOOKING AT OF VARIOUS
PROPOSALS
OF ON THE THINGS THAT WOULD HELP
IMPROVE WE'VE GOT THE. TWENTY
ONE TRANSFER PATHWAYS THAT ARE
IN PLACE
THAT PROVIDE CONSISTENT A
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS EACH OF THE
CAMPUSES SO IT'S.
WORKING TO PROVIDE SOME
CONSISTENCY FOR STUDENTS THAT IF
THEY CHOOSE THAT THEY CAN GO TO
ANY OF THE UC CAMPUSES THAT WE
HAVE SO WE HAVE THAT.
IN PLACE AND WERE LOOKING AT
PROVIDING MORE INFORMATION AND
OUTREACH SO THAT STUDENTS KNOW
THAT'S AVAILABLE.
AS IT GOES FOR THE TRANSFER.
TASK FORCE OF THEY'RE GOING TO
BE.
TAKING A LOOK AT THE A PILOT
PROJECT ON THAT IS GOING TO.
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE
EIGHT EIGHT DEGREES FOR
CHEMISTRY AND PHYSICS THE
FACULTY ON A BOTH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO SEE IF THEY CAN
PROVIDE SOME GUARANTEED
ADMISSIONS PROGRAM THERE THAT
WORK IS UNDER WAY.
AND THERE IS A ALSO DISCUSSIONS
THAT ARE IN PLACE ABOUT
INCREASING TAG AGREEMENTS. A
TRANSFER ADMISSION GUARANTEE
AGREEMENTS WE HAVE MONTHS SIX OF
THE CAMPUSES A ABOUT A THIRD OF
OUR ENROLLMENT. IS WITH STUDENTS
THAT COME UP WITH THROUGH THE
TAG PROGRAM. A AND SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT
THOSE TWO.
THE CHANCELLOR I MEAN THE
PUBLIC JUST GOT HERE AND.
HE IS.
CHAIRING THAT TASK FORCE SO
THAT WORK IS UNDER WAY.
AND.
WILL BE ABLE TO UPDATE YOU AS
SICK PROCEEDS.
AND AS WE TALK ABOUT TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN THE PORTENTS OF THAT. IN THE
LARGE LATINO POPULATION THAT ARE
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AYE I'D LIKE TO HEAR.
.
THE COMMENT ON A PROGRAM SUCH AS
POINT THEY.
THAT I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN BOTH
AS A MENTOR.
.
HOW EFFECTIVE?
?
DO YOU SEE PROGRAMS LIKE THAT
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT
BELONGINGNESS.
ON THE CAMPUS YET IMPORTANCE OF
THAT YET.
BUT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE IN TRYING
TO QUICKLY GO TO. ARE YOU SEE
INFORMATION CENTER FROM WE HAVE
A INFORMATION UP THERE THAT
SHOWS THE OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS
THAT PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS. AND I KNOW THAT IT'S A
BEEN POSITIVE I I'M NOT SURE I'M
GONNA BE ABLE TO GET THIS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE I LIKE A
FIVE SECOND DELAY HERE. YEAH. OF
LET'S SEE SO FOR POINT TODAY I
KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD.
.
A GOOD BENEFITS IN BOTH BUT
GETTING STUDENTS TO ENROLL AND
THEN. BE PREPARED.
.
AND SO. BUT IF I CAN GIVE YOU
SPECIFICS AYE WELL BUT BUT THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THEY.
.
THAT KIND OF MENTORSHIP AND
OUTREACH IS REALLY CRITICAL.
TO GET PEOPLE TO CHOOSE.
AT THE UNIVERSITY AND THAT
WE'VE SEEN GROWTH AND IN
INDIVIDUALS THAT I HAVE A
PARTICIPATED IN THAT PROGRAM. OF
THAT END UP COMING UP AND.
AND THAT KIND OF CONNECTION IS
REALLY CRITICAL.
I'M NOT GETTING THE NUMBERS AS
FAST AS I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE IT BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN SHARE
WITH YOU. THERE WOULD BE
SPECIFIC OTHER THAT THAT FIRST
YEAR EXPERIENCE.
THE INTRODUCTION TO THE
CAMPUSES WE KNOW THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL IN AND
CAMPUSES ARE DOING A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS. TO PROVIDE.
STUDENTS A. SMOOTH TRANSITIONS
NAM AND THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO. GET THROUGH THAT
FIRST YEAR AND THEN SUCCEEDED BY
MOVEON.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SELECT THE HAVE.
OKAY WILL BRING GET NOW THE CSU
SYSTEM
.
AND AND AS YOU KNOW WHERE OUT
RUNNING OUT OF TIME SO IF YOU
COULD HELP US.
.
MOVING ALONG SO WE GET TO THE.
COMMENTARY PIECE OF THE GREAT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
I'M LAUREN BLANCHARD I SERVE AS
EXECUTIVE VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT AFFAIRS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCES OFFICE.
AND SEATED NEXT TO ME IS STEVE
REALLY GAY WHO SERVES AS
EXECUTIVE VICE CHANCELLOR OF FOR
BUSINESS AND FINANCE FOR THE
CHANCES OFFICE AND WE'RE BOTH.
OF VERY PLEASED TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY TO DISCUSS THE ACTIONS
THAT THE C. ISSUE WITH TAKING.
TO IMPROVE STUDENT SUCCESS AND
DEGREE COMPLETION FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR STUDENTS BUT
THEIR FAMILIES AND OBVIOUSLY FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO
WILL TAKE A MOMENT TO TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING AROUND
STUDENT SUCCESS.
THE C. S. USE ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
FRAMEWORK IN THE ROLE OF THE YOU
SEE AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAN IT IS TODAY.
IN THE CURRENT GLOBAL ECONOMY
MORE STUDENTS NEEDED AGREE ARE
CREDENTIALED BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL
AS THE NECESSARY PATHWAY FOR A
CAREER.
THIS SHIFT ALSO COINCIDES WITH
THAT RISING DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE'S POPULATION AND LIKEWISE
OUR STUDENTS AT THE CSU.
AND HAVE AND AS HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED ALREADY HERE TODAY.
CALIFORNIA FACES A LOOMING
DEGREE DROUGHT THE STATUS QUO IS
INSUFFICIENT FOR STUDENTS FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND FOR OUR
STATE.
THAT IS WHY SEE IT'S YOU HAS
LAUNCHED WHAT WE CLAIM AS OUR
MOON SHOT.
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE.
THROUGH THIS INITIATIVE THE CS
YOU WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE SUCCESSFUL.
GRADUATE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
POSITIVELY IMPACTING THEIR LIVES
FAMILIES AND THE COMMUNITIES.
AND IN DOING SO THE CSU WILL
CONTINUE TO FULFILL ITS FOUNDING
MISSION TO PROVIDE AND PRODUCE
THE GRADUATES NEED IT'S TO POWER
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE PROSPERITY.
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE IS DESIGNED TO
BENEFIT EVERY CSU STUDENT.
THOSE CURRENTLY NROLLED A MAC
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES AND THOSE
TO COME.
BUT WHILE EVERY STUDENT WILL
BENEFIT FROM THE COLLECTIVE
EFFORT DRIVING THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE. THE CSU IS
SPECIFICALLY MEASURING PROGRESS
BASED ON SIX SYSTEM WIDE GOALS.
THEY ARE.
A FORTY PERCENT FOR YOUR
GRADUATE FRESHMAN GRADUATION
RATE.
WHICH MORE THAN DOUBLES THE
PERCENTAGE AND NUMBER OF
STUDENTS ON THAT TIME LINE OVER
THE COURSE OF THE INITIATIVE.
A SEVENTY PERCENT SIX YEAR
FRESHMAN GRADUATION RATE.
A FORTY FIVE PERCENT TO YEAR
TRANSFER GRADUATION RATE.
AND EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT FOUR
YEAR TRANSFER GRADUATION RATE.
THE ELIMINATION OF THE THE
GRADUATION RATE GAP BETWEEN PELL
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AND THEIR
PEERS.
AND THE ELIMINATION OF THE
GRADUATION RATE GAP BETWEEN
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS AND THEIR PEERS.
THESE TARGETS THAT I JUST
DESCRIBED WERE NOT JUST GUESSES
ARE UNREALISTIC HYPERBOLE.
RATHER THEY WERE DATA INFORMED
AND DEVELOPED BY AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE THAT
INCLUDED C. S. U. TRUSTEES
ADMINISTRATORS FACULTY AND
STUDENTS.
AND BENEFIT FROM THE IMPACT OF
THE EXPERTS THAT WE HEARD
EARLIER TODAY. INCLUDING DOCTOR
HANS JOHNSON FROM THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
AND DOCTOR LANDET A JOSIE FROM
CALIFORNIA COMPETES.
THE C. S. YOU CURRENTLY AWARDS
NEARLY HALF OF THE STATE'S
BACHELORS DEGREES.
WITH SUFFICIENT ANNUAL
INVESTMENT OF NEW GENERAL FUNDS
TO GROW ENROLLMENT AND SUPPORT
STUDENT SUCCESS.
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE PUTS THE CSU ON
TRACK TO GRADUATE AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
BY THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
POSITIONING THE STUDENT.
POSITIONING THE STATE TO MEET
OUR SHARE OF CALIFORNIA'S
PROJECTED WORKFORCE NEED.
ACHIEVING THESE AMBITIOUS GOALS.
WILL REQUIRE THE ENTIRE CSU
COMMUNITY
TO BE ENGAGED AND WORKING TOWARD
THIS COMMON OBJECTIVE.
AND I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT THAT
IS EXACTLY WHAT IS OCCURRING.
ALL TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES HAVE
DEVELOPED AND ARE IMPLEMENTING
THEIR OWN LOCAL PLANS TO ACHIEVE
CAMPUS GOALS FOR COMPLETION AND
EQUITY.
EACH THE ISSUE CAMPUS HAS ITS
OWN NUMERIC GOALS FOR
IMPROVEMENT. AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS ASSESSING
PROGRESS WITH EACH GRADUATING
CLASS.
AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL AS YOU HEARD
ME SMIDGEN EARLIER WE HAVE
DEVELOPED SIX OPERATIONAL
PILLARS THAT ARE DRIVING OUR
WORK THESE PLANTS ARE BUILT ON.
STUDENT OUTCOME DATA RESEARCH
AND BEST PRACTICES FROM ACROSS
THE SEA IT'S YOU AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THE TACTICS THAT ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN
PROVEN TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND AS I
WAS SHARE LATER WE ARE ALREADY
BEGINNING TO SEE THEIR IMPACTS.
BUT FIRST LET ME JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TO DELVE DEEPER IN TO THE
WORK THAT IS UNDER WAY TO
ACHIEVE OUR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE CALLS.
THE FIRST AREA THAT IS THE
CAMPUS STRATEGIC A PRIORITY IS
ACADEMIC PREPARATION.
THE CSU WILL PROVIDE STUDENTS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARRIVE
ACADEMICALLY UNDERPREPARED. THE
OPPORTUNITY AND SUPPORT NEEDED
TO COMPLETE THIRTY DEGREE.
COLLEGE LEVEL SEMESTER UNITS
BEFORE BEGINNING THEIR SECOND
ACADEMIC YEAR.
IN RECENT YEARS MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND INCOMING FIRST
YEAR STUDENTS.
ARE INFORMED THAT THEY ARE NOT
QUITE READY FOR COLLEGE LEVEL
MATH OR ENGLISH COURSE WORK
AFTER BEING FULLY ADMISSIBLE TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
NEARLY SIXTY PERCENT OF THE
STUDENTS ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND HALF OF HISPANIC STUDENTS
RECEIVE THAT MESSAGE.
OF THESE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS ONE IN FOUR WILL NOT
RETURN FOR THEIR SECOND YEAR.
ONLY TEN PERCENT WILL GRADUATE
IN FOUR YEARS. AND LESS THAN
HALF WILL GRADUATE IN SIX YEARS.
THAT IS WHY THE CSU ENACTED THE
SYSTEM WIDE POLICY CHANGES AIMED
AT. IMPROVING ASSESSMENT OF
COLLEGE READINESS.
STRENGTHENING THE EARLY START
PROGRAM RESTRUCTURING
DEVELOPMENTAL EDUCATION AND
CLARIFYING IN UPDATING GENERAL
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS
PROVIDING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING AND SUPPORT
TO FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATORS TO
IMPLEMENT THESE POLICY CHANGES.
REALLOCATE IT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO CAPS IS FROM ONE TIME
SOURCES.
AND WE HAVE SOUGHT PHILLIP THAT
THROBBING SUPPORT WITH
ORGANIZATIONS WHOSE EMPHASIS ON
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY ALIGNED WITH
OUR CSU VALUES.
FACULTY AND STAFF.
ARE CURRENTLY REDESIGNING
COURSES.
IMPLEMENTING MODELS SUCH AS CO
REQUISITE THAT YOU HEARD EARLIER
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS MORNING
WHERE ACADEMIC SUPPORT IS
IMBEDDED INTO CREDIT EARNING
COURSES.
BEGINNING IN FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALL CSU STUDENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO BEGIN EARNING COLLEGE
CREDIT BEGINNING THEIR FIRST DAY
OF ON CAMPUS.
WHILE RECEIVING THE ADDITIONAL
ACADEMIC SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
THIS WILL PLAY A TREMENDOUS ROLE
IN IMPROVING STUDENT PERSISTENCE
AND DEGREE COMPLETION AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY ENCLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
THE SECOND AREA OF FOCUS FOR THE
SEE IT'S YOU IT'S IT'S UNDER THE
ARM OF ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT.
THE C. S. YOU WILL ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO IN A ROW
ENROLLED IN THECOURSES THAT
THEY NED WHEN THEY NEED THEM.
THIS INCLUDES THE HIRING OF
ADDITIONAL TENURE TRACK FACULTY
TO TEACH ADDITIONAL COURSE
SECTIONS WHICH STEVE WILL SPEAK
ABOUT SHORTLY.
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES STRATEGIES
SUCH AS REPEAT CREATING AND%
REFINING DEGREE ROAD MAPS FOR
STUDENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE CSU SAN MARCOS HAS
IMPLEMENTED DEGREE SET GO. AN
INITIATIVE THAT ALLOW STUDENTS
TO SEE THEIR MOST EFFICIENT
ROADMAP TO GRADUATION.
STUDENTS CAN REGISTER FOR
CLASSES DIRECTLY FROM THE DEGREE
PLAN OR PROGRAM AND THE CAMPUS
IS ABLE TO USE THE INFORMATION
TO BETTER PREDICT COURSE DEMAND
AND MATCH RESOURCES.
CAMPUSES ARE ALSO STRATEGICALLY
OFFERING COURSES IN WINTER AND
SPRING INTERCESSION AND IN THE
SUMMER SESSION TO PROVIDE
STUDENTS ADDITIONAL OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENROLL IN THE
CLASSES THEY NEED FOR
GRADUATION.
TO EITHER GET THEM BACK ON TRACK
OR TO GET THEM AHEAD IN THEIR
TIME TO DEGREE COMPLETION.
THE THIRD AREA IS STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT AND WELL BEING.
YOU HEARD THAT'S THIS REFERENCED
EARLIER WELL WHERE THE CSU WILL
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE WELL
BEING OF ALL CSU STUDENTS WHILE
FOSTERING A STRONG SENSE OF
BELONGING THIS ON CAMPUS.
MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF OUR C.
ISSUE CAMPUSES NOW HAVE DREAM
CENTERS.
ALL TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES HAVE
FOOD PRINT PANTRIES ARE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAMS TO HELP
STUDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
FOOD SECURITY.
A NUMBER OF CAMPUSES ASSIST
STUDENTS WITH CAL PRESS
APPLICATIONS ARE PROVIDES SHORT
SHORT TERM EMERGENCY HOUSING ON
CAMPUSES.
IN FACT THIS WEEK.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES STARTING TOMORROW
WILL BE ATTENDING ACS YOU BASIC
NEEDS CONFERENCE
WHERE THEY WILL BE SHARING BEST
PRACTICES AND LEARNING
ADDITIONAL WAYS TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS WELL BEING.
THE FOURTH AREA ITS FINANCIAL
SUPPORT.
SEE IT SHE WILL ENSURE THAT
FINANCIAL NEED DOES NOT IMPEDE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
MORE THAN SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF OUR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
HAVE ALL TUITION COVERED BY NON
LOAN EIGHT. BUT BEYOND
TRADITIONAL FINANCIAL AID
CAMPUSES ARE PROVIDING FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS TO STAY AND
ROLLED AND TO STAY ON TRACK TO
GRADUATE.
FOR EXAMPLE AT FRESNO STATE
MICRO GRANTS ARE AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE ON TRACK TO
GRADUATE. BUT MIGHT FACE
UNEXPECTED FINANCIAL CHALLENGES.
AT SACRAMENTO STATE STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN THE FINISH IN
FOUR. AND THE THROUGH INTO
PROGRAMS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR UP TO
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
DISCOUNTED COURSES
TO ASSIST IN COMPLETING THIRTY
EIGHT DEGREE CREDIT HOURS EACH
YEAR.
THE FIFTH AREA ITS DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING.
THE CSU WILL USE DATA RICH
EVIDENCE TO IDENTIFY AND ADVANCE
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL ACADEMIC
SUPPORT PROGRAMS.
AT THE SYSTEM LEVEL WE ARE
COMPILING STUDENT OUTCOME DATA.
STEALING IT AND PROVIDING IT IN
ACTIONABLE FORMS FOUR CAMPUSES.
FOR EXAMPLE THE FACULTY
DASHBOARD PROVIDE CSU FACULTY
WITH THE DATA ON STUDENTS WHO
COMPRISE THEIR MAJORS ALLOWING
THEM TO SEE WHICH COURSES
STUDENTS ARE STRUGGLING WITH.
WHERE THERE ARE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
IN COURSE PERFORMANCE AND IF
STUDENTS ARE ON TRACK FOR
EARNING A DEGREE?
AND AT CAL STATE FULLERTON DATA
ARE USED TO IDENTIFY COURSES
THAT ARE SLOWING STUDENTS
PROGRESS TO GRADUATION. DRIVE
CLASS DRIVING CLASS SCHEDULING
AND EXPANDING SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION WHERE IT WILL BE
MOST EFFECTIVE.
AND FINALLY THIS SIXTH AREA IS
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS WHERE WE
ARE IDENTIFYING AND REMOVING
ADMINISTRATIVE IMPEDIMENTS TO
GRADUATION.
AS BUT ONE EXAMPLE SAN DIEGO
STATE IS CHANGING ITS CLASS
REGISTRATION PROCESS MOVING
REGISTRATION EARLIER.
BEGINNING WITH THE FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SEMESTER THIS CHANGE
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR STUDENTS
TO MEET WITH ADVISORS AND
DEVELOP ACADEMIC SCHEDULES
DURING CRITICAL PRE REGISTRATION
PERIODS.
THE STRATEGIES THAT I'VE JUST
DESCRIBED BOTH CAMPUS BASED AND
SYSTEM WIDE ARE ALREADY HAVING A
MEASURABLE IMPACT ON CSU
STUDENTS.
THIS PAST YEAR TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE STATE INVESTED
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING IN THE C.
ISSUES STUDENT SUCCESS EFFORTS.
I AM PROUD TO STATE THAT A
LITTLE MORE THAN ONE YEAR INTO
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE.
OUR STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALREADY SEEING A
STRONG RETURN ON THAT
INVESTMENT.
NEARLY NINETY NINE THOUSAND CSU
STUDENTS ARE AND THEIR BACHELORS
DEGREE THIS PAST YEAR.
THIS REPRESENTS AN ALL TIME HIGH
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
WITH AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS CROSSING THAT
COMMENCEMENT STAGE COMPARED TO
LAST YEAR.
AND SOME CAMPUSES.
IMPROVEMENTS REALLY HAVE BEEN
QUITE DRAMATIC.
CSU MONTEREY BAY HAS INCREASED
THEIR FOR YOUR GRADUATION RATES
FOR FRESHMAN FROM TWENTY THREE
PERCENT TO THIRTY PERCENT SINCE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE HAS COMMENCED.
AT SYNONYMOUS STATE
THEY HAVE BEENCHRIS THEIR TWO
YEAR GRADUATION RATE FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS FROM FIFTY ONE
PERCENT TO SIXTY PERCENT IN JUST
THE PAST TWO YEARS.
WITHOUT QUESTION GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS
HAVING THE DESIRED IMPACT ON
STUDENT SUCCESS.
SO WHAT THIS IS MEAN.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IT MEANS THAT
THESE GRADUATES ARE ABLE TO MOVE
INTO THE WORKFORCE ARE CONTINUE
THEIR ACADEMIC STUDIES PREPARED
FOR SUCCESS.
SECONDLY IT MEANS THAT MORE
GRADUATES ARE BEING PRODUCED TO
MEET THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
NEEDS.
AND THIRDLY IT MEANS MORE ACCESS
FOR NEW STUDENTS LOOKING TO
ENTER THE CSU.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE DEMAND FOR A CS YOU
EDUCATION IT'S HIGHER THAN IT'S
EVER BEEN BEFORE.
THE RECENT HIGHER EDUCATION
ELIGIBILITY STUDY FOUND THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES MEETING THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
SEE IT'S YOU. HAS INCREASED TO
FORTY ONE PERCENT.
A TESTAMENT TO IMPROVING K.
TWELVE OUTCOMES AND STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
AND AT THE SAME TIME MORE
STUDENTS THAN EVER BEFORE ARE
ENTERING THE CSU WITH AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER.
AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT THESE
APPLICATIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
RISE AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
OFFER MORE AB T. PROGRAMS AND
MORE STUDENTS WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PATHWAY. AS
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
WORKS TO WHAT'S MEETING ITS OWN
AMBITIOUS GOALS.
THESE TRENDS ARE REALLY GREAT
NEWS NOT ONLY FOR STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES BUT ALSO FOR OUR
STATE WHICH NEEDS THESE STUDENTS
TO ATTEND COLLEGE GRADUATE AND
JOIN THE WORKFORCE WITH A
BACHELORS DEGREE.
BUT THIS WORK MUST BE SUSTAINED
AND SUPPORTED TO CONTINUE THIS
MOMENTUM.
MEETING CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
DEMANDS WILL REQUIRE BOTH
IMPROVED GRADUATION RATES
WHICH WE ARE WELL ON OUR WAY TO
ACHIEVING THROUGH GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
BUT ALSO INCREASED UNIVERSITY
ENROLLMENT.
I WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO VICE
CHANCELLOR STEVE REALLY A WHO
WILL SPEAK MORE ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND THE CHALLENGES
FACING THE CSU OR LESS.
ARE LESS
SPEAK MORE OR LESS.
GOT YOU.
SO OUT OF THANK YOU LAUREN AND
UP.
THAT THIS AMBITIOUS PLAN HAT
LAUREN HAS LAID OUT FOR YOU TO
PROVE GRADUATION RATES AND
ELIMINATE THE EQUITY GAPS AMONG.
OUR STUDENTS DOES REQUIRE
RESOURCES.
SUSTAINABLE PREDICTABLE AND
SUFFICIENT VESTMENT WILL CAN
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE THE
MOMENTUM AS WE FULFILL THIS
MISSION.
WERE THANKFUL FOR ALL THAT YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES IN BOTH THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY.
HAVE DONE AND YOUR RESPECTIVE
STAFF HAS DONE TO HELP US INVEST
IN THE AMBITIOUS GRADUATION
INITIATIVE THAT LAUREN JUST
DESCRIBED.
SO I'M GONNA DIE JUST DIE
QUICKLY TOUCH ON GIVEN OUR TIME
CONSTRAINTS ARE THREE AREAS THAT
HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT ON OUR
ABILITY TO TO FILL THAT SEND
BEFORE I TOUCH ON THOSE THREE.
JUST BASICALLY STE ARE DESCRIBED
AYE NUMERICALLY WHAT THE
INVESTMENT LOOK LIKE TO GET TO
THE RESULTS OF ORANGES TO
DESCRIBE FOR YOU.
THIS PAST YEAR THE CSU HAS
INVESTED FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO HIRE SEVEN HUNDRED
NEW TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
AND WE HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL SEARCHES UNDERWAY
RESULTING IN FOUR HUNDRED NET
NEW FACT THE POSITIONS THAT ARE
TEACHING AN ADDITIONAL THREE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED COURSES.
EIGHTEEN MILLION ES BEEN
INVESTED IN ADVISING ADDING TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT NEW
ADVISERS.
TWENTY FOUR MILLION HAS BEEN
INVESTED IN STUDENT AND ACADEMIC
SUPPORT PROGRAMS WHICH LAUREN
JUST DESCRIBED TO YOU AND THE
INCLUDES THINGS LIKE TUTORING
MENTORING SUMMER SESSION
COURSES.
OUR STUDENT WELLBEING PROGRAMS
AND THE DAVID DIP DRIVEN
DECISION ANALYSIS LARA
DESCRIBED.
SO WILL BE BRIEF PROVIDING A
VERY DETAILED REPORT AT THE
MARCH BOARD MEANING OR POOR
TRUSTEES BUT LET ME TURN QUICKLY
TO OF THE THE THREE AREAS.
RESOURCE AREAS THAT REALLY
IMPACT WHETHER WE CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL CONTINUE TO GET TO.
THAT THAT THE NUMBERS THAT
LAUREN HAS HAS DESCRIBED OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
THE FIRST IS JUST THE COST OF
INCREASED ACCESS AND COMPLETION.
YES YES YOU GRADUATION
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE AND ALL OUR
STUDENTS.
SUCCESS EFFORTS
HAVE RESULTED IN ADDED COST AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE AS I JUST
DESCRIBED SO SIMPLY PUT.
MORE STUDENTS MEAN MORE COURSE
SECTIONS IN COURSES THAT MEANS
MORE FACT BEEN ADVISERS TO
SUPPORT THOSE COURSES AND COURSE
THAT TRANSLATES INTO MORE COSTS.
WE ESTIMATE OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS HE ISSUE WILL NEED
AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
PER YEAR TO DIRECT TOWARDS THIS
PLAN FOR A TOTAL IN ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT OVER AT THE NEXT TO
YEARS OF FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY TO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
ONE REASON FOR THE NEED FOR THIS
INVESTMENT CAN BE UNDERSTOOD
STOOD BY OUR COLLECTIVE PRIORITY
FOR ALL CSU UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO FINISH IN
FOUR YEARS. THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
DO SO GET THE COURSES THEY NEED
AND GET TO FIFTEEN UNITS IN EACH
SEMESTER.
.
PICK A LIMITS
QUICKLY THEN GO TO THE COST OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SAT AGAIN
IT'S NOT JUST NOT TEACHERS IN
CLASSROOMS AND MORE CLASSES BUT
ALSO HAVING. UP FACILITIES THAT
ARE NOT FALLING APART. AND WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSING VERY HEAVILY ON
OUR CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES
OUR OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
BUT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE MAJOR
PROBLEMS IN THIS AREA AT THE C.
ISSUE CONTINUES TO EXPERIENCE
UTILITY FAILURES OF HOT WATER
HEATING SYSTEMS FOR EXAMPLE AND
ELECTRICAL SYSTEMS. AT CAMPUSES
SUCH AS SAN FRANCISCO STATE AND
FRESNO STATE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THESE ARE NOT
THE TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROGRAMS
THAT DONORS ARE GOING TO WANT TO
FUND.
THE FUNDING PROVIDED BY THE CSU
IN STATE HAS NOT BEEN ADEQUATE
TO ADDRESS THE MAINTENANCE
ISSUES
OF THIS AND SIMILAR UP PROJECTS.
UP THE ERRORS AND ANNUAL NEED
OF TOURING FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS CONTINUAL
AGING OF THE SYSTEMS AND CHIP
AWAY AT THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG. OF TWO
BILLION DOLLARS.
THEN THE THIRD.
IN FINAL AREA THAT AFFECTS OUR
ABILITY TO STAY THE COURSE ON TO
GRADUATION INITIATIVE ARE OUR
CLASSROOMS IN ACTION MAKE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
OUR STUDENTS DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY A LEARNING
CLASSROOMS LECTURE HALLS
LABORATORIES AND LIBRARIES THAT
ARE SAFE ENRICHING. AND REFLECT
MARS TECHNOLOGY CENTRIC MERCK
WORKPLACE.
OUR FIVE YEAR FACILITIES PLAN
WHICH WAS APPROVED LAST YEAR
IDENTIFIED EIGHT POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ENACTMENT
PROGRAM INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
I NOW DUE TO THE CHANGES MADE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO ON HOW THE
STATE APPROACHES ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING NEEDS.
FUNDING FOR ENTRY INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT I JUST DESCRIBED NOW
COMPETES WITH ALL OTHER EXPENSES
ALL OTHER OPERATING EXPENSES AND
AND SUCH AS EXPANDING ACCESS AND
HIRING ARE FACT MEAN STAFF.
GIVEN THE HIGH PRIORITY OF THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS GONE LARGELY
UNFUNDED IN MANY CASES.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN CSU
CAMPUSES HAVE IDENTIFIED TWENTY
EIGHT HIGH PRIORITY DEPARTMENT
ARE AT A INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
WE'RE ANTICIPATING BEING ALL TO
FIND TWO HUNDRED MILLION OR
PORTION OF THAT NEED TO HELP
FUND INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
LIFE THE LIBRARY PREPRESS
REPLACEMENT PROJECT AT CAL STATE
EAST BAY WHICH IS SUFFERING FROM
SOME SEISMIC ISSUES. RENOVATE A
LARGE CLASSROOM BUILDING AT
CINEMA STATE AND CO FUND A
SCIENCE IN AGRICULTURAL COMPLEX
AT CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO.
THE TRUSTEES OPPORTUNE BUDGET
NEED INCLUDES FIFTEEN MILLION TO
FINANCE ABOUT TO HER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN PROJECTS.
WE PLAN TO ADDRESSED ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND RENOVATION.
PROJECTS AT CHANNEL ISLANDS AND
RENOVATIONS AT CAL MARITIME
ACADEMY KALPANA SALAS OBISPO AND
CAL STATE SAN PORTANTINO.
SO I'M JUST GOING TO CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS BY JUST SAYING THAT.
THAT THE.
IF THE TRENDS CONTINUE IN TERMS
OF THE FUNDING OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THIS ISSUE BUDGET.
OUR ABILITY TO ACCOMPLISH WHAT
LAUREN HAS HIGHLIGHTED IS GONNA
BE VERY VERY DIFFICULT IT WILL
ESSENTIALLY STAGNATE.
PROPOSED AUGMENTATION OF THE SEA
ISSUE BUDGET OF NINETY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN YEAR. IS
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF THE
MINIMAL.
AMOUNT THAT THE TRUSTEES HAVE
PUT FORTH.
IN ITS TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE
BUDGET.
A REQUEST IN NOVEMBER.
SO WITH THAT I'M GOING TO.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING AND.
TURNED OVER GOT MIKE OVER TO
LAUREN TO CONCLUDE.
AND I TURNED IT OVER TO YOU FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE A QUESTIONS.
YEAH AND THIS IS REALLY KIND OF
FOR ALL SEGMENTS BUT BUT ALL BUT
I'LL ASK YOU AND. YOU KNOW WE
NEED MORE PEOPLE WITH DEGREES.
AND WE WANTED TO GO THROUGH OUR
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES BECAUSE WE
VALUE IN TRUST THEM AND
SOMETIMES THE FOR PROFIT
UNIVERSITIES.
I DON'T TO THE BEST JOB IN GAL
STUDENTS BUT ONE THING THAT FOR
PROFIT UNIVERSITIES DO WELL.
IS THEY SERVE THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS.
YOU KNOW THERE THERE OUGHT ON
RANCID.
GOOD LOCATIONS GOOD ADVERTISING.
CLASSES START EVERY MONDAY.
AND THE BARRIERS TO ENTRY ARE
ARE ARE LOW. THEY HAD CLASSES
THAT FRIDAY NIGHTS A WEEK WHEN
THE STUDENTS NEED THEM AND. YOU
KNOW THAT THE PUSH BACK ON THAT
THE PUBLIC SYSTEMS IS THAT YOU
KNOW WE TEACH CLASSES WHEN IT
MAKES SENSE FOR THAT. FACULTY
MEMBERS CELL ROOMINESS TRADERS.
MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY FROM.
NINE TO THREE.
BUT YOU GO OUT OTHER HOURS
RATHER DAYS AND WE HAVE THIS.
IN THESE FACILITIES ARE UNDER
UTILIZED YOU KNOW HERE AT SAC
STATE WE HAVE THIS AFRICA WAS
CALLED THIS.
SENIOR PROGRAMS COLOR RICHMOND
PROGRAM.
AND THEY USE THE WHOLE CAMPUS
ON A FRIDAY BECAUSE.
YES YOU START USING IT CSU S..
SO. I KNOW THERE'S ALL THESE
CAPITAL NEEDS IN THIS IS NOT
JUST FOR YOU THIS IS FOR THE ALL
THREE SEGMENTS SO.
WHAT CAN WE DO DIFFERENTLY TO TO
MINIMIZE THAT THE NEED TO PUT SO
MUCH MONEY AND READ SOME
ARTICLES IN THE BEAT? REHAB BUT
YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT ROT
UTILIZING OUR ASSETS TO THE TO
THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY.
.
TIMES AND DAYS OF THE WEEK SO.
WE DON'T HAVE UNLIMITED MONEY IF
YOU'RE SO WHAT CAN WE DO
DIFFERENTLY TO TO ADDRESS THAT.
MONEY ISSUE AND ALSO WHEN
POTENTIALLY STUDENTS WANT TO GO
TO CLASS.
PUPPY OUT START A KNOW THAT.
ONE STRATEGY THAT SEVERAL OF
OUR CAMPUSES HAVE BEGUN TO
IMPLEMENT A LOOKING AT.
SPACE UTILIZATION.
AND CONDUCTING STUDIES TO
DETERMINE EXACTLY WHERE THE GAPS
ARE.
IN TERMS OF CLASSROOMS THAT ARE
NOT BEING USED
AND THEN USING THAT THEN TO WORK
WITH THE VARIOUS ACADEMIC
COLLEGE IS. A TO RETHINK THEIR
TRADITIONAL NINE TO THREE ARE
NINE TO FIVE STRUCTURE THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE TO OFFER COURSES.
AND PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR
FACULTY WHO WISH THEN OUGHT TO
OFFER COURSES PERHAPS IN THE
LATER EVENING ON WEEKENDS A AND
THAT MORE IMPORTANTLY IN
SURVEYING STUDENTS. DETERMINING
BASED ON MANY OF THEM WORKING IN
THEIR SCHEDULES WHAT COULD BE
MORE TIME SLOTS THAT GO BEYOND
THEIR TRADITIONAL TIME FRAME OF
THE COURSES CAN BE OFFERED AND
THAT FACULTY WILL DELIVER THOSE
COURSES.
WE SEE CHANGES HAPPENING.
AT SAN MARCOS A AS A RESULT O
THAT.
AND WE CERTAINLY ANTICIPATE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE OTHER
CHANGES AS WELL BASED ON A
GROWING NUMBER BY CAMPUS IS
CONDUCTING THE SPACE UTILIZATION
STUDIES.
THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE OKAY.
AND AND THEN UST YEAH I KNOW
THAT. WHEN GIVEN A GREATER
DETAIL DURING THE BUDGET
HEARINGS I WANTED. IF TAKE UP
TOO MUCH TIME TODAY BUT AS FAR
AS THE.
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVES I
THINK FANTASTIC WORK YOU ALL ARE
DOING.
.
I SEE IT RIGHT HERE AT C. S. U.
S..
SO IF YOU CAN LOOK AROUND AT THE
MACRO LEVEL.
WHAT WERE THE BIGGEST TAKEAWAY
CC FOR FIRST COUPLE YEARS
AS FAR AS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
THINGS THAT?
TWENTY FIVE CAMPUS WIDE HEARD
WHATEVER NEVER IS IS DOING.
AND THAT WE COULD DO MORE OUT.
WELL GOOD QUESTION.
I WOULD SAY THAT.
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING NOW AND
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THAT THE THE
BIGGEST TAKE WAY FOR US
ESPECIALLY AS WE ARE? WORKING TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
IT'S GOING TO BE THE
RESTRUCTURING OF THE DEVELOPMENT
EDUCATION PROGRAM WHICH WE HAVE
LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR THAT TO
OCCUR. AND THAT WE HAVE SEEN
RESULTS ALREADY IN ENGLISH OF
WHERE OF A LOT OF THOSE COURSES
THAT WERE NON CREDIT BEARING.
THAT ENGLISH FACULTY HAVE
CONVERTED THOSE OVER ALREADY
INTO CREDIT BEARING COURSES.
AND WE'RE SEEING STUDENTS
OBVIOUSLY GRADUATING I IN A
TIMELY MANNER OBVIOUSLY
MATHEMATICS HAS BEEN THE BIGGEST
BARRIER.
NOT ONLY FOR US IT'S THE ISSUE
BUT IF YOU LOOK ACROSS THE
NATION.
IT HAD MATHEMATICS PERFORMANCE
HAS BEEN A STRUGGLE FOR A NUMBER
OF STUDENTS ESPECIALLY FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND SO THE
IMPLEMENTATION THEN OF THAT SAME
CO REQUISITE MODEL FOR
MATHEMATICS OF THAT WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF IMPERFECT OF. OF
FINALIZING NOW FOR
IMPLEMENTATION AND FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I CAN SAY TO YOU THAT
WE BELIEVE WILL MOVE THE NEEDLE
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY.
AS IT RELATES TO ALLOWING MORE
STUDENTS AND IT AND PARTICULARLY
MORE STUDENTS OF COLOR.
TO BE ABLE TO GRADUATE AND I'M
AN A TIMELIER MANNER AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY OF BE PREPARED.
AT IT WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF
QUALITY THAT WE WOULD ANTICIPATE
OTHER STUDENTS COMPLETING AND
BEING READY FOR THE WORKFORCE
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
TAKEOVER TAKEAWAYS. THE OTHER IS
OF REALLY LOOKING VERY
CAREFULLY.
AT HOW STUDENTS REALLY ARE
PROGRESSING.
IT'S IT'S TYING IN WITH THE
DATA DRIVEN KIND OF WORK THAT WE
HAVE TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IF THERE ARE
STILL SOME STUDENTS. OF THAT ARE
NOT PROGRESSING IN A TIMELY
MANNER WHAT OF THOSE BARRIERS
AND UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY ARE
AND ADDRESSING THEM IN A TIMELY
MANNER SO THAT NO START STONES
ARE LEFT UNTURNED.
AS IT RELATES TO PERSISTENCE
AND COMPLETION OF OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU POCKET JUST THAT VERY
QUICKLY AT TO TO WHAT BY LAUREN
JUSTICE SAID THAT THOSE TOOLS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET STUDENTS
TO TAKE CORRECT LASSES BUT IT'S
CARQUEST KEYED TO HAVE. THOSE
ADDITIONAL CLASSES SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY GET INTO THOSE CLASSES
AND THAT'S BEEN AS MANY VIEW
PROBABLY HEARD FROM CONCERNED
PARENTS AND STUDENTS AS IT'S
BEEN SUCH A. A BIG GUY OBSTACLE
IS HAVING ENOUGH COURSES AND
ENOUGH FACTLY TEACHES COURSES SO
THOSE TOOLS THAT LAUREN WAS
DISCUSSING A BEEN THAT BEEN.
VERY EFFECTIVE BUT WE'VE HAD TO
HAVE ENOUGH CLASSES AND A FACT
WE TEACH IN THOSE CLASSES
TO.
DIRECTIVE STUDENTS.
TO GET THE HIGHER UNIT LOAD.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL NEXT BRING UP OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM LESS THAN TWO.
I RESPOND TO THAT. QUESTION OF
THE DAY HOW TO BE DELIVERED TO
CREEK GAP
.
PERFECT I THOUGHT CHRISTIAN US
MILLION PLACE CHANCELLOR FURTHER
FINANCE IN FACILITIES PLANNING
AT THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
JOINED BY EXECUTIVE VICE
CHANCELLOR LAURA HOPE INDEED
MATTHEW ROBERTS.
THE SERGEANTS HAVE PASSED OUT
MATERIALS THAT WE WILL SIMPLY
REFERENCE WE WILL MOVE CONCISELY
AND WE'LL START WITH EXECUTIVE
VICE CHANCELLOR HELP.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION ON
THIS MATTER IT'S OUR PRIVILEGE
TO BE HERE AND. TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THAT THE MAJOR
DIRECTIONS OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES EMBRACING.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE GAPS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING THIS
MORNING.
UP WITH IN YOUR PACKET ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU'LL FIND IS A
CHANCELLOR OR TEASE OAKLEY'S
VISION FOR SUCCESS.
AND SPECIFICALLY THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS OUTLINED SIX MAJOR GOALS
ON THE ONES THAT SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS DEGREE ATTAINMENT ARE
THESE.
INCREASING THE A NUMBERS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO OBTAIN
CREDENTIALS DEGREES AND SKILL
SETS.
TO PREPARE THEM FOR HIGH DEMAND
JOBS BY TWENTY PERCENT.
INCREASED THE NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT JUST
TRANSFER PREPARED BUT WHO
TRANSFER TO THE CS YOU WHEN YOU
SEE.
BY THIRTY FIVE PERCENT AND TO
DECREASE THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF
UNITS ACCUMULATED BY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
WHO EARN ASSOCIATE DEGREES FROM
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY SEVEN
UNITS?
DOWN TO SEVENTY NINE WHICH IS
THE TOP PERFORMING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN TERMS OF EFFICIENCY.
AND FINALLY TO ELIMINATE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS ACROSS THE
BOARD WITHIN THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
AS EVER THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICABLE JUST STRIVE TO
PROVIDE ALL OF OUR STUDENTS WITH
AN IMPROVED QUALITY OF LIFE.
AND EDUCATION WHICH MEANS
REDUCING THE IMPACT OF RACIAL
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC INEQUITIES.
AS THESE GOALS INDICATE TRANSFER
AND THE ASSOCIATES DEGREE
ATTAINMENT OUR TOP PRIORITIES
FOR THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
FOR CHANCELLOR.
TO ACHIEVE THESE GOALS
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS
COMMITTED TO SEVERAL MAJOR
DIRECTIONS THAT WE BELIEVE WILL
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
ON OUR CURRENT STUDENTS AND ALSO
CULTIVATE SUCCESS AMONG STUDENTS
WHO HAVE NOT YET FOUND THEIR WAY
TO OUR DOORS.
THESE EMERGING DIRECTIONS
INCLUDE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
GUIDED PATHWAYS STATEWIDE IN THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS AND HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT GUIDED PATHWAYS
ALREADY FROM SOME OF OUR
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
THE OTHER ADDITIONAL DIRECTIONS
THAT WE THINK WE'LL HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT INCLUDE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA. AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A NEW ONLINE COLLEGE.
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON STRANDED
WORKERS WHO ARE NOT CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN OUR SYSTEM.
THESE ARE ENORMOUS GOALS THAT
RICK WILL REQUIRE TIME AND
SUSTAINED COMMITMENT ON GOING
IMPROVEMENT.
SO LET ME START WITH A LITTLE
EXPLANATION ABOUT GUIDED
PATHWAYS.
VERY PATHWAYS IS A FRAMEWORK
NOT A PROGRAM NOT AN INITIATIVE
BUT A REENGINEERING OF THE
STUDENT EXPERIENCE AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
IS BASED ON A NATIONAL MODEL AND
REFUTE REFER FUELED BY REFORM
MOVEMENTS THAT ARE EVIDENCE
BASED APPROACHES THAT KEEP
STUDENTS OF THE ORGANIZATIONAL
CENTER.
OF OF THE COLLEGE PROCESS.
THE GUIDED PATHWAYS FRAMEWORK
FEATURES FOUR PILLARS.
THE FIRST IN MANY WAYS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AT LEAST IS
ONE OF THE MOST CHALLENGING. AND
THAT IS CLARIFYING THE PATH.
THAT STUDENTS WILL TAKE.
AS WAS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BUILT
IN CALIFORNIA IS A WONDERFUL
SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES TREMENDOUS
ACCESS BUT IT IS ALSO EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED.
ON ONE OF THE THINGS I COULD
TELL YOU ANECDOTALLY I COME FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND
WE INLAND EMPIRE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
NOTED IS THAT.
A NUMBER OF OUR STUDENTS
COME UNDECIDED AND THEY ALSO
HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
FOLLOWING A PROGRAM MAP BECAUSE
THERE MAY ONLY BE ONE OR TWO
COURSES DIFFERENCE.
IN FIVE OR SIX BUSINESS
PROGRAMS.
SO ONE OF THE OUR JOBS WITH
CLARIFYING THE PATH IS MAKING
SURE THAT WE CREATE CONDITIONS
FOR THE FACULTY.
TO CREATE MORE CLARIFIED PROGRAM
MAPS FOR STUDENTS TO FOLLOW.
SO THAT THEY CAN MORE CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS THAT THEY
NEED TO TAKE AND DO SO MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
SINCE MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
FIRST GENERATION.
WE WANT TO PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS
WITH RELENTLESS CLARITY THAT'S
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE SUCCESSFUL
NAVIGATION OF OUR SYSTEM.
THAT AS I MENTIONED HAS BECOME
UNNECESSARILY COMPLEX.
PILLAR TO PRIORITIZE THE NEED TO
HELP STUDENTS MORE SEAMLESSLY
ENTER THEIR EDUCATIONAL PATHWAY
AND WE'RE WORKING TO DO SOME OF
THOSE THINGS THROUGH CONCURRENT
ENROLLMENT DUAL ENROLLMENT.
AND A BETTER ON BOARDING
PROCESS FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
WITH ONGOING INTERACTIONS
RATHER THAN JUST SORT OF THAT
INITIAL OF ORIENTATION.
PILLAR THREE IS A COMMITMENT TO
HELP STUDENTS STAY ON THEIR
CHOSEN PATHWAY NUDGING THEM
THROUGH TO THEIR MILESTONES AND
COMPLETION POINTS.
ENGAGING THEM WHEN THEY WAVER OR
EXPERIENCE CHALLENGES.
I FINALLY PILLAR FOR ENSURES
THAT STUDENTS CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THE SAME RIGOROUS AND
VALUABLE LEARNING EXPERIENCES.
THAT OUR FACULTY ARE VERY
DEDICATED TO.
CONTINUING FOR EVERYONE.
ALL OF THESE COMPONENTS REQUIRE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
APPROACHES AND SYSTEMS THAT GO
BEYOND SPECIAL PROGRAMS.
SCALE EFFECTIVE PRACTICES TO ALL
STUDENTS MAKING SURE THAT THEY
REACH THE GOALS THAT THEY
CHOOSE.
GUIDED PATHWAYS IS ALSO BEING
SUPPORTED THROUGH A NUMBER OF
REFORM EFFORTS.
SPECIFICALLY THE REFORMS AND
DEVELOPMENTAL AGE EDUCATION
REFORM THAT OF AN OUTLINE IN AB
SEVEN OH FIVE.
AB SEVEN A FIVE WILL REQUIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ASSURE
THAT STUDENTS
COMPLETE TRANSFER LEVEL ENGLISH
OR MATH. WITHIN A YEAR SOME
COLLEGES ARE ALREADY ENGAGING
THOSE REFORMS WITH TREMENDOUS
RESULTS.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
KNOW IS THAT THERE'S MORE THAT
THERE'S MORE THAN ONE WAY TO DO
THAT SO CORRECT WAS THAT MODEL
IS ONE OPTION.
STAT WAY MODEL IS ANOTHER A BUT
WE THINK THAT THIS WILL BE THE
KEY TO HELPING MORE OF OUR
STUDENTS SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE.
AND ALSO ADDRESSING MANY OF THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT HAVE BEEN
SO STUBBORN FOR MANY DECADES.
THE ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER ALSO INITIATED NAM IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IN MANY WAYS
REFLECTS THE BEGINNINGS OF
GUIDED PATHWAYS EFFORTS IN OUR
IN OUR SYSTEM.
AS YOU MAY RECALL THE ADT IS A
FULLY ARTICULATED AND SYSTEM
WIDE CURRICULUM MAP FOR OVER
THIRTY DEGREE PATTERNS.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AS WELL
AS OUR CSU PARTNERS ARE
COMMITTED TO THE SISTINE SUPPORT
AND DEVELOPMENT OVER THE AGE OF
THE AB T..
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS THE AB
T. HAS GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY AS
EVIDENCED BY THE FOLLOWING DATA.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN TO
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
ASSOCIATE DEGREES FOR TRANSFER
WERE AVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICABLE URGE STUDENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICABLE EDGES NOW OFFER.
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY TEASE TO STUDENTS
WITH THAT ARE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ELK TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AND
TWELVE APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED ASSOCIATE DEGREES FOR
TRANSFER WERE AWARDED TO
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIVE
STUDENTS.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE ASSOCIATE DEGREES
FOR TRANSFER WERE AWARDED.
WHICH PUTS US ON TRACK TO EARN
THE NUMBER OF OF.
DEGREES AS A GOAL OF FORTY ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE ASSOCIATE DEGREES FOR
TRANSFER HAVE ALSO DEMONSTRATED
PROGRESS TOWARD AMELIORATING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AMONG VARIOUS
STUDENT GROUPS.
FOR INSTANCE LATINO LATINO
STUDENTS GROWTH IN AT T.
OBTAINMENT HAS BEEN EXPONENTIAL
FROM LESS THAN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWELVE AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN. TO ALMOST EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
HOWEVER AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS DEGREE OBTAINMENT WALL
PROVING HAS NOT GROWN AT THE
SAME RATES
AN ISSUE THAT GUIDED PATHWAYS
AND BASIC SKILLS REFORM. WILL
HELP TO CHANGE.
MORE SYSTEMATIC WORK HOWEVER
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER
EDUCATION NEEDS. AND TO THAT END
A NEW FUNDING FORMULA HAS BEEN
PROPOSED ONE THAT WOULD HELP
STABILIZE FUNDING RATES LOCALLY
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S NEEDIEST STUDENTS.
AND INCENTIVIZE WORK THAT
RESULTS IN INCREASED STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
THE CURRENT FUNDING MODEL IS
SOLELY BASED ON STUDENT
ENROLLMENT AND GROWTH AND IT
SHARPLY PENALIZES COLLEGES WHEN
THE ECONOMY SHIFTS AND GROWTH IS
MORE DIFFICULT.
WITHOUT GROWTH DOLLARS OR COLA
COLLEGES DO NOT HAVE A
SYSTEMATIC WAY TO CULTIVATE
FUNDING INCREASES TO MEET THE
CHANGING NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENT
BODY.
WITH A MORE BALANCED APPROACH TO
FUNDING THAT INCORPORATES.
THREE DIFFERENT LEGS WE THINK
THAT UP COLLEGES WILL HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO INNOVATE AND SUPPORT
THEIR STUDENTS.
THE DETAILS OF HOW THE FUNDING
FORMULA WILL SPECIFICALLY WORK
ARE BEING DISCUSSED NOW AND
CHANCER OAKLEY HAS ASKED THE
PRESIDENTS AND CHANCELLORS TO
TAKE THE LEAD ON DEVELOPING THE
SPECIFICS OF THE MODEL.
FINALLY THE BUDGET INCLUDES A
PROPOSAL FOR A NEW ONLINE
COLLEGE.
BOTH THE GOVERNOR AND CHANCER
OAKLEY ARE FORWARD THINKING AND
LOOKING AT WAYS THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM CAN ADDRESS NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WHO ARE NOT
ALREADY BEING SERVED?
CURRENT LABOR RESEARCH PAINTS A
DIM PICTURE OF THE ECONOMIC
STABILITY OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
LITTLE OR NO COLLEGE EDUCATION.
AND YET THAT IS THE SITUATION
FOR TOO MANY.
AS THE DEMANDS FOR JOB SKILLS
CONTINUE TO GROW AND CHANGE
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE NEEDS TO
DYNAMICALLY MEET THOSE NEEDS.
AND ALSO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
WORKERS WHO ARE IN MANY WAYS
STRANDED.
STRANDED BECAUSE THEIR WORK
SCHEDULES ARE CONDITIONS LIMIT
THEIR CAPACITY TO ATTEND A
TRADITIONAL BRICK AND MORTAR
COLLEGE.
STRANDED BY TRADITIONAL
ENOUGH FLEXIBLE OPPORTUNITY. AND
STRANDED BY A DEFINITION OF
EDUCATION THE DOES NOT FLEX
OPTIONS FOR SUB AWARDS OR MICRO
CREDENTIALS.
THAT WOULD BOOST EARNING
CAPACITY AND ALSO FINANCIAL
STABILITY.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE JUST
HAVE ALREADY ENGAGED ONLINE
LEARNING FOR MANY OF ITS
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMMING
OFFERINGS.
THROUGH THE ONLINE EDUCATION
INITIATIVE.
AND THROUGH THAT INITIATIVE MUCH
HAS BEEN LEARNED ABOUT THE BEST
WAY TO DESIGN COURSES TO PROVIDE
STUDENTS SUPPORT.
TO PROVIDE TECHNOLOGY INTERFACES
HOWEVER THE ONLY I THE ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE WAS
DESIGNED TO SERVE.
CURRENT STUDENTS WHO ARE ALREADY
ENGAGED IN THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFER WORK.
AND WHO ARE NOW LEARNING ON A
TRADITIONAL SEMESTER OR QUARTER
CALENDAR.
THE NEW ONLINE COLLEGE IS
CURRENTLY DEVISED TO BE
SOMETHING MUCH DIFFERENT.
A PLATFORM IN WHICH STUDENTS
COULD ENROLL IMMEDIATELY AND
ENGAGE IN BURSTS OF EDUCATION
RESULTING IN MEANINGFUL
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS THAT ARE
IMMEDIATELY APPLICABLE.
THAT COULD MEAN ANYTHING FROM A
FOOD HANDLER'S LICENSE THAT
MIGHT TAKE TWO HOURS.
OR PROJECT MANAGEMENT BADGE THAT
MIGHT TAKE TWO OR THREE WEEKS.
THE NEW ONLINE COLLEGE IS ALSO
BEING DESIGNED OF THE COMPETENCY
BASED MODEL. MEANING THAT IT IS
DESIGNED AROUND THE LEARNERS OWN
PACE TOWARD DEVELOPING MASTERY
OF THE MATERIAL. AND USING
CONSTANT FEEDBACK AND
EDUCATED TECHNOLOGY.
IT IS NOT BUILT ON A TRADITIONAL
MODEL OF READ AND RESPOND BUT
INSTEAD ON THE CONCEPT THAT
LEARNING IS DYNAMIC AND
INDIVIDUALIZED.
AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE THIS
PROPOSAL IS A LONG TERM PROJECT
AND THE GOVERNOR HAS IDENTIFIED
SIGNIFICANT DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THE FOUNDATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THAT PROJECT.
THE CHANCES OFFICES COMMITTED TO
ESTABLISHING PROGRAMS THAT WILL
BE AVAILABLE AND CONSCIOUS OF
LABOR DEMANDS AND IS BEGINNING
TO ESTABLISH.
SOME OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AROUND ACCREDITATION AND
GOVERNANCE.
ALL OF THESE BIG GOAL SUGGEST.
THAT WE ARE COMMITTED TO THE
SPEC EXPANDING ACCESS TO
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS INCREASING
OUTCOMES.
ESPECIALLY AMONG OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND
IMPROVING THE LIFE OF ALL OF OUR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
STUDENTS.
SO TO TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ASPECT OF OUR INITIATIVES I'M
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO DEAN
MATH ROCK.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I THINK
WE'RE IN THE AFTERNOON NOW ON
MATTHEW ROBERTS LIKE WITH THE.
DIVISION OF WORKFORCE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT UNDER BONTA
UNCLE ALONE SHE SENDS HER
REGARDS TODAY.
COULDN'T BE HEAR UP I'M ALSO THE
FORMER SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE
GULF HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY SO COMING
FROM THE CATO SYSTEM.
I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE MIDDLE SKILL JOBS THAT
WE'RE FOCUSING ON IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF WORKFORCE
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
CREATE STACKABLE CREDENTIALS ARE
STACKABLE DEGREES WHERE STUDENTS
CAN SORT OF.
VERSUS IN A VERSATILE WAY SORT
OF DRAW UPON.
MULTI DISCIPLINES FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE HOUSE WHETHER BE
WHAT WE TRADITIONALLY CALL
ACADEMICS OR WILL WE ALSO CALL
ACADEMICS INTRUDER EDUCATION.
AND SO UP FOCUSING ON THESE
MIDDLE SKILL A JOBS IN THESE
OPENINGS IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING PROBABLY FOR THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS. UNDER STRONG WORK
FORCE UNDER.
AB G. ADULT EDUCATION BLOCK
GRANT FUNDS REALLY TRYING TO
OUTCOMES IN THE SYSTEM. AND AS
LAURA MENTIONED THIS MORNING AYE
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING
COMPLETIONS IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BY TWENTY PERCENT. ARE
LOOKING AT THE DATA AND YOU DO
YOU HAVE A.
A HANDOUT HERE IN YOUR PACKET
TODAY THAT JUST KINDA TALKS
ABOUT WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
PROJECTIONS FOR THOSE MIDDLE
SKILL JOBS. UP WHAT WE LOOK AT
IN IN WORKFORCE IS OUR THE
COMPLETIONS WHETHER IT WOULD BE
A TRANSFER WHETHER IT WOULD BE
DEGREE ATTAINMENT WHETHER IT
WOULD BE CERTIFICATE ATTAINMENT.
ALL OF THOSE COUNTY SORT OF
OUTCOMES AND STACKABLE IN TERMS
OF GETTING A STUDENT TO THEIR
ULTIMATE DESTINATION OF. A
GRADUATION BOTH IN COLLEGE AND
CAREER.
IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
SO WE WE RELY HEAVILY ON THE
LABOR MARKET INFORMATION AS
ASSEMBLY PERSON A BAKER TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER TODAY. BUT WE ALSO
TALK ABOUT ENGAGEMENT AND REALLY
ENGAGING WITH THE REGIONAL
ECONOMIES THAT ARE OUT IN THE
SYSTEM UNDER STRONG WORKFORCE
PROGRAM. THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT A REGIONAL
STRUCTURE.
TO HELP SUPPORT THOSE REGIONAL
ECONOMIES BECAUSE AS WE KNOW
EACH REGION IS IS VERY
DIFFERENT.
AYE IN YOUR HANDOUT IT TALKS
ABOUT THE TOP TWENTY FIVE.
JOBS THAT.
SORT OF SCOPE OUT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE MORE
APPLICABLES FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND YOU COULD
SEE HEALTHCARE IS THE LEADING
ONE.
IN ADDITION TO OTHER A BIG
INDUSTRIES SO WE ARE VERY HONED
IN AND TARGETING OF THE REGIONAL
ECONOMIES WE FEEL AS IF.
THIS THIS ONE POINT THREE IS
THIS THE STATE'S ONE POINT THREE
MILLION.
AT NEED GAP FOR MIDDLE SKILLED
WORKERS IS IS A DEFINITE NEED
AND SO WE DEFINITELY SEE THE THE
OUTCOMES. GEARING UP AND WERE
AND RAMPING UP WITHIN OUR OUR
HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES AND
SOON TO BE OUR HUNDRED FIFTEENTH
WITH THE ONLINE COLLEGE.
AND SO THAT'S PRODUCING GOOD
RESULTS FOR US
I SO HOPEFULLY YOU FIND THE.
THE HANDOUT HELPFUL IN TERMS OF
JUST GIVING YOU SOME BASELINE
DATA BUT WE DO FEEL AS IF WE'RE.
WE'RE GETTING VERY CLOSE TO
ACHIEVING THAT GOAL OF OF A
THROUGHPUT OF STUDENTS COMING UP
FROM OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM.
AND OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
AND THEN ON TO.
BUT I SEE ISSUE AND YOU SEE SO.
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF OUR WORK
OUT WITH THAT.
AND I'LL MAKE SOME VERY QUICK
POINTS ON INFRASTRUCTURE WE'VE
INCLUDED IN THE PACKET  A
PLAN THAT WE SUBMIT TO YOU IN
THE ADMINISTRATION EVERY YEAR.
UP TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF THAT CHALLENGE THE
FIVE YEAR PLAN ADOPTED BY THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS PROJECTS IN
NEED OF TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS IN CAPITAL PROJECTS.
OF THAT TOTAL ABOUT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IS FOR NEW FACILITIES
ABOUT TWELVE BILLIONS FOR
MODERNIZATION OF EXISTING
FACILITIES. OVER TEN YEARS WE
EXPECT ABOUT A NEED GROWS TO
ABOUT FOR A FORTY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS.
EVEN THAT TOTAL THOUGH DOES NOT
REPRESENT THE TOTAL FACILITIES
NEED FOR THE COLLEGES AND AS
WE'VE REPORTED BEFORE OUR OFFICE
ESTIMATES THAT THERE'S MORE THAN
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FACILITIES MAINTENANCE NEEDS
OVER FIVE YEARS.
AS YOU KNOW MEETING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF THE
COLLEGES AS A RESPONSIBILITY
THAT'S BEEN SHARED BY THE STATE
AND LET ME GO TO COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
AND WE CAN ACCOUNT FOR THAT IN
OUR PLANNING PROCESSES BY
ESTIMATING THAT ABOUT FORTY
PERCENT OF THE NEED.
IS ADDRESS WITH LOCAL FUNDS.
I AFTER ACCOUNTING FOR THE LOCAL
FUNDS AND PROPERTY ONE BOND
FUNDS WE ESTIMATE THAT OUR PLAN
THE FEW REMAINING NEED OF STATE
FUNDS IS ABOUT SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS OVER TEN YEARS.
AS THE CHAIR NOTED.
WE'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT
ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO MEET
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ALL
HIGHLIGHT TO THE FIRST IS ON
YEAR ROUND INSTRUCTION. IN THAT
REPORT YOU'LL SEE A STATISTIC
THAT SAYS OVER THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF DAYS
OF INSTRUCTION. HAS INCREASED BY
TWENTY THREE DAYS FROM TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE DAYS TO
TUTOR AT NINETY FOUR DAYS.
AND THAT WE KNOW ONLINE
EDUCATION WILL HAVE IMPACTS ON
OUR CAPITAL PLANNING AND SO WE
MAKE ASSUMPTIONS.
THAT WE UPSET ABOUT TEN PERCENT
OF THE NEED TO TRY TO ACCOUNT
FOR THAT IMPACT.
BUT IN THE IMMEDIATE TERM OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITY IN THIS AREA
SECURING FUNDING FOR THE
PROJECTS INCLUDED IN THE SYSTEMS
BUDGET REQUEST.
AND SO FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE
HAD REQUESTED.
.
THAT.
THIRTY THREE PROJECTS BE FUNDED
FIFTEEN CONTINUING PROJECTS
EIGHTEEN NEW STAR PROJECTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FUNDS FIVE
OF THOSE PROJECTS AND SO WERE
WORKING WE PLAN TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BETTER
JUSTIFIER NEEDS BUT WE HOPE THAT
WE CAN WORK WITH YOU TO. TO
EXPLAIN OUR NEEDS AS PART OF
THIS PROCESS.
AND OVER THE LONGER TERM WE HOPE
TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
TO BEST MEET PIC COLLEGES
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
.
BY NECESSITY WE CREATE THESE
CAPITAL PLANS BY PROJECTING OUR
CURRENT TRENDS.
BUT THE POINT OF THE VISION OF
SPUR SUCCESS IN OF THIS HEARING
IS THAT MORE DRAMATIC CHANGE IS
NEEDED. AND SO AS WE MADE OUR
MOVE FORWARD WE HOPE WE CAN WORK
WITH YOU TO CONSIDER SOME
QUESTIONS HOW BEST ABOUT STATE
LOCAL ROLES. HOW DO YOU TARGET
RESOURCES TO THE DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS AND HOW DO YOU
STRUCTURE INCENTIVES IN THE WAIT
FOR DISTRICTS TO THINK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE CONSISTENT WITH
THE STATE CALLS?
SO JUST CAN TO CONCLUDE ARE A
FEW CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
OBVIOUSLY THE SIZE OF OUR SYSTEM
WOULD TWO POINT THREE MILLION
STUDENTS.
CREATES BOTH A CHALLENGE AND AN
OPPORTUNITY IN THE SENSE THAT WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY IMPACT.
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS.
BUT ALSO IT'S A COMPLEX SYSTEM
GIVEN ITS SIZE.
SOME OTHER MORE A MORE GRANULAR
CHALLENGES INCLUDE.
IDENTIFYING ACTING UPON
SEGMENTAL BARRIERS WITH BOTH K.
TWELVE AND UNIVERSITY PARTNERS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS MOVE MORE SEAMLESSLY
THROUGH OUR SYSTEM AND ONE OF
THINGS THAT WOULD HELP THAT IS.
AS WAS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY OF
BETTER ATTENTION TO DATA
COLLECTION AND DATA SHARING. IT
IS ALSO OUR HOPE.
THAT STUDENTS OF WHO ARE
ACHIEVING A AT THE AB T. WOULD
HAVE OPTIONS BETWEEN BOTH THE
CSU AND YOU SEE AND NOT HAVE TO
CHOOSE ONE OR THE OTHER TWO
EARLY IN THEIR. COLLEGE CAREER
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
INDEPENDENT UNIVERSITIES AS WELL
AS THE YOU SEE HONOR THE ADT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT OUR SYSTEM
COULD IMPROVE WITH.
IN TERMS OF ACTION PLANNING
WITH MORE POST EMPLOYMENT DATA.
ON IF WE HAVE THAT AVAILABLE
THAT WOULD ASSIST US.
AND.
WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY.
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
WE WARN YOU OUT YEAH I KNOW BUT.
YOU HAVE. A AMERICA IT'S IT'S
ARE. REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT
CAUCUS LUNCH RIGHT NOW WE ARE
MISSING SO. AND IN SOME OF THE
ISSUES FRANKLY WILL BE
DISCUSSING IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
AND LATER ON THE SPRING SO. VOTE
CONTINUE BRING UP OUR
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES AND. MAKE SURE WE
DON'T IGNORE THEM.
YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M BETH HELMET ON THE
PRESIDENT OF MEL'S COLLEGE I'M
GRATEFUL NOT TO BE IGNORED AND
I'M AWARE WERE BETWEEN YOU AND
PUBLIC COMMENT AND LUNCH SO. WE
WILL ACCELERATE OUR PRESENTATION
HERE.
THANK YOU A CHAIR MCCARTY AND
STEPPED OUT FOR YOUR PRESENCE
HERE ALSO ALL THE.
MEMBERS WHO ARE STILL HERE.
LISTENING TO US.
AS THE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. MORE THAN SEVENTY
FIVE.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES THAT
COLLECTIVELY GRANT MORE THAN ONE
FIFTH OF ALL THE UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREES IN THE STATE EACH YEAR.
AND MORE THAN HALF OF ALL OF OUR
GRADUATE DEGREES.
WE ALSO INVEST INSTITUTIONALLY
IN OUR STUDENTS. BILLS ITSELF A
HISTORICALLY A WOMEN'S COLLEGE
THAT GRANTS DEGREES TO WOMEN AND
GENDER NON BINARY STUDENTS AT
THE UNDERGRADUATE LEVEL AND ALL
GENDERS AT THE GRADUATE LEVEL.
WE ENROLL ABOUT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AND WE GIVE INSTITUTIONAL AID
OF ABOUT TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
EACH YEAR. OVERALL OUR SECTOR
GIVES EIGHT ON THE ORDER OF ONE
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR TO USE TO STUDENTS.
WE ALSO ENROLL A MAJORITY OF OUR
STUDENTS FROM CALIFORNIA AT
MILLS THAT MEANS ABOUT FOUR
FIFTHS OF OUR STUDENTS COME FROM
CALIFORNIA AND FOUR OF THE
INSTITUTIONS ACROSS THE A I CC
YOU. IT MEANS ABOUT THREE
QUARTERS OF OUR STUDENTS COME
FROM CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT OF OUR
STUDENTS AT MILLS OUR STUDENTS
OF COLOR THAT'S ABOUT THAT'S
ABOUT COMPARABLE TO THE AVERAGE
ACROSS THE A I CC YOU
INSTITUTIONS. WE HAVE THIRTY
PERCENT LATINO STUDENTS AT MILLS
I'M ABOUT A QUARTER AT OVERALL
AT ACROSS THE SECTOR. WE ARE
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTION AT
MILLS AS OUR THIRTY ONE OTHER.
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES.
WE ENROLL MORE THAN A THIRD
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS OVERALL WE ENROLL
ABOUT.
HALF FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENTS AT MILLS HALF OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE PAL ELIGIBLE ACROSS
THE SECTOR IT'S ALMOST THIRTY
PERCENT.
CAN ALSO OF HALF CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS FOR WHICH WE'RE
GRATEFUL OFF FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ACROSS THE SECTOR IT'S ABOUT
FOURTEEN PERCENT ALSO MENTION
THAT MILLS IS MORE THAN HALF
LGBTQ.
WHICH IS A SIGN OF WHERE WE ARE
IN THE BAY AREA TO AND NOW I
WANNA FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON OUT
HOW MILLS HAS WORKED ACROSS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TO CONNECT
TO THE PUBLIC SECTOR. INTO THE
ARCADE THROUGH TWELVE SECTOR TO
ENHANCE OUR ABILITY TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE NEEDS.
SO THERE'S THREE THINGS I THAT
I'LL TALK TO YOU ON BEHALF OF
THE A I CC YOU AND NO TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE A I CC YOU
CHRISTENSEN ARE AS IS IN
WASHINGTON DC OTHERWISE SHE
WOULD BE HERE FOR YOU SO I'M
PINCH HITTING. OB.
WITH THE SEVENTY EIGHT CAMPUSES
THAT A AYE CCU HASN'T SEVENTY
SERVE UNDERGRADUATES.
MORE THAN FIFTY SIX ALREADY HAVE
ARTICULATION AGREEMENTS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO IN TERMS
OF ADVANCING ACCESS.
I THE INDEPENDENT SECTOR IS VERY
MUCH INVESTED IN ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
MOST STUDENTS AND FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE CLOSE TO AN
INDEPENDENT COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY.
AND MANY OF OUR COLLEGES.
HAVE ALREADY I WORK TO
INTEGRATE THE EIGHTY T. PROGRAM
MILLS AND MANY OTHER
INSTITUTIONS ARE WORKING TO DO
THAT RIGHT NOW AT MILLS WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MAJORS THAT WE
SEE MAPPING INTO THAT ASSOCIATE
DEGREE TRANSFER PROGRAM.
SO ACCESS IS A CRITICAL PIECE
FROM MY DEMOGRAPHIC SKETCH YOU
ALREADY SEE THAT THE SECOND
THING I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT IS COMPLETION.
A I CC YOU INSTITUTIONS ALREADY
HOLD THE HIGHEST COMPLETION
RATES IN THE STATE.
OUR FACULTY TO STUDENT RATIOS
ARE LOW BUT ELEVEN TO ONE.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A STRONG
DEGREE OF CONNECTION AND SENSE
OF BELONGING FOR OUR STUDENTS
BASED IN PART ON OUR SIZE AND
OUR ON OUR ATTITUDE OF PUTTING
STUDENTS AT THE CENTER OF OUR
MISSION.
HOWEVER WE'RE NOT DOING WELL
ENOUGH THERE AND WE'RE NOT
STANDING FAST.
AT MILLS FOR INSTANCE THERE
SEVERAL INITIATIVES THAT ARE
UNDERWAY TO IMPROVE HOW STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES
ACTUALLY DO WITH AN ART DEGREE
GRANTING PROGRAMS.
A FEW EXAMPLES AM POWER IS A NEW
SIGNATURE UNDERGRADUATE
EXPERIENCE FOR US THAT FOCUSES
ON COMMUNITY ENGAGED LEARNING
AND FACULTY MENTORS
UNDERGRADUATE RESEARCH
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERY STUDENT.
WE ALSO ARE IMPLEMENTING E.
PORTFOLIOS WHICH GIVE STUDENTS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
METACOGNITIVE LEARNING
REFLECTION TOLL THAT HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
BECAUSE STUDENTS HAVE A CHANCE
TO CONNECT TO THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING. AND PREPARE IT
AND CURATED FOR FUTURE EMPLOYERS
AND GRADUATE SCHOOLS THAT THEY
MIGHT BE INTERESTED AND.
WERE ALSO INTERESTED IN MANY OF
THE INITIATIVES YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD ABOUT FROM OTHERS ACROSS
THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
TRANSFORMATIONAL ADVISING.
ACADEMIC NAVIGATORS WHO CAN
HELP STUDENTS UNDERSTAND AND
SUCCEED WITH AN ACADEMIC AND
CAREER ENVIRONMENTS. AND ALSO
DEVELOPING OUR FACULTY WERE
ASKING A LOT OF OUR FACULTY
TODAY AT THE INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES AND ELSEWHERE AND WE
NEED TO HELP THEM PREPARE TO
MEET THAT CHALLENGE BY A BY
PREPARING THEM UP FOR THE THE
MULTIPLE ROLES THEY HAVE NOW.
FINALLY WITH COMPLETION WE CAN'T
FAIL TO TALK ABOUT AFFORDABILITY
WE REALIZE THOSE THINGS GO HAND
IN HAND ACROSS THE SECTOR WERE
WORKING TO PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL AID TO OUR STUDENTS.
AT MILLS WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A
HISTORIC TUITION RESET WHERE WE
REDUCED OUR TUITION BY THIRTY
SIX PERCENT FOR NEXT YEAR.
THAT ENABLES US TO BETTER
TRANSLATE OUR VALUE TO STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES WHO ACTUALLY CAN'T
AFFORD AN EDUCATION AND
INDEPENDENT COLLEGE BUT DON'T
ALWAYS REALIZE THAT FROM THE
COMPLEXITY OF PRICING THAT HAS
BECOME A HALLMARK OF HIGHER ED.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO TALK TO
ABOUT HIS INNOVATION AND IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT COMING FROM THE
BAY AREA I WOULD TALK TO YOU
ABOUT INNOVATION. I I WANT TO
GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES FROM
ACROSS OUR SECTOR I THINK IT'S
BEEN A HALLMARK OF CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO EXPERIMENT TO
TRY THINGS AND TO.
HIT ON NEW IDEAS THAT CAN MAKE
A DIFFERENCE UP ACROSS HIGHER
EDUCATION AND NOT ONLY EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES WERE AMONG THE FIRST TO
HAVE FOUR YEAR COMBINED
BACHELORS AND TEACHING
CREDENTIAL PROGRAMS.
WERE INNOVATORS IN THE ONLINE
SPEAR FROM WHICH YOU'LL HEAR
MORE FROM MY COLLEAGUE A DOCTOR
DAVID PULL FROM CALIFORNIA
BAPTIST UNIVERSITY.
WE'VE ALSO HAD SEVERAL
INSTITUTIONS MAKE SPECIFIC
ARRANGEMENTS A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES POINT LOMA NAZARENE
UNIVERSITY LANDLOCKED AND NOT
ABLE TO PHYSICALLY GROW CREATED
A PARTNERSHIP WITH ITS LOCAL SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO
CREATE A TWO PLUS TWO PROGRAM SO
THAT STUDENTS CAN COMPLETE A
BACHELOR'S OF SCIENCE IN NURSING
WITHOUT EVER LEAVING THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
UNIVERSITY OF THE PACIFIC.
STOCKTON WITH SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
COLLEGE WHERE THEY IDENTIFIED
STUDENTS INTERESTED IN TEACHING
AND RECRUITED THEM INTO A TWO
PLUS TO PROGRAM WHERE THEY
TRANSFER FINISHED AGREES AND
EARNED A TEACHING CREDENTIAL IN
JUST FOUR YEARS.
THOSE ARE GREAT EXAMPLES OF
COLLABORATIONS ACROSS THE
SECTORS AT MILLS I WANNA SHARE
SOME OF OUR OWN EFFORTS TO
CREATE A HUB OF INNOVATION AND
HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
SO WE'VE WORKED TO LEVERAGE OUR
LOCATION IN THE BAY AREA AND IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
PROMOTE PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT.
AND COST SHARING BECAUSE WERE
ALL TRYING TO REDUCE COSTS AND
HIGHER ED. AND ALSO TO SEEK
FOUGHT PARTNERS IN COLLABORATIVE
WAYS TO ENHANCE INNOVATION.
WE THINK WE CAN WORK WITH UC
BERKELEY TO IMPROVE OUR OUR.
COLLECTIVE CAPACITY TO ADVANCE
BOB REGIONAL NEED TO MEET THOSE
REGIONAL NEEDS AN EDUCATION.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REPUTATION
THAT CAN WORK AND COLLABORATION
WITH UC BERKELEY'S TO CREATE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
WE'VE HAD A TASK FORCE RUNNING
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR WE
FORMALIZED THAT COLLABORATION
WITH UC BERKELEY'S CHANCELLOR
AND THAT TASK FORCE HAS ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL INITIATIVES.
THEY'RE ONLY REALLY LIMITED BY
THEIR CREATIVITY AND INTEREST
WE'VE ALREADY WORKED ON HOUSING
COLLABORATION. ADDITIONAL CROSS
REGISTRATION.
KEY COURSES THAT ARE BERKELEY
STUDENTS CAN TAKE AT MEL'S AND
COURSES THAT MIL STUDENTS CAN
TAKE AT BERKELEY. GLOBAL
INTERNSHIP AND STUDY AWAY
OPPORTUNITIES THREE PLUS TWO
DEGREES A FAST TRACK TO GRADUATE
DEGREES FOR UC BERKELEY STUDENTS
FROM A FROM A FROM MILLS AND
OTHER MEASURES.
SO THAT'S A WAY FOR US TO HELP
UC BERKELEY MEET ITS ITS
CAPACITY ISSUES BY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF SOME OF THINGS
MILLS IS ESPECIALLY GOOD AT.
WE'VE ALSO WORKED WITH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT THE
PERALTA DISTRICT IS A POWERHOUSE
OF A COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
RIGHT IN OUR BACKYARD WE DEVELOP
PATHWAYS TO DEGREES AND WE HAVE
A TASK FORCE OPEN AND RUNNING
I'M WORKING ON AN AMMO YOU. SO
THAT WE CAN FORMALIZE THOSE AND
FINALLY I WANT TO MENTION OUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT. OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AYE HAS
AN OAKLAND PROMISEPROGRAM THAT
IS DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THOSE
COMPLETION RATES FOR THE OAKLAND
STUDENTS WHO ARE RIGHT OUTSIDE
THE GATES OF MEL'S.
THIS YEAR WE'VE GUARANTEED AN
ADDITIONAL TEN SCHOLARSHIPS TO
OAKLAND PROMISE STUDENTS THAT
COMBINED WITH PELL GRANTS AND
CAL GRANTS WILL ACTUALLY MAKE
THE COST OF MILLS FREE TO
STUDENTS I'M FROM OAKLAND. WITH
THOSE SCHOLARSHIPS THROUGH THE
OAKLAND PROMISE PROGRAM ONE OF
THOSE IS FOCUSED ON AFRICAN
AMERICAN FEMALE STUDENTS THE
OTHER ON ONE OTHER SPECIFIED FOR
A LATINA EXCELLENT STUDENT SO.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY FOCUSING ON
THE DEMOGRAPHICS THAT ARE
CHANGING FAST IS IN CALIFORNIA
AND READY TO SERVE THEM.
I'LL JUST SAY MORE GENERALLY FOR
OUR SECTOR I THINK YOU'LL FIND
US NIMBLE AND READY TO
COLLABORATE ON TO MEET THIS
WORKFORCE CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE
SAID AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
CALIFORNIA BAPTIST.
THEY DON'T HELP WITH. A GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN NINA AND
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT TIMELY
ISSUE.
AND TODAY WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES FACING THE STATE'S
FOLLOWING TO TALK ABOUT SOME
SOLUTIONS.
MY NAME IS DAVID COLE I'M VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE DIVISION OF
ONLINE AND PROFESSIONAL STUDIES
AT CALIFORNIA BAPTIST
UNIVERSITY.
CEBU ONLINE WAS ESTABLISHED
RESPONDED THE VERY DIFFERENT
NEEDS OF THE NEW NORMAL
GENERATION OF STUDENTS.
THE NONTRADITIONAL STUDENT THAT
BALANCES PROFESSIONAL AND FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES WHILE ADVANCING
THEIR EDUCATION.
OUR ONLINE AND HYBRID PROGRAMS
OFFER STUDENTS THE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN FLEXIBILITY EXPECTED FOR
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY LEARNING.
CEBU ONLINE OFFERS DEGREE
PROGRAMS UTILIZING THE LATEST
TECHNOLOGIES AND DISTANCE
EDUCATION THROUGH FACULTY AND
STAFF WHO ARE COMMITTED TO THE
STUDENTS ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL SUCCESS.
CAL BAPTIST UNIVERSITY AS A
WHOLE IS A WASP ACCREDITED NON
PROFIT UNIVERSITY HEADQUARTERED
IN THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE.
WITH A PRESENCE THROUGHOUT
RIVERSIDE AND SAN BENITO COUNTY
AND BEYOND.
THE UNIVERSITY WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY CURRENTLY IN
ROLES TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AT
THE UNDERGRADUATE GRADUATE AND
DOCTORAL LEVEL.%
OF OUR UNDERGRADS CLOSE TO
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN CEBU ONLINE.
EACH YEAR CBO ONLINE GRADUATES
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
WITH BACHELOR'S DEGREES.
HELPING THEM ACHIEVE THEIR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND CAREER
GOALS.
REMEMBER THESE ARE PRIMARILY
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS.
ADULTS
THAT HAVE SOME COLLEGE UNITS BUT
NOT A BE A OR B. S..
THEY WANT TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
FINISH THAT DEGREE IN ADVANCE IN
THEIR CAREERS ARE SHIPPED TO NEW
ONES.
ACCORDING TO THE LUMINA
FOUNDATION THERE ARE FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS WITH
SOME COLLEGE CREDIT BUT NO
DEGREE.
THERE'S A HUGE UNTAPPED
POTENTIAL HERE FOR THE STATE FOR
ITS ECONOMY AND ESPECIALLY FOR
THE STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THIS IS A POPULATION THAT THE
STATE NEEDS TO SERVE UP WE ARE
TO CLOSE THE ONE POINT ONE
MILLION BACHELOR'S DEGREE GAP.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE PROBLEMS.
BUT HOW ABOUT SOME SOLUTIONS.
CB ONLINE WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE
FALL OF TWENTY TEN AS A SEPARATE
OPERATING DIVISION FROM THE MAIN
CAMPUS.
WE CALL IT A UNIVERSITY WITHIN
THE UNIVERSITY.
THE DIVISION HAS IT'S OWN
FACULTY ADMINISTRATION
ADMISSIONS RETENTION ASSESSMENT
AN OPERATING BUDGET.
THIS ALLOWED CB YOU TO HIRE A
TEAM OF PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE
FOCUSED SPECIFICALLY ON THE
ONLINE ON THE ON THE ADULT
STUDENT.
THIS SET UP THE CONDITIONS FOR
SUCCESS.
IN TWENTY TEN THERE WERE JUST
OVER FIVE HUNDRED DEGREE
COMPLETION STUDENTS WHO WERE
OFFERED TWELVE MAJORS. AND
CONCENTRATIONS THAT WERE HOUSED
IN THE VARIOUS SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES ON OUR MAIN CAMPUS.
THESE REMOVED UNDER THE
OVERSIGHT OF THESE WERE MOVED
AND MOVED ON TO THE OVERSIGHT OF
CEBU ONLINE. AND SEVEN AND A
HALF YEARS LATER.
CV ONLINE SERVICES JUST UNDER
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS
AND NOW OFFERS FORTY TWO MAJORS
IN CONCENTRATIONS.
THAT INCLUDE FOURTEEN MASTER'S
PROGRAMS
AND TO DOCTOR PROGRAMS.
WE NOW HAVE TWENTY SIX MAJORS AT
THE BACHELORS LEVEL AND THAT
CONTINUES TO GROW EACH YEAR.
MOST IMPORTANT OUR FOCUS ON
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT BETWEEN
FACULTY AND STUDENTS HAVE
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT
RETENTION. AND PERSISTENT RATES
FOR ADULT ONLINE STUDENTS.
THE SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE FOR
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS.
YOU THESE YOUR U. S.
INSTITUTIONS IN THE SAME
CARNEGIE CLASSIFICATION THE CB
YOU.
MASTERS LARGE PROGRAMS.
THAT OFFER ALL PROGRAMS
COMPLETELY VIA DISTANCE
EDUCATION
THE AVERAGE.
IS TWENTY SIX POINT THREE
PERCENT.
CBO ONLINE IS SIXTY FIVE POINT
TWO PERCENT.
FIRST A SECOND YEAR COHORT
RETENTION RATES FOR U. S.
INSTITUTIONS IN THE SAME
CARNEGIE CLASSIFICATION.
IS FORTY TWO POINT SEVEN
PERCENT CBO ONLINE IS SEVENTY
ONE POINT TWO.
AS CBO IS A HISPANIC SERVING
INSTITUTION.
THIRTY NINE POINT THREE PERCENT
OF CBO ONLINE IN THIS IS JUST
THE DIVISION NOT THE OVERALL CBO
THAT'S EVEN MORE.
THIRTY NINE PER THIRTY NINE
POINT THREE PERCENT OF CBO
ONLINE ARE HISPANIC WITH THE
RETENTION RATE THAT WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF OF SIXTY NINE POINT TWO
PERCENT THESE ARE ADULT
STUDENTS.
TOTAL MINORITY POPULATION IS
SIXTY THREE POINT THREE PERCENT
AT CEBU ONLINE. AND FIRST TO
SECOND YEAR COHORT RETENTION
RATES FOR THIS GROUP IS SIXTY
EIGHT POINT FIVE PERCENT.
WHEN THE CONDITIONS FOR
SUCCESSFUL PRESIDENT
YOU CAN ACCOMPLISH MUCH FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
A MORE RECENT EXAMPLE OF WAYS
THAT A I SEE SIEU SCHOOLS CAN
HELP CLOSE THE GAP.
IS AN EXAMPLE OF CBO LINES FAST
TRACK TO SUCCESS PROGRAM THAT WE
DEVELOPED ORIGINALLY WITH MOUNT
SAN JACINTO COLLEGE.
AND CBO ONLINE AND NOW HAS GROWN
TO A PARTNERSHIP WITH NINETEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WITH OVER EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY STUDENTS CURRENTLY
ENROLLED AND JUST UNDER AN
ADDITIONAL NINE HUNDRED STUDENTS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY EXPLORING THE
PROGRAM.
NOT ONLY IS THIS PROGRAM
EXTREMELY TRANSFER FRIENDLY WITH
ADMISSION GUARANTEES.
BUT INCLUDES INSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLARSHIPS BY CBO ONLINE TO
EASE THE FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THEIR
BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
THE.
US SIGNIFICANT TUITION
DISCOUNTING ALSO.
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM
REALLY MAKES IT VERY COST
EFFECTIVE.
FAIRLY CLOSE TO WHAT A STUDENT
AND ADULTS STUDENT WOULD BE
PAYING.
AT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM.
I THINK THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SYNERGY BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FULLY ONLINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEENTH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. IF THE SKATE STATE DOES
INDEED GO THAT ROUTE.
THE FAST TRACK TO SUCCESS
PROGRAM AS AN EXAMPLE THAT THERE
CAN BE POTENTIAL FOR A STRONG
PIPELINE FOR NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS.
IN CLOSING I'D WANNA MENTION TWO
POINTS.
THERE IS NO FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM TARGETED THIS GROUP OF
STUDENTS THE NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENT WANTS TO COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE.
EVEN A SMALL AMOUNT OF AID FROM
THE STATE WOULD HELP THEM GO.
BACK AND PAY DIVIDENDS FOR THE
STATE IN THE LONG RUN THROUGH
INCREASED INCOME AND SPENDING.
SECONDLY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT SOME PEOPLE HAVE HESITANCY
AROUND ONLINE EDUCATION.
WELL THERE CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN
SOME BAD ACTORS IN THE FOR
PROFIT ARENA.
AND FOR ALL IF WE'RE REALLY
HONEST IN THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
AS WELL.
THERE ARE MANY A I SEE SIEU
SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
WHO LIKE CBO ONLINE. HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT ONLINE AND
HYBRID EDUCATION CAN BE DONE
WELL.
ONCE AGAIN OF THE CONDITIONS FOR
SUCCESSFUL THERE TOGETHER WE CAN
DO GREAT THINGS.
THE STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
OKAY THANK YOU.
QUESTION.
YES MISTER VOEPEL.
THE TRYING TO BURN THROUGH THIS
MISTER CHAIR BUT. GOT A FEW
THINGS TO SAY HER ARM.
I DID A TO TOURISM VIETNAM.
AND WHEN I.
EFT THE MILITARY.
WITH ALL THE NORMAL VETERAN
COMBAT PROBLEMS.
ON.
I HAD TO GET A JOB.
AND EVERYONE TOLD ME TO GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OTHERWISE I'D
BE LOST.
WELL. I TOOK THAT ADVICE AND.
MANY MANY PEOPLE HELP ME ALONG
MY WAY FOR WHAT'S OF FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I WOULDN'T BE
SITTING HERE.
SO I GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
SYSTEM.
EVERYONE IS BUILT FOR MANY YEARS
IT HAS BENEFITTED ME.
MY DISTRICT.
IS.
MIDDLE AND LOW INCOME.
LOW CLASS.
MIDDLE CLASS.
PEOPLE IN URBAN AREAS AND A
LARGE PORTION OF
RULE AREAS AND WE HAVE ALSO A
LARGE.
POPULATION OF REFUGEES.
SO ONCE AGAIN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE MY FIRST LOVE.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE DID.
THE UC AND CSU SYSTEM AND
EVERYTHING THEY'VE BEEN DOING
AND THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN A
STAUNCH SUPPORTER UP AND DOWN
THE LINE FOR EVERYONE SO. WE'RE
WORKING VERY HARD BECAUSE YOU'RE
WORKING HARD.
I DO HAVE SOME.
COMMENTS AND OUT SORT OUT WITH A
RHETORICAL QUESTION.
DUE TO THE HIGH COST OF LIVING A
REAL ESTATE IN CALIFORNIA. WHY
SHOULD ANY OF OUR?
BACHELOR DEGREE GRADUATES
STAY IN CALIFORNIA.
WHAT BACHELOR DEGREE GRADUATES
WOULD WANT TO COME HERE FROM
OTHER STATES?
THAT IS.
BOTH SEVERE RHETORICAL QUESTION.
IF WE HAVE A SEVERE SHORTAGE OF
BACHELORS DEGREE EMPLOYEES I'M
LOOKING AT THIS NOW FROM THE
EMPLOYER VIEWPOINT.
EMPLOYERS MUST ADD INCENTIVES TO
THE EMPLOYMENT PACKAGE TO
ATTRACT.
CALIFORNIA OR OUT OF STATE
GRADUATES.
THAT'S A TREMENDOUS HANDICAP IN
THE OPEN MARKETPLACE.
BECAUSE WE CAN DO THE BEST JOB
IN THE WORLD EDUCATING THESE
PEOPLE AND IF THEY CAN'T GET A
JOB WERE LIVING CALIFORNIA WE'RE
IN DEEP TROUBLE.
PERSONAL OBSERVATION I WAS IN A
BUILDING.
WHEN I WAS IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
CORPORATE SECTOR.
I WAS IN A BUILDING WITH OVER
TWO HUNDRED HIGH TECHNOLOGY
PEOPLE MOST OF THEM WERE P. H.
D.'S AND BACHELORS MASTERS
EXCEPT FOR.
EXCEPT FOR THEY WEREN'T FROM
AMERICA OUT OF TWO HUNDRED AT
LEAST A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY WHERE
FROM INDIA NIGERIA TAIWAN. ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
AND THE REASON THEY WERE THERE
IS A WERE DOING THE SAME JOB AS
OUR GRADUATES.
BUT THE CORPORATIONS IN THE
COMPANIES TO PUT SIX SEPARATE IN
A THREE BEDROOM. UNIT.
WORLD.
LESSON LEARNED THEIR.
SO.
THIS COMMITTEE AND YOU WE ARE
NOT JUST TRYING TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE AND GET THEM GRADUATED.
WE HAVE TO GAINFULLY EMPLOY HIM
AND COMPETE.
DRAMATICALLY AGAINST THE WHOLE
REST THE WORLD.
MANY OF.
THE BACHELOR DEGREE HOLDERS CAN
WORK OUT OF STATE AND STILL DATA
COMMUTE WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
BUSINESSES
SO IT ISN'T JUST A LITTLE
EMPLOYER.
MANY MANY COMPANIES NOW ARE
DOING AWAY WITH CALL CENTERS THE
CALL CENTERS ARE SIMPLY.
THE TRAINING CENTERS AND
EVERYONE'S WORKING OUT A STATE
OUT OF THEIR HOUSES EXCEPT ROOM
ONCE I GET TRAINED UP.
THAT'S GOING TO REFLECT ALSO ON
OUR BACHELOR MASTER AND P. H.
D.'S.
SO THE WHOLE TECHNOLOGY.
CHANGE IN IN THE WORLD.
BRICK AND MORTAR ISN'T MAKING
IT.
I'M.
BRICK AND MORTAR.
PEOPLE CAN BE WAREHOUSED
OR WORK REMOTELY FROM ANYWHERE
IN THE BILL WORLD.
SO NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE TO
COMPETE WITH OUR OWN PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES WE'RE
COMPETING WITH THE WORLD.
NOT LIKE THE TRANSITION JUST
BRIEFLY.
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE GRADS IN
VOCATIONAL GRADS.
THEY WORK IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY GENERALLY DON'T DATA
COMMUTE REMOTELY THEY ARE
PLUMBERS ELECTRICIANS.
SELL TECHNICIANS ALL THAT STUFF
AND I LIKE TO CALL THEM.
TONGUE IN CHEEK
NOT SILICON VALLEY BUT RED CLAY
VALLEY.
OKAY THEIR HER NOT COMMUNITY
THERE HERE DOING STUFF RIGHT
HERE IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OUR THEIR BABIES THAT'S THEIR
MOM AND DAD OKAY.
AND I'M FINALLY SILICON VALLEY
HAS ITS CHALLENGES IN ARE BASIC
ECONOMY ALSO HAS CHALLENGES.
A BASIC ECONOMY.
MUST HAVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AA
GRADUATES TO RUN SMALL
BUSINESSES EMPLOY OTHER HIGH
SCHOOL COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND.
HIGHER DEGREES.
IT'S INTERESTING BICU GOT A
SHEET METAL SHOP IN YOUR
SUCCESSFUL NOVEL SON YOU HAVE
SIXTY EIGHTY EMPLOYEES YOU'RE
HIRING THAT MBA.
TO HELP YOU.
VERY INTERESTING HOW THIS STUFF
WORKS.
I'M.
SO.
I'LL LEAVE YOU WITH THIS LAST
STATEMENT.
IT MY DISTRICT THE DEGREE GAP IS
BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND THAT IS PROBABLY.
OF FAIR AMOUNT. OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS
THERE OUTSIDE THE LARGER URBAN
AREAS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTARY.
REYES ABOUT A NUMBER OF ISSUES
FOR OUR POLICY CAMINO BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER GOING FOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PART OF YOUR
PANEL THAT JUST BY HAND THAT
THERE ANY ANYBODY BUT TO TESTIFY
IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY TWO PEOPLE COME ON UP
MISSED MCCARTY AS THEY YET PART
I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS DOCTOR
POOL FOR COMING CB YOU IS A
GREAT. ASSET TO OUR COMMUNITY
AND I'VE BEEN TO SEVERAL OF THE
OUR ONLINE GRADUATIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU BOTH. AND I ADMIRE THE
FLEXIBILITY OF THE PRIVATE
COLLEGES
SO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR GOOD
WORK.
I THINK I CAN IN.
CHAIRS MEDINA MCCARTY AND THE
HOUSE WILL AS YOUR COLLEAGUES
AND STAFF THANK YOU FOR A ONE
MINUTE. AND I'M GONNA KEEP IT
SHORT HOW TO GET YOU TO LUNCH I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR CONVENING
THIS HEARING TODAY YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND MOVING THIS
CONVERSATION FORWARD. A CLEARLY
THIS IS OF HUGE IMPORTANCE TO
BOTH OUR STATE ECONOMY AS WELL
AS TO ALL OF THE STUDENTS THAT
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT TODAY THE
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS WERE
GRADUATING READY FOR COLLEGE
DOING WHAT THEY'RE TOLD. AND NOT
HAVING A SEAT FOR THEM ON THE
OTHER END AT THE FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS A LAST YEAR THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
PRODUCED A REPORT CARD BUT HOW
ARE STATES DOING IN CLOSING THE
ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION.
GAP OF THE NUMBER OF COLLEGE
GRADUATES WE NEED TO MEET THE
WORKFORCE DEMANDS OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE OF THE REPORT CARD
IS NOT. A THE KIND THAT A PARENT
WOULD WANT TO PUT ON THE
REFRIGERATOR. THAT STATE A
AVERAGE IN MATH AND HOW WE'RE
DOING TO CLOSE THAT GAP WE LOOK
AT. OUR COLLEGE PREPARATION
ACCESS COMPLETION AND AND
AFFORDABILITY.
AND WE HAVE A NUMBER OF.
MECHANISMS WITHIN EACH OF THOSE
BUCKETS THAT WE THINK WILL
REALLY MOVE THE NEEDLE AND
HELPING MORE STUDENTS GET IN AND
THROUGH. I'M OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THAT THANK YOU
AGAIN AND I'M APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND I'LL BE A
PATH IN THIS AROUND TOO. FOLKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MCCARTY
TREM MEDINA MEMBERS.
MARIO GUERRERO BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION I
JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT AS THE
PP I SEE ESTIMATED WE ARE
LOCKING OVER ONE MILLION
GRADUATE SHORT.
BY TWENTY THIRTY AND WE HOPE
THAT IT'S NOT LOST ON
LEGISLATORS ARE THAT THE CSU
TURNED AWAY THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
QUALIFIED STUDENTS THIS PAST
YEAR DUE TO FUNDING. THIS TREND.
WILL ONLY GET WORSE WITHOUT
ACTION.
TOWARDS THE VERY END OF THE
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER
ADMINISTRATIVE GOVERNORSHIP AND
THROUGH THE TENURE OF GOVERNOR
BROWN BOTH THE CSU AND THE SUIT
AND THAT YOU SEE HAVE A BEGUN
TURNING AWAY TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF QUALIFY CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
ANNUALLY.
THIS IS A CRISIS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL WELL BEING. AS YOU'RE
AWARE THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
UNDER FUNDING THE CSU WITH
NINETY TWO MILLION.
DOLLARS WHILE THE CSU REQUESTED
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION.
ARE SEE AFFAIRS RECOMMENDING
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION.
OUR REQUEST OF REQUESTED FUNDING
LEVEL WILL INCREASE.
STUDENT ADMISSIONS BY MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS EVEN
WITH THIS AMOUNT.
WE WOULD STILL BE TURNING AWAY
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
SEE AFFAIRS REPORT. EQUITY
INTERRUPTED HAS SHOWN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM EDUCATES A FAR MORE
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY.
TODAY THAN IT DID THIRTY YEARS
AGO AND THAT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR HAS INCREASED
WHILE A PUBLIC FUNDING FOR THE
CSU HAS DECREASED AS I A CHAIR
MEDINA MENTIONED.
SO IN CLOSING.
TO CLOSE THE DEGREE GAP WE
SHOULD START BY ENSURING THAT
ALL OF THE QUALIFY CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS. ACTUALLY GET ADMITTED
TO A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR THE YEAH THAT
THE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT CHAIRMAN
DEAN AND I WANT TO THANK THE ARE
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN A WHERE
KNOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
NO EASY ANSWERS.
TO TO THESE ARE QUESTIONS WE
KNOW IT'S GONNA TAKE.
A OUT PARTNERSHIP AND AT THE CUT
COLLECTED STEPPING UP OUR GAME
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PUTTING MORE RESOURCES ON THE
TABLE TO THE STATE BUDGET
PROCESS BUT ALSO. OUR PARTNERS
FOR THIS THREE SYSTEMS PLUS OUR.
ARE A PRIVATE COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES ARE WORKING WITH US
AND SO I ONE THING THAT WE ONE
AT. THAT POTENTIALLY LOOK AT
THIS SPRING IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS IS HELPING FURTHER OUT
MAP BALLOTS.
A PLAN AS FAR AS I'M SOME GOALS
AND METRICS AS FAR AS HOW WOULD
ADDRESS.
THIS.
PACIFIC WAIT
MR MEDINA.
NO CLOSING STATE OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I WANT